this is Joo podcast number 408 with Echo
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Eko good
evening I dropped my Gilly blanket and
started heading toward the road right
after they passed my location my partner
motioned on the radio that he had pulled
out on the road and was pulling up
behind the vehicle once I got to the
road I saw them put their vehicle in
reverse and RAM my partner's vehicle now
it was game on and we knew we were in
for a fight with
kids just then and unbelievably they put
their Jeep into drive and sped directly
for me when they were about a 100 yards
away I lifted my rifle and started to
pie off to the right to make sure that
if I had to engage I would not be
shooting through the vehicle and
accidentally hit my
partner I did not want to engage
juveniles but they were speeding up and
I thought I might have to I also knew
that if I shot shot the driver I then
had to find a place where I could jump
to safety and not get run
over as I was taking my weapon off safe
and getting ready to engage the driver
and the passenger both jumped out of the
Jeep and tumbled from the vehicle while
it was still in motion thank God my
partner was able to grab the female and
I was able to snatch the
male we called for
backups and the Cavalry came
so that right there is an excerpt from a
new book that is out called borderline
defending the home front written by
Vincent Roco Vargas uh book that I had
the honor of publishing and writing the
forward to Vince was a border patrol
agent he was a member of borar which is
the part of border patrol special
operations
it's their search and rescue
unit and he served at the boorder of
Patrol Special Operations
group and also as a medic on the bortac
team and before any of that he was a
ranger by God and the US Army the 75th
Ranger regiment where he fought in both
Iraq and
Afghanistan he's a father with seven
kids and now he's also a writer an actor
a producer a musician a business owner
and it's an honor to have him with us
here tonight to talk about his
experiences and Lessons Learned Rocco
hello what's up
man pretty epic run you've been on in
life yeah yeah I keep hearing that it's
it's kind of crazy like as I started you
know I I I read well I've known you for
I don't know how many years but maybe
six or seven years something like that
seven years at least yeah so I've known
you and like oh cool ranger oh cool uh
oh border patrol for a little bit you
know you just you just you know hear
little things but man when I got done
wrapping this up and I started to kind
of assemble in my head your life like
the the the pathway of your life it's
been a it's been a wild ride man it's
been a wild ride yeah and it's
impressive man it's impressive
everything you've done and what you've
been up to it's it's badass man so and
now you're going to be a bestselling
author which is pretty cool too I'm
shooting for it yeah you got to got to
check that one off the list right um
let's let's just jump into this start I
guess start from the beginning um of
your life and you you say here in the
book uh my father this is like literally
the beginning of the book my father
Carlos Vargas was a former Marine he
came from nothing living in the Bronx
and then moved to Echo Park in Los
Angeles when he was 14 my father made
some of what he would call knucklehead
choices that ultimately resulted in him
joining the
military uh he turned his life around
from a street kid to a Jarhead
eventually translating what he learned
in the service into a career in the Los
Angeles Fire Department his work ethic
and fierce love for his family
intimidated but also inspired me I had
much to live up to and failure was never
an option yeah so your dad your dad's
Puerto Rican right he is is that right
so he's like a old school Bronx Puerto
Rican yeah yeah yeah he seriously tough
dude tough dude he actually when he
moved to LA the what I'll explain there
because I didn't want to explain too
much about like back I don't know I
wasn't sure I wanted the book to be like
a bual book so I was kind of skimming
over life but my father moved to LA uh
at a young age of 14 because they were
kind of one going running away from the
abusive father he had he was kind of a a
my grandfather was a drunk kind of
abusive man as my grandmother would try
and get away they keep going further
further west eventually they end up in
LA and uh he's in the streets of eeko
Park and you know his friends were were
Mexican kids because there was no Puerto
Ricans at the time in LA right there
were the very there very few it was them
right his whole family and uh he got
involved in kind of the gang world and
and the gangs back then it wasn't gang
banging it was more like territorial you
know if they got in fights it was with
you know belts or or pipes and uh one
day he was going to go kind of visit a
girl on the wrong side of the tracks
kind of thing and uh you know they they
tried to they almost got jumped and he
pulled out a pipe and he hit a couple
dudes with it uh he dropped the pipe and
ran the cops came he got arrested and he
had a choice to uh join the Marines or
go to jail what year was what year was
was he in the Marine Corps it was uh
just the ending of the Vietnam era so he
joined he said in basic training they
made the announcement that the Vietnam
War is Over so he received the Vietnam
campaign for joining at the time but he
never went to Vietnam there was a
conversation we just had the the other
day he goes you have any have any I just
I just missed it I was like damn dad I
get I know how he I guess I would know
how he feels he feels you know he wanted
to see it so yeah that was my dad's era
yeah you always got to be thankful cuz
you never know you never know like he
might have shipped off and that's that
yeah no no Vinnie a
couple yeah I remember a couple calls
and he was like Vinnie can I go to Iraq
with you you you think I can get on a
plane I'm like what are you talking
about dude he just uh he was always in
for the fight but just a good dad and
then your mom your mom's Mexican right
she is yeah she is she's from she was
born in canoo Texas which is like a
small corner of El Paso right before you
get into New Mexico for Anthony New
Mexico and uh where she was you know
where she was born in in in that little
city it's like everyone kind of stays
there kind it's almost seems like the
world has passed it up 20 20 years you
know where when my grandmother passed
away um the cousins all dug the hole and
when when we carried her we carried her
from from the from the place of the
church to the final resting place the
grave site you know we lowered her into
the to the hole and then I was the first
one to dig the dig the dirt and put it
back and the family sits there watching
the grandkids fill the hole and it's
this kind of old school tradition thing
that like you don't see anymore I
remember hearing the the sand fall to
her like it's a tin casket and I was
just like Jesus this is [__] crazy
and so yeah man we we we we we covered
her up with dirt and to find a wrestling
spot next to my grandfather and my uncle
who were buried in the same spot so yeah
it's just kind of this old school area
and then at 18 she decided to move to LA
and try and do something different and
get out of the kind of the the monotony
of the of the city of what what everyone
kind of went to a caner or they picked
fruit or you know same kind of kind the
Mexican kind of thing and and so then
your dad ends up in the fire department
yeah he he became an LA City firefighter
was he was a construction worker for a
little while uh it was a heavy rain
season and he went to go file for an
unemployment and then he saw the sign
that said you know hiring LA City
Firefighters and my dad was like well
let's do it so my mom and him stayed up
stayed up late studying for the test and
you know she helped him study for every
single test and he got through it and he
know these gang tattoos right so he had
a couple cover a couple of them and and
they called him tattoo that was like his
whole nickname cuz back then it wasn't a
lot of people with tattoos you know what
I mean so they called him tattoo and
yeah he made it through and and I
remember the change in our life I
remember going from this we had a
two-bedroom house in in this small area
in La kind of like R area and then uh I
remember we bought this house that was
like in a kind of like a urban area that
it l it looked like we we moved up right
we moved up in the world and we we now
me now we had a three-bedroom house
right and my brother and we shared room
before it was four kids in one room it
was two bunk beds you know what I mean
the boys bunk bed the girls bunk bed now
I was like me and my brother we shared a
room and eventually my dad remodeled the
house and we all had our own room it's
actually the same house I stayed in the
whole time I was filming mines yeah was
in my room damn yeah at my uh we were
having our fourth kid and so we needed
another room so I took my son's house
which or my son's room which was a
converted garage like we I converted the
garage into a room for him cuz we had
the two girls living in one room my wife
and I had a room and then we had this
other kid my son we're like all right we
need a room for him so we made that the
garage into a room and then we have a
daughter another daughter coming so I
just cut that room in half so it was
like two prison two prison cells
like it was my son could touch both
sides like when he would lay down he
could touch both sides if he put his
hands out so hey man you got to kind of
do what you got to do you got to get
through it so you you remember the days
when your dad was working construction I
remember the change of Lifestyles I
remember you know we had this small
little house and I remember just little
glimpses of it and then I remember the
the kind of the move up you're like big
time I felt it I felt the difference now
I mean I remember the struggle from that
point on until my parents started to
manage money better or just kind of
figure it out I guess but I remember
yeah man I remember the whole change
yeah you're going to be digging out of
like debt too right like you you buy a
house like you're in debt you you're you
just you spent all your money every last
dollar and it takes like a couple years
to recover from that yeah I remember in
high school when I noticed like oh we're
doing all right as I remember I remember
the change is like oh I can tell my
parents are doing good you know what I
mean they're both worked right my mother
was a she worked as a like a secretary
for the LA Unified School District you
know so so was one of those things where
they both parents worked they were doing
their thing we played Sports and we kind
of were on autopilot at a certain age
and I I remember like oh man the parents
are doing pretty good with money right
now and were you attracted to trouble at
all no man I saw a lot of it I was I was
always a fighter I was always willing to
fight but I honestly stayed so involved
in sport my dad had me so involved in
sports there was no excuse for anything
I didn't have time I played year round
Sports no matter what I remember telling
my dad like at 12 I'm like Dad I'm done
I don't want to play Sports Go well then
you're going to come home you're going
to you're going to clean this you're
going to do this you're you know I'm
like [__] that list of [__] I'm going
back to sports and so you know my
brother got got involved in some some
some kind of the street stuff the street
life when you grew up in LA in the 90s
it was you were either involved in gangs
or you some kind of sports and I took
the athlete route and I had a lot of
like old-timer dudes in my world who
were just like keep doing it you know
what I mean I felt like I had the
blessing of a couple people that were
big gang members in the area just like
keep doing it man we're proud of you and
I'm like oh [__] well keep sing of
trouble stay out of the [__] and and
keep playing sports and how good were
you at sports was good enough I wasn't
great like I didn't get you know I was
bad at education right I was bad at
reading and so I was going to go as far
as that can take me you know um I went
to Junior College to play baseball
because it was the only opportunity I
had because I didn't take the I I I
failed the PSATs I'm telling you I
probably got my name right it was
probably the only thing I got you know
what I mean so once I failed that one I
was like well there's no [__] point
wasting money on the actual SATs so
let's just go to Junior College and
Junior College had an opportunity where
if you did really well in junior college
you can get go to Pro anyway so I was
like what a good chance let's just try
and figure that out I got in trouble a
little bit and um I ended up finding
myself going to Northern to uh Northern
California to Chico to play some summer
ball out there with some friends and
that got me a full ride to Kentucky to a
school in Kentucky called brush
University and uh I became academically
ineligible there and just joined the
military be K you know yeah yeah I did
some tried independent Pro I tried all
kinds of weird stuff and yeah the
military call so so hold on so you you
get to College you're playing ball in
college yeah so you got freaking skills
yeah and yet you just academically
ineligible you just not going to classes
or I could I couldn't read man I
graduated high school with like a fifth
grade reading level I was dyslexic but
we never it was no one ever told us that
you know what I mean my mom hired like a
a Reading Coach for a while and just
couldn't get couldn't figure it out um
read coach was like Hey ma'am your son's
dumb I'm sorry that's all like like I
would not be able to focus long enough
to get it done it was high school time
where like if you were good at sports
and you showed up every day you'd get a
c you know what I mean and so like I was
good at sport my sister was my twin
sister I have a twin sister right we're
in the same class together I just sat
there and read baseball books or tried
to like do whatever I could to kill the
time she did everything she got a B I
got a C and she's like what the [__]
yeah yeah I was just good enough you
know they mention your name you're like
oh Vince had you know this three hits
and two stolen bases in the morning you
know so like you're the man yeah I was
good enough to people knew
that so then how long was it before you
get well well uh you're in college when
did when was September 11th I was in
Juni I was in junior college at Glendale
Community College at the time and uh I
was waking up to get ready for class and
my mom said I heard her kind of a
screech of like Vinnie like scared
Screech and I was like so I come out my
room I was like what's up M and I she's
watching TV just Frozen and the first
plan already hit and it's live and I see
the second plane hit and I was like
what's that like what happened like in
my head was like just a a plane accident
right and we're just watching she goes I
think we're being attacked and I was
like what it was like the first thought
like we it's when you really didn't know
what the [__] was going on and the first
thought was like someone's attacking us
I'm like I'm confused as [__] my dad's
LA City firefighter so he's already at
work and uh he's like Vinnie I don't
know if you should go go to school I uh
but I think I had like a baseball game
or something I was like I was like I'm
going to go to school you know what I
mean and I think when I got to school I
saw everyone else's kind of Expressions
about it and thoughts and that's when I
really just started seeing how like
heavy that was and that's when I was
like [__] dude am I gonna have to join
the military and that's what I thought I
thought we were all going to have to
just join um but the dream of like
baseball was like we'll keep doing this
we'll see what happens keep we'll see
what happens um and I I remember it was
like the second day the day after
America was like super like patriotic
and like nice you know mean you're and
people are like usually not nice about
driving everyone's like oh yeah you can
cut in who gives a [__] you know we're
all Americans you know and I was down in
ventur Boulevard and uh we used to just
go there to hang out and um there was
this like a makeshift [__] parade
like people with with flags and honking
their horns and everyone's like
patriotic and all a sudden [__] like
Oprah there interviewing people and all
this like it was was crazy and I was
that I remember me and my buddy were
dumbass College we spray painted our
bodies red white and blue and we're just
like I felt it man I felt like the
I felt every the energy of like everyone
kind of coming together and it was like
a really beautiful beautiful moment and
I've never been this like gungho
patriotic person it wasn't something
like my dad he's military we love
America I never thought anything more
than that and that was probably the
first time I was like damn this is heavy
it was heavy man I remember I'll never
forget that day it's just like [__]
should I join and uh I didn't yet not
yet so you so now you get at going to
this College in Kentucky
yeah
and there you don't you don't your
grades aren't good I guess how long have
you going there for for a year but I I
failed out of Ceramics is what got me
dude what is Ceramics is that like
making clay pots and stuff
yo yeah I I kept bro everything I said
about you being
awesome I I'm trying not to tell you
everything dude failed you're going to
lose all respect soon don't
worry yeah dude [__] I kept the
transcript cuz I'm like [__] that's
going to be a story one day I'm sure but
you know every other grade was like a c
a c a c so I was like doing good enough
and then I I didn't drop out of I didn't
drop the class in time and so I was
trying to drop the class in time I
overslept one day I missed the drop
deadline boom that affects your grade
didn't even need the [__] class right
it was just like an extra class but it
put me under a 2.0 which made me
ineligible and lose my full ride dang
yeah dude yeah so I got a job at Texas
Roadhouse and I was like well [__]
what's next and then I had I had a baby
dude I forgot I had my baby at the same
like around the same time and I was like
[__] what the [__] I'm going to do who's
paying for the baby I mean so the baby's
mom my ex who who eventually became my
ex-wife but the baby's mom uh she was
doing everything I was asking my mom
like can you just drop off some diapers
can you get him some where she was she
in LA or La yeah yeah so my mom would
like drop off some some some money yeah
and dude I was raised by cool parents
and to say parents like I was raised
knowing I wanted to be a parent right
like it was a cool environment man we
had four of us right kids and we'd play
we we be competitive with each other so
I never had a doubt in my mind I wanted
to be a dad but like the way it happened
was UN not unexpected so much but like
of when you're 21 years old you're like
[__] dog now what you know I got no
money from me you know I'm put myself in
I I didn't need the money for college
but i' still took out a loan just I
could P pay for beers like dumb [__]
like
that yeah and so then I knew knew um I
tried to figure out what was next um I I
I applied for some like opportunities to
go try for some independent pro teams
those never panned out because I was
just a I was just a party animal kid uh
I got an opportunity to play it was
professional in Germany for like the I
think it was the Rockford Rockman
Richmond roosters or something but they
said I couldn't take my daughter at the
time and so I didn't want that like that
didn't feel right uh I was at Buffalo
Wild Wing sitting next to a Navy
who who would tell me stories about the
military and we were watching uh the
news and it was that time where that
Marine was putting the flag over
saddam's statue and they pulled it down
they were interviewing his family man
and his family was like crying and all
happy and proud of him dude and I was
like [__] I don't think my family's ever
looked at me like that you know what I
mean I've just always been like a just
kind of the I've always felt like my mom
was always like ah Vinnie don't get in
trouble ah Vinnie don't get hurt oh
Vinnie you know what I mean I've always
been like like the the fear of my mom is
like I'm going to [__] something up you
know what I mean because I was just a
mischievous dude and uh that's when
that's when I kind of knew I was like
all right everything's [__] not going
the right way my brother said he gave me
he's like may maybe you should join the
military help Dad maybe so I went to the
recruiting office and um I went to the
Marines first because I thought my dad
would be proud if I join the Marines and
he was like [__] no don't join the
Marines I was like I I think it was his
way he knew the War was happening he was
scared for me he's like don't join the
Marines dude and my mom's like don't
join the Navy I think she had a family
member or a cousin or something that
joined the Navy and it was sexually like
molested raped or whatever and so she
was like don't do that I was like I'm
not going to let that happen mom I'm
going to fight but either way I remember
so those two were out for me like and I
even went to the Navy to be like I I'd
do Navy Seals but D they didn't have
contracts guys like no you can be an
underwater welder and we could put in
your contract I was like n that don't
sound cool at all [__] that so that's a
good move you did didn't want to listen
to that recruit he was lying to you um
so then the I was actually waiting for
my ride to pick me up in the Army
recruiter um say what are you doing here
I was like I was just thinking about
joining the military so come to my
office God you look like a steak to him
he sees like a lost 21y old kid bro he's
like yo what are you doing here my
friend in decent shape just sitting
there no ride he's like you [__] got
you bro pulled me right in he said you
know we got a $20,000 bonus I was like
oh bro like [__] I'm down I was like
what's the hardest thing you have he
said Army Ranger or special
forces and like special force the only
thing I ever heard right I knew Army
Ranger I don't know much about any of
these I just knew Special Forces sounded
really dope and I was like well I'd love
to do that so I took the tests and I got
a 108 GT score which put me two points
below what was mandatory for SF and they
didn't have a twoo waiver at the time
later they did when I was in basic
training I'm like [__] dog but um so I
said yeah I'll do our Ranger and so they
found me an option 40 contract and uh I
had no idea what I was getting into I
just knew like Ranger cool and I watched
Blackhawk Down I was like [__] yeah this
is rad let's let's check this out you
know then I watch banded brothers and I
was like dude I gotta go I'm ready man
so I got excited about
it how long was it before be between
signing the dotted line and shipping out
six months okay so I got two credit
cards maxed them out just CU I was just
a dumbass like I'm going to die in IR
wck anyways let's just do this and I
started drinking like a mother everyone
drinks at the [__] bars and [__] went
home to see my my daughter um and uh
yeah man just waited for that ship out
dat how was uh boot camp and all that it
was cool um never in my life did
anything like that never expected it U
my dad was pretty tough dude and so none
of it intimidated me they couldn't put
their hands on me so I was like I don't
give a [__] dude like this is whatever I
was kind of older 23 years old so I'm
kind of babysitting a lot of these
[__] young Knuckleheads on how to do
like don't quit [__] getting me in
trouble dude you know what I mean like
there was a lot of teaching them how to
max out their credit cards
there's a lot of threatening going on in
the Barrack between several of us older
dudes and the young ones and uh yeah it
was like a group of older dudes like one
was a you know there was an older dude
who was like [__] 32 or something
like that and he was a he was a
firefighter daveid kahill and I remember
the drill song I was like he's like
why'd you join he goes cuz he was from
New York and he's like cuz those
[__] killed some of my [__]
friends and he goes what [__] it took
you so long and I was like damn damn we
were all like this [__] is Rowdy
dude and she he had com about all of us
that were older you know what I mean
like what the [__] took you so long you
know and uh it was an experience man it
it wasn't as hard as I I imagined I
actually learned a lot about myself
didn't know I I'd be able to run as well
as I did I never was like this distance
Runner anyways and it turned into like
oh I can run pretty good I got in really
good shape I started filling out like
like bigger I didn't realize like I
would be gaining weight in basic
training essentially kind of filling out
some muscles um and then I found out
that everyone had a ranger contract the
whole [__] platoon had a ranger
contract I was like oh [__] I thought it
was just like one and I got it you know
like no it's all of us and so I started
learning asking those guys questions and
they were telling me like yeah dude you
got to go through this then you got to
go to Airborne you got to go to rip and
they're going to try and make you quit
I'm like oh [__] no way well [__] let's
do it you know and you know air got the
Airborne and that was that was just
Airborne it's not not that challenging
Airborne yeah it sucks to jump out of a
plane but like at the same time like
well if this was going to get to Rangers
fine uh and then rip was cool man rip
was a [__] kicking the nuts but all
in all like I just kept looking for like
what's going to [__] could make me quit
MH I don't know and I didn't want to
quit cuz like I have a daughter and like
I want to see her I want to see her
proud of me and I want I think of her
watching me across some kind of stage in
her being real proud of her dad receive
an award whatever it was it was just in
my vision I had I carried with me
everywhere and then my dad I couldn't
say I quit cuz I feel like my dad would
be like the [__] like you know what I
mean like you know and so like those are
the two people that really motivated me
like to keep going and and it just
continued throughout my career was those
those two and my kids you know my kids
multiplying mhm and how long is Rip
Rip's not that long right I think it's 3
weeks I think it's only 3 weeks and the
biggest part of rip was called coal
range and it's like they take you out
into the field you do some Land
Navigation and then when you're when
you're if you pass Land Navigation at
night they just [__] you up until you
[__] try and make you quit and um
it's just over and over and over and
then that's usually where you lose the
the most people you got your PT test you
got a five b run and then you got like
just all the smoke sessions in between
but cold range is where you lose a lot
of people and they do the whole thing
where like pays to be a winner you know
run a mile and they [__] they [__]
you up and then if you don't you're not
first well then you [__] keep going
and I mean this will last all night and
uh that's when people quit and then you
know you have a poncho and you're cold
as [__] and people are like afraid to
cuddle so you're like all right dude
[__] you I'll cuddle up you know and so
people just quit and that's where you
you lose a lot of guys from that yeah
it's weird I always when I figured this
out when I learned this that in well to
go to Ranger regiment and be a ranger at
Ranger regiment you don't have to go to
Ranger school a lot of people don't know
that you have to go through rip which is
3 weeks long so you're like a well at
this point you were 23 but some kids in
Rangers they're like 18 years old and
they're at ranger battalion like I had a
lot of dudes man I had a lot of dudes
who showed up in their 18-year-old
Knuckleheads but they were willing to
[__] endure that suck Fest so we're
like cool they're they're they're one of
us now I think that's the cool thing
about range of regiment too is that we
we get to raise our our privates we get
to raise those soldiers and we raise
them exactly how we want them and the
same thing I showed up as a 23-year-old
that's still treated like nobody and
they train you to be the type of Ranger
that you want they want you to be shoot
where I shoot go where I go do what I do
you know and don't [__] question it
or else you get [__] up yeah and
that's what we we raise dudes who do
that and that's what what makes Ranger
regiment what it is yeah and Rangers
like most people don't stay in Ranger
for a long time because it's a tough
like Spartan life yeah it's hard to find
dudes who've done the full four and been
successful I want to say it's hard I
said it's those guys you you give a
little bit more of a tilt of the cap too
like oh [__] yeah the dude did his four
and he got his ranger have and he became
a team leader because a lot of dudes
that do two and they get kicked out for
drinking reasons for uh RFS Rel leased
for standards right we have a certain
standards you have to meet and so
there's guys get kicked out in one year
two year three it doesn't matter because
it's a [__] challenging lifestyle
it's a challenging lifestyle for
families a lot of guys have drinking
issues and fight you know whatever it is
it's not easy to to run that pace and
still trying to be a normal person
outside that with a marriage or or
relationship as well as trying to manage
your drinking because it's kind of the
culture as well in our little in L world
so we fight we [__] we drink and yeah
it's Madness dude I met a dude one time
and he had been at like Ranger regiment
for like 19 years or something and this
is when I was younger but this dude
looked like he had nothing else like he
was literally in the I was I was on an
army base and he was in the the like PX
or whatever and he's wearing like Ranger
panties a ranger t-shirt and like
running shoes and like high and tight
and he looks like just there's nothing
in his life except for just Ranger and I
was like Yep this dude's this is a hard
dude you know if you I ended up talking
to him he's like he I've been at Ranger
rang for 19 years or something crazy
like that and I was like this dude's cuz
you know in the SEAL Teams like dude
it's a hard job and then you get like
cool stuff and you hang out and you have
a lot of autonomy right Rangers like if
you're an 18-year-old right if you're a
20-year-old seal you're you got all
kinds of autonomy you know you they're
like just make sure you're in
shape uh you know make sure you show up
they're not like this what're like in
the in the Rangers it's like show up
we're going to jump at whatever 6
o'clock in the morning show up at 2
o'clock in the morning so we can start
inspecting and checking everything they
don't play around they don't play around
well because we're raising knucklehead
kids that don't know [__] so you have to
be like very precise with everything but
you'll show up on a Monday be like all
right we're going to go for a five my
run we're going to swim across the lake
and we're can come back and go home
you're like what the [__] for it doesn't
matter we're just training
yeah it's just what we do yeah respect
dude Rangers don't play around um so you
get through all that stuff I'm going to
jump to the book here real quick you say
once arriving to my unit I had learned
so much about myself already I was 23y
old private first class and I was
becoming a well-rounded professional
Soldier more than just a baseball player
within 45 days of joining ranger
battalion I Was preparing to deploy to
Afghanistan while in Afghanistan I
wasn't if I wasn't on a mission eating
cow or in the gym I had nothing to do
but think fast forward a little bit
while one day while sitting in a squad
room in Afghanistan a few of us started
talking about what we wanted to do after
we got out of the army I mentioned the
fire department everyone had their
normal copper firefighter career
aspirations and no one said anything out
of the ordinary until staff sergeant
Ricardo barazza am I saying that right
barza spoke up and simply said border
patrol he told us they had Special
Operations units and a huge budget for
training it's the closest thing to being
an Army Ranger but doing it in the
civilian world he said with a flourish
so this is on your first
deployment uh staff sergeant barza is
the first person that makes you think
about border patrol how's that first
deployment to
Afghanistan I was nervous man I didn't
know what to [__] expect I think
that's what the fear was like what the
[__] what's GNA happen and what I don't
mention in the book is that I just got
to Battalion when Pat Tilman was killed
so I'm dealing with that as a [__]
brand new private and like seeing the
chaos of that [__] dude dude
coming back [__] up from that the
whole backlash from [__] Pat Tillman
he's in my company the platoon is second
platoon I'm in first platoon so like it
was so close to us as new guys we were
like Jesus [__] dude and they're like
hey get your stuff ready we're going
overseas what was the how long did it
take for you to start hearing like that
that was a fratricide within five days
showing up to Battalion we're in
formation they're like hey we're going
to be Garden of the gates we had our DCU
to go back to meet him so we're supposed
to be the reach brick to meet that meet
that platoon meet those guys
and when that went down it was just like
shut it down we're just you guys are
just pulling security and answering
phones and it was like we're started
hearing what happened and then boom the
news and then we had we had a a
formation we're in the rear d right rear
detachment and they talked about like
hey this is what you're going to say to
anyone that calls here's the you know we
have a thing and that's when we all
started talking like what the [__] went
down dude and then that's you know I had
to pick up um you know Pat to's brother
and we just kind of started escorting
dudes around and helping get their stuff
and some guys were getting RFS and just
[__] it was just like not enough was
said because we're just kind of new
we're nobody's but like you started
hearing everyone else talk and it was
like this is crazy I don't know the [__]
and I I started learning everything from
the news I was like these dudes ain't
talking to me because I'm nobody you
know what I mean all they would do is
[__] us up because we were new and I
guess they were angry and uh when they
got back they we got [__] up even more
it was crazy it's crazy and then we get
deployed you know no one still talks to
us because we're privates Train Train
shut the [__] up let's go and you're
like this is [__] nuts dude yeah and
you got to be thinking like if this can
happen to Pat Tillman yeah like who am I
it was crazy Vinnie over here getting
ready to get Vinnie nobody yeah damn
Vinnie big chin and uh yeah dude I
remember I remember talking to one of
the platoon HS and he's like you nervous
I'm like yeah yes sir and he was like
well don't worry about it you know 90%
of the time you're just going over there
you know you might not see combat you
know 10% ever ever engage with uh he's
give me these numbers I'm like okay this
sounds good and I remember one of the
first deployments were like Fast roping
in and [__] there's there's like
they're getting fir on their helicopter
you're like oh [__] dude what to the
[__] odds dude I saw dude's crawling
dude and I was like oh everyone's
getting shot and uh we roped in and he
was just like no dude people are
breaking their ankles on the fast rope
and it's just like yeah it's like oh
[__] Bro the fash was [__] taken to
do that but my thought is like I don't
want to go dude dude's getting [__]
hit I'm carrying three Goose off rounds
in the back of me don't hit me yeah
man
yeah yeah and so what was your what was
your mission on that like what was your
kind of standard Mission set on that
first deployment to Afghanistan it was
it the same as kind of the ROM but it
wasn't as active as as
so I I I'll explain it like our job has
always been like kind of raids and like
how do you gather that Intel is just
however we get it and obviously me being
a nobody was just like hey there's Intel
in this area we're going to go try and
uh kill or capture this individual same
kind of thing like TSD targets or
whatever the case um and so we go into
these missions but they were they were
not as often as they eventually became
because Intel got better but as well as
how we gathered the Intel you know my
first appointment 2004 the only thing
that you would kind of secured from an
objective was like an embitter phone and
that was like rare if you found one
you're like dope dude we got an embitter
by 2005 in Iraq there was cell phone
towers everyone everyone had a cell
phone so then the missions came like
dude soon as you scrub someone's [__]
cell phone you had like 20 other dudes
you need to go hit you know what I mean
so that that changed that the whole op
Tempo changed when technology changed
for them it helped us and so 2004 you
know we were just had a few missions
here and there more a lot of training
going on a lot of like getting ready for
for the thing but you know just a few
missions here and there but it was
wasn't like IAQ and you guys are doing
four month deployments yes okay yeah
uh any major like lesson learned about
that from that deployment where you like
dude I'm never doing that
again the whole thing was like I there
was one mission where we went to a high
point and um I was using just binocular
I'm a nobody AG guy for the goo off I'm
like the ab AG guy right so I'm just
like staying out of the [__] way and
I remember just like scanning the
objective area and I'm like he AR uh I
think we got dudes on a roof
and he's like let me see he had a big
ass dip and he let me see and he goes
[__] yeah we did so he calls I remember
he calls on the radio he calls to the to
to the we had a Fister on the ground but
he also had a Fister that was flying
with Spectre gunship and uh they see it
they're like yeah and they were like sir
what do you wants to do he's like load
round so we I loaded a [__] round
dude and I'm like [__] he we're about
to goo off this [__] dog you
know what mean I've already fired like
15 in practice and training and so I'm
like this is dope and it's going to be
scary let's go I close it I close it the
ventry close it and I'm just and they're
like do we fire like what do we do you
know what I'm saying and he's going on
the radio and supposedly they called
fire but the radio communication was
[__] so then by the time it came back
to us like hold fire hold fire and the
team started pushing in on them and we
didn't find out until after I was like
what happened he like I know they told
us not to fire then we have to take it
out and that's to me it's like even
scared like God I got to take this
[__] round back out put right back
into my [__] ruck sack and then uh
the cool moment was like the PLS like
there's people kind of approaching from
the back from the rear like one of the
houses woke up people were kind
he's like give me one and I just jumped
up like let's go and I started running
with him and we're lazing it and seeing
all these people come out and eventually
the turf came in and kind of calmed it
all down but I was like [__] dude we're
really doing this [__] dog like that's
like really in the middle of this like
[__] foreign ass country people know
who the [__] we are we're [__] fast
we're [__] it was just that was the
first like damn dude I'm actually doing
this [__] yeah what's crazy to me is
like you've probably been in the Army
for a year maybe maybe maybe maybe yeah
so you're like boot camp Airborne School
rip yeah some training with the with
your company and then boom you're on
deployment yeah I think I learned really
how to how to be an A and AG for the
[__] Goose off in deployment like
that was like the moment of really
learning because we trained so often and
then same like I was doing a lot of
ready ups and deployment dude just like
with they you nothing going on today
let's go boom they put exit on the wall
we're just ready up ready it's like 90%
of my skill sets was built in combat
there not in combat just training it was
like [__] nuts yeah sh yeah and did
you like the job I did I did I think
like in the book I said a lot of
thinking I thought like well [__] if I
applied myself I could have done so many
different things like not that I hated
what I was doing but I was ready for it
to be done like let me do my four years
and go out because I'm like now
motivated to [__] face the world like
I could do I thought I was a baseball
player and that's all I didn't think
there was more outside of my life so
when I lost baseball I was like I was
ready to kind of give up I like [__] all
this I've been playing baseball since I
was four years old year round since
seven like it's all I [__] knew like
when people struggle transitioning out
of the military I struggle transitioning
out of baseball so when I found the
military it's real yeah dude it's like
professional feels it over here
transition out of football for Echo
Charles yeah dude CU you're like what
the [__] am I you know and then when I
got to the military I found like oh I'm
kind of good at this too that's when I
was like all right this is cool but [__]
if I could be good at this what else
could I be good at so like yeah I was
sitting in my room thinking like [__]
what could I done what what else could I
What could I do and so that's what like
the conversation BR when he said uh
border patrol I was like the [__] is he
talking about never heard of these I've
heard of him but I I didn't know it was
even a thing that anyone would want uh
I'm GNA fast forward a little bit in the
book book is obviously I'm just reading
highlights just get the book so much
details and stories it's just a freaking
great book um on December 16th 2014 I
lost a CL close friend whom I had spent
a significant amount of time with in the
pipe line on the way to ranger battalion
Devin
buero died while participating in a live
fire
exercise yeah so this is like another
reality check you know yeah I came back
from that deployment and um so Devon was
with me in basic training and then
Airborne Airborne was so like laidback
that we thought our PT was not going to
be good enough for Ranger selection for
rip so we were like intentionally
[__] around so they would make us do
push-ups and we'd be like Ranger Ranger
like they we were pissing people off but
for us was like [__] it get smoked all
day let's get ready for Ranger you know
we got to rip and they gave us a weekend
before the PT test on the Monday and uh
we went out to Columbus like idiots you
know and we're drinking beers and we're
bullshitting and we're all talking to
like I was talking to my my baby's mom
he was talking to his girl and one of
our Knuckleheads from basic training he
goes I hear him tell a girl yeah yeah
we're Army ranges you know and I like
who the [__] is he talking to and
another dude turned around goes oh
really what company he said what Delta
company he goes we don't have a Delta
company and boom the fight broke out
dude and I'm like I gotta go and boom
trying to pull this dude out of there
but they had my card on on Tab like all
kinds of [__] went wrong so we ran the
[__] you know the MPS were [__]
chasing we jumped into the back of a
truck and we just lay there like hope
the [__] god they don't get us that
Monday morning we didn't realize this
but Devon's like dog and Devon pagero
right he's like dog I can't find my ID
card I was like what he go I think we
loost I think I lost it that on the on
the during the fight I was like what the
[__] bro they call him to the front of
the formation and uh he goes I lost my I
lost my ID card he goes yeah okay you're
recycled boom they kicked him out of the
course and I was like [__] me dude so I
didn't know if we were going to see him
ever again that's my boy you know what I
mean so I come back from this deployment
and I [__] run into him at the ch I'm
like Devon he goes yeah I [__] made
it I was like holy [__] he got recycled
again cuz he failed the [__] Five
Mile and then the next one he finally
made it boom he's in ready town with us
right he's in Charlie Company and so
we're trying to connect again about like
dude let's I'm I want you to meet my
daughter she's here now you know what I
mean I got married like let's like let's
let's have it he was supposed to come
over for dinner um but you know I had my
live fire Alpha Company did their live
fire and then his next day with Charlie
come doing their live fire the next day
he was supposed to come home for dinner
so that not of their live fire they gave
us a call you know they notified all of
us that someone was killed during
training but in the call they said
Figaroa and I was like Figaroa from
Charlie com I was like I don't I don't
know who that is I'll figure it out in
the morning I remember they woke me up
and I was like my wife times she's like
hey they're calling about someone an
incident I was like oh and I was like I
don't know the figure okay I got to when
I got to um when I got to Alpha Company
my buddy uh Solon Kim he he comes up to
me he's like bro did you hear I was like
yeah figure I don't know who that was
goes no dude it was Devin no was
like no dude say was F was like no dude
it was Devon and [__] we hugged it out
was like what the [__] happened and so
people started to tell us what was going
on and that was the first time like as a
as a man as a grown man like my emotions
I I wasn't sure how to handle that you
know what I mean I was raised obviously
by a tough dude that CME would be weak
in his world you know and as I was
getting home from the day and trying to
still piece it together as I was putting
the keys into the door I remember kind
of like shaking and it all kind of
overwhelmed me and and I just busted out
crying like holy
[__] and I told my wife like you know
that my friend I supposed to come over
for dinner tomorrow um he was the one
who was killed and it was just like a
shock to us like Jesus [__] how' he get
killed what happened so a lot of people
got RFS for that right they got released
for Standish for this um you know we're
doing a it's like a
paralleled live shoot and so you you go
clear and you go clear and you continue
right there's a big gap between the the
two buildings and sometimes you only use
one building and you have these targets
that every time you engage they were
kind of falling over and so you reset
them and I guess the range safety
officer wasn't paying attention or the
offic whoever it was wasn't paying
attention to as they kept resetting they
kept shifting and it got to a point
where it reset in a spot where when it
shot and engaged and went through the
wall through the target through the wall
and hit him in the throat while he's
pulling Security in the other
room and so they they provided all the
medical they possibly could um um on the
in the van uh on the way to the hospital
they said they felt the release of his
hands and that's when he died on the way
there yeah and that one was a that one
was heavy for me because I was like you
know I've lost friends into gang
violence you know and I and it's kind of
like when you grow up an it's it's okay
but that one was like damn he didn't die
in combat he died training for it like
he wanted it and it [__] sucked man
that one that one
hurt
so you go through that and but you're
still on a workup and that's the thing
everybody six months later we're gone
you're still doing your job and you go
to Iraq the second one so what year is
this that's 2005 now 2005 you roll into
Iraq where were you in Iraq mosul okay
yeah we did the whole mosul thing we um
that was uh one of our most successful
deployments as a battalion you show up
there with like the the one dude in the
middle of the circle that you want to
get and then everyone else is kind of
like who can lead you to him um that was
mosul 2005 and and we we captured the
the top dog and it was like kind of a
weird how it worked so the Rangers will
go on the mission that day and we're
like TST targets right time sensitive
Target missions uh waiting for certain
certain Intel to drop and boom we're
we're on it so all of our kit was right
by our by our uh this when we first
started using Strikers and so all of our
kit was by the strikers and we're just
sitting there doing our thing getting
ready hashing it out getting ready for
it boom we get a call we're gone uh and
you can do one Mission you can do six
missions a day it doesn't matter it was
just kind of this crazy crazy thing but
the days we're off we were we were qrf
and we're qrf for Delta dudes right the
CAG dudes and so it was kind of like
we're were switching days and then there
was times we like hey we had a heavy day
last night can you guys do do TST today
and then we'll just pick up yeah like
yeah whatever and so as we started
getting closer and closer to this dude
you know they're they're wanting the
mission they want the big one you know I
mean so I remember one day they gave us
a day off like hey you guys are back on
qrf we're going to this was good Intel
we're probably going to try and catch
this dude and as we're all kind of
trying to get his dude by chance one day
we had dudes lay up in the house and we
were going to pick him up as we're going
to pick him up this dude shows up to the
house next door and so boom we hit the
house I remember we hit the house boom
Going In I walk right by like someone
snatched the dude already they grabbed
him up you know put him on his knees and
start cuffing him putting putting the
sandbag over we we use something
different at that one point I remember
going right past him like that's a big
ass [__] and kept going and room
clear Bo and then right you start
hearing the radio tra like hey we caught
the fat guy we were like [__] Homie we
got him and then phones went off and
then more Intel gathered and I mean that
night I think we did six missions it was
like boom boom boom boom boom cuz just
[__] started popping off right like
everyone was like I guess they were in
panic mode so they started messaging
each other and then we were able to pull
all that data and boom and you're you're
straight up assaulter yeah I'm a saw
Gunner at this time I'm a saw Gunner on
a team oh you're a saw Gunner and and
just getting after yeah yeah dude saw
Gunner like it was the best job in the
world bro it's like everybody wants you
in the room quick you know it's the team
was like go I'm like let's go and uh
yeah man it was a good good time mosul
was pretty pretty busy for us we had a a
lot of engagements we had um you know
the truck in front of us took an ID at
one point we had a hand grenade hit and
hit a couple of my dudes on on first
Squad while we were kind of like oh [__]
we ran over there and seeing the chaos
of that Madness um we had one of our
little birds on a mission got got
engaged on and and and the the pilot
luckily the Copa helped him pull it back
up and got out of there like so we had a
lot of like little interesting you know
just combat [__] man warship and it was
a it was a good experience it was uh
there was definitely that I tell people
like that's when I I kind of mended my
relationship with God you know as I as I
grew up I was kind of wasn't sure I I
was raised Catholic and then kind of
converted to Christianity when I was in
Kentucky and then from there I was kind
of like ah man my life is kind of going
to [__] so you start blaming God you
know I me like I lost my scholarship you
know I can't can't read my kid all this
things so I started getting angry with
God and then I was there I was like Yo
dude I want to be in my kids lives man
and and my my wife was pregnant at the
time I was like I want to see her be
born and and I want to be a dad and like
get me out of this dude and I'll I'll
[__] whatever you know what I mean like
what I actually I promised I'd wear a
suit to church I still haven't done this
[__] dog but um yeah man you might want
to straighten that out know I know every
time I say that I like I I get I got to
get my suit in the cleaners but um yeah
it was like the moment where there was
enough action happening enough [__] was
going down enough dudes were earning
their Purple Heart where I was like man
it's a numbers game now dude and um I
started getting trying to be right with
God and and before every Mission I was
kind of had my my piece we we talked and
and we do our mission and so that was
like my favorite deployment because the
most experience it just really we had a
lot of action going on at the time
yeah um fast forward a little bit here
you say in April 2005 after returning
from a deployment in Iraq I Was
preparing to be sent to Ranger school
the day before we left we played a
football game with the platoon Bar's
team versus mine because of my Comm
competitive nature I wanted to win so
damn bad but ra but barazza bazza's
competitive nature matched mine and his
team won after I was walking off pissed
he stopped me come here he said in his
deep cocky tone I hesitated in my
frustration Vargas come here he repeated
what's up Sergeant he snagged a ranger
tab off his cover handed it to me and
said come back with your [__] or don't
come back at
all we hugged and I walked it off a
still fuming but also shocked by the
gesture he cut off his own tab from his
cover and gave it to me this wasn't
something I'd ever seen anyone do it was
powerful I didn't want to let this man
down just i' like I'd never wanted to
let my father
down that's freaking
legit like someone giving you their
Ranger tab before you even go to Ranger
school that's when they they used to sew
it on so he had to cut it rip it off
just the Gest alone was like they call
it a drive on tab in ranger battalion
and I didn't know about this never heard
of it you know it was just drive on Tab
is like you look at that [__]
and you remember why you want this so
bad and you [__] come back with it or
don't come back at all and in Ranger
town if you don't pass Ranger school
you're gone anyway so I like get the
[__] out of here then you know and um so
that's actually a thing a drive on T
your tab to someone else I don't know if
it's necessarily giving it but I know
there's versions of that and there's
sometimes you have one people sew it
into their hat is like they look at it
right the drive on T it's like motivates
you to you want that someone like I
guess someone would do with a trident or
something I don't know but I it wasn't
the it was the first time I've ever
heard of it but by the time I got my
Ranger tab I've done it to someone as
well because I kind of continue that
tradition but I I've heard it's not
uncommon for it but for me I've never
seen that [__] and then for it to be
that guy Braza for me was like it was
like the leader that when I showed up to
Ranger toown I thought everyone was an
athlete you know me and then I showed up
and I was like [__] they're not athletes
they're just dudes that are willing to
do the job um and so that kind of was
like man I thought it was going to be
like [__] badass Rambo dudes and [__]
they could all fight they could all
[__] run they could all play sports
and no it wasn't the case um he was
though he was an athlete he was a big
bad [__] he was highly respected
and he was the dude that I looked at I
was like yeah I want to be like that
that's the dude and uh so for him to to
to take his own tab off his hat and give
it to me um was pretty special but I
[__] wanted to beat his ass so
goddamn bad dude I was [__] mad that
he won again yeah that's uh and you got
more about about barza in here so I'm
obviously not reading the whole book but
um it's freaking legit and that that
definitely was a powerful section Ranger
school any major challenges at Ranger
school yeah one but but um for the most
part you know it's pretty pretty lucky
you know um I was a distinguished on
graduate of the [__] school so I
never got really in trouble uh the one
time they gave everyone major nose I was
taking a piss and so they missed me you
know I mean like weird circumstances I
show up to [__] mountains phas it's
my same platoon s from Afghanistan who
told me those statistics and he goes hey
he got he got r fest for for some [__]
so he's like hey Vargas what the [__]
this guy's a stud this kid's a stud you
know so like all everyone's like hey
tell me about your deployments man he
said I'm like okay that's cool so like I
by chance I ran into different things
that kind of like I guess kind of helped
helped me through the way and just luck
and [__] you know um I was older so I I
could manage myself really well I I
learned to [__] just managed to suck
uh Mountain's phas I I fell pretty hard
and uh I I severed a I did a Brach
plexus nerve damage so the arm the right
arm was dead and so I wasn't going to
say [__] I got through [__] Florida
phase and you know I took a swim in the
[__] in the swamp with one armor and
struggled for a little bit had some
range of buddies help me out you know
but um no man I got through it you know
Lord willing and as well as I graduated
the same day the anniversary date to
Devon's death and that was kind of the
motivation for just trying to go
straight
through um going to the book I I
graduated from Ranger school right on
time December 16th and I was the
distinguished Honor Graduate the
downside was that I had severed my nerve
as you just said staff sergeant barza
was killed in Iraq from wounds he
sustained on a mission yeah he and
Sergeant Dale Brim died while clearing a
building in ramadi Iraq when they came
under enemy fire we lost two of the most
influential and well-respected
individuals in our Battalion and I was
angry about it staff sergeant Bar's
death Hit me hard perhaps more so
because I wasn't there in country with
him when it happened and that's because
you're of your shoulder so you didn't
get to go on deployment um I believed he
was a better man than me I would have
gladly traded places with him would he
have Di died if I had been there like
most men and women in the military I had
survivors guilt if those bullets had hit
me instead maybe staff sergeant barazza
would still be alive when his body was
flown home I was one of the soldiers
detailed to work his
funeral that was one of the hardest
things I ever had to do but it was an
honor I treasured to this day men like
barazza Were Heroes and the fact that
they were killed solidified my decision
to leave the
army
yeah he was a badass
dude always mad that I was upset with
him and I that was the last conversation
we had I was I was frustrated you know
and I never got a chance to tell him how
how much of an impact he's made in my
life how influential as a as a leader he
was and um I'm no superhero I don't know
if I would I was even going to be in the
same room as him during that time but it
should have could as what as
um ate me alive and
it he wanted to get out and he wanted to
go do other things and so did Dale and
um I felt like [__] this number of game
is starting to hit really close to home
and so uh I wanted to kind of get out as
well and so I was ready to leave M but
you still had another deployment to do
right yeah
how's that psychologically when you're
in undeployment and you don't
like kind of want to be there yeah that
was hard that was I I my wife asked me
before when we first met like you ever
smoke cigarettes I'm like no I was like
well yeah I smoked five my last
deployment because every time there was
a mission I was like thank God because I
kept thinking like it's my last mission
it's it's no different than Dale and and
and Rick how they were waiting to get
out and they were going to come home and
get out of the military and I'm sitting
here doing the same same thing I was
getting out 3 months after this
deployment so I'm like get through this
[__] deployment and start packing
your [__] you know what I mean and so
every Mission I was like [__]
and I'm a team leader I'm a team leader
and sometimes acting squad leader
because we had our squad leader got
injured and so we're just managing this
team and everyo every Mission I'm like
[__] dude like please and that's like
the worst way it's the worst cuz like I
don't want to be like that I want to be
like [__] excited about this [__] but
every every time we went out I was like
nervous and I hated that feeling and I
knew I was like it's time dude shut it
down because my mind was too wrapped up
and dude the first the first mission
coming back
from Rick and Dale's death was five
dudes on the roof waiting for us and
they [__] actually engaged on us
right and it was just like and I had
[__] two I think three new guys 17
years like 18 years old sorry 18 19 year
old dudes and I'm like [__] and I'm
telling them like be ready be ready be
ready we're the main we were the main
effort and they went to go breach the
door the the uh the gate and they
started engaging Us in in the in the
alleyway and as much as I was
comfortable with it it was like oh yeah
they're fighting us [__] boom aim the
guns they go boom boom boom and our gun
team's firing up there my my saw gun is
firing up there and we're just kind of
organizing traffic here trying to see
what's going at the back end and uh the
whole time like [__] dude this
is like the one thing I don't need but
like let's figure it out you know what I
mean and you know we were able to engage
on some dudes we were able to take out
that building we dropped some bombs on
it this and that then you come back I'm
like [__] give me that cigarette boom
smoke cigarette I'm my cough you know I
mean I'm like it was just like I needed
something that I can just say like all
right that's out of the way you know
what I mean and when that deployment f
[__] ended I knew I was like [__]
this yeah I'm getting the [__] out of
here yeah I never had that experience
but I was always worried about guys that
were nervous guys that were like scared
because then all of a sudden sometimes
that affects the way they act and and in
my opinion if you're more aggressive
you're going to have better chance of
survival you're help the team more like
if you're scared you're nervous it's
going to you're going to hesitate you're
not going to want to do something and it
can really [__] things up bad if you're
that guy and like I said luckily for me
like I never had to feel like that but I
can't honestly if I try and think about
that what that must be like to be like I
don't want to be doing this cuz it's one
thing to be like oh I don't want to be
cold or I don't want to be freaking
tired I want to go to sleep and I want
to be warm but it's another thing to be
like I don't want to die and I'm going
towards a building with bad guys in it
that want to kill
me that's got to be that's got to be
rough on the freaking psyche dude and
I'm
like I I'm all about like doing my job
right and I have these [__] three
kids that like I'm responsible for so I
couldn't be a [__] [__] about it I
had to like that was the hardest thing I
was like these [__] depend on me you
know what I mean and so like the whole
time like I don't even think I called
home the whole deployment because I like
my grandfather died my uncle died and I
was like let's just get through this
[__] like let's focus here let's get
done and once I was done I was like I'm
out so you get out um you say two
options in your head firefighting on
Border Patrol you applied for 30 jobs
yeah and those were just random jobs
anything I was like an indeed or I think
at the time it was some other but like
yeah just like yeah that works that
works that works you uh look like it
looks like you're going to get picked up
for Tucson fire department yeah which
would have been you know obviously a big
badass fire department awesome and right
as you're thinking you're going to get
picked up they go on a hiring freeze
yeah and meanwhile you got how many kids
you got now two kids I had three at the
time so three kids you got bills to pay
yeah dude I mean hey everybody just if
you don't know if you just get out of
the army after what was it 4 years stint
four years if you get out of the army
after four years you don't get anything
yep there's no retirement I guess you
can still go to the VA if you want to
wait for a long time to get like your
your broken arm looked at or something
but you're out dude and and that's got
to be well that's why you say in the
book like you just you were just like I
need a freaking job yeah that's why I
play yeah I I was like dude I got to pay
these bills I ended up going to full to
school full-time and worked full-time
just to cover my [__] bills because
you get comfortable living at as was a
E5 jump pay and NCO pay in the Special
Operations right so you got paid pretty
decent and then you get in and you're
like oh [__] we got to somehow cover
that big gap of money that not a one job
is not going to cover yeah so I I got a
job at the prison pretty fast and then I
was going to school fulltime to for
firefighting just to get my my fire one
and two my EMT and all that [__] just so
I can survive um you end up eventually
at a small Department in coolage Arizona
you get hired there and you say soon
after joining I was called to fight a
fire that occurred on the tour bus of a
musician called Kenna yeah I never heard
of Kenna Eko they were they they were
small but I remember they were on
they're on MTV cuz I went home right
away and Googled it like who the [__] is
this dude you know what I mean uh you
say I was the lead on the hose but as I
was fighting the fire I couldn't help
but feel disappointment I had spent the
last four years of my life doing some of
the crazy stuff imaginable trying to
fill that void by fighting fires wasn't
working for me so you got that off to
the first one huh bro it was see it was
the first one where I was actually on
the hose the first one we went to the
house was just fully engulfed and I just
watched it I remember my father coming
home smelling like smoke and I'm like
damn dope right you know I mean I mean I
used to love when I hugged him and I
could smell it I was that's [__]
badass dude you know and then the movie
Backdraft came out and then you're like
dude this is fire I forgot about then
you're like this is dope career uh and
so it was the first time I was finally
de with all the training and I went into
this like this crazy ass little small
fire department and I'm lead on the hose
and you know this thing is [__]
engulfed and I'm hitting it and it's hot
in there and I'm just spraying and I'm
like yeah [__] that this isn't for me
and it wasn't just wasn't scary it
wasn't intimidating wasn't it was the
first fire call out of like everything's
EMS at this time so the kind of the
things have shifted in the fire world
and I was my mind wasn't I wanted
excitement I wanted fear I wanted I
wanted something more something more and
I remember getting out of out of the
tour bus the fire's done it was a
battery that just leaked and caused a
fire whatever the [__] uh I remember
taking off my gear and I actually left
it there I told the chief like hey I'm
I'm I'm done damn thank you and my wife
at 's like you just wasted two years of
schooling for firefighting I said yeah
yeah but n my heart's not in this [__]
I'm out dang yeah she's like uh cool
what's for dinner who's paying for
groceries well I was working at the at
the I was working at the prison Stu and
so it was like a volunteer thing and I
was trying to transition into it oh that
was a volunteer fire fighting oh okay
cool that's cool no no I didn't yeah I
kept the family still had
food uh so then you then now you decide
and I'm fast forward you decide now it's
time to go border patrol um you got to
go through the testing Pro process the
application process the written portion
oral exam physical exam background check
lie detector how's the lie detector test
I didn't have to do it how'd you get
around that I a top secet clearance oh
nice I still held my TS clearance with
SCI and so they were like hey we saw you
had a little drug history I'm like yeah
that's that was a high school just kid
you know yeah because you have the TS
clearance we're just not going to give
you the the the light I was like oh good
oh good yeah man that the one I've heard
some good stories about that lie
detector test apparently that thing is
good to go although I got two stories
one of my friends went to the agency and
one of them went to the FBI and the one
that went to the agency was a guy that
kind of like you you have friends that
like lie sometimes yeah and actually
it's kind of Habitual and they kind of
lie a lot but everyone kind of knows it
so it's all it's like dude it's just
like oh just it's just Fred dude he just
lies he was one of those guys he was
just lied like about random [__] like
he'd say you know you'd go out and he'd
be like oh I got that girl's number and
you he didn't get any girl's number he
talk to a girl but he'd be like so he's
like always telling you like these lies
but they're just little lies and it's
all good we all get it and then I had
another friend that was like kind of a
wild man but was like pretty honest dude
and so the liar went to to the agency
and he's like he comes back and he's
like uh I said did you have to do the
light detector test and he's like yeah I
flatlined it and I was like what do you
mean he's like I just Flatline the whole
thing he's like anything they asked me
it didn't it didn't it didn't affect me
and so a that could have been a lie
right he could have been lying about
that right so we don't know but also if
you just lie all time maybe your heart
rate's just fine and your sweat's just
fine and it's just no Factor the other
dude that did the FBI he I was like oh
did you do the LI to goes bro that thing
like he couldn't lie about anything he
said it was going off the rails like
anytime they asked him anything remotely
suspicious that thing was G he goes I
just had to just come clean on
everything I was like yeah cool so you
didn't have to take it good for you
lucky you um dude I have another friend
that failed like a lie detector to test
for a police department and they were
like have you ever ever been with a
prostitute and he was like No And like
but in his mind he had like gone on a
date with a girl and she was like I'm
only going to go with you if you buy me
dinner and he was like okay and he
bought her and that's what happens
people overthink everything and they
start digging into stuff like well is
that considered that yeah the port
Patrol Li DET detector is is known for
being hard I'm known some really really
good dudes he's like one kid told me he
goes yeah dude I stole uh some some
candy from my mom when I I was like
seven I'm like you [__] kidding me
they they pined you for that one you
know mean like I don't know but like I
think they ask a question then you start
digging deep for all this [__] weird
[__] and then they're like yeah there's
a TV show where they put just normal
people on lie detector tests and I can't
see how that's good like they're asking
the husband the husband and the wife are
there they're both on lie detector's
tests oh Jesus and they ask the you know
like the wife will be like do you ever
think about other men I'm like what are
you doing this dude doesn't want to know
this this dude does not want to know
this this is a lose situation who's
signing up for this it's crazy that they
still use the lie detector test when
like you know it can't be admitted in
courts all these things like you know
like I guess it's a valid question and
answer thing but like man I feel like we
lose a lot of really good dudes who are
just kind of Knuckleheads you know I
mean yeah yeah for sure and it should be
like yeah likey if you did something
stupid You' be like yeah I did this it
was really stupid and I guess maybe some
of the stupid things that you do might
be disqualifying so maybe you're in a
position where you kind of got to lie
about him but yeah it's yeah so anyways
you didn't have to take it thank God
thank God cuz then you made it to the
border patrol uh and then the whole
process takes like two years again just
for people out to listen this that might
be interested in Border Patrol the whole
process to long to get in there finally
um you go to the academy and Academy is
a really good curriculum you talk about
it in here um the whole thing is in the
federal law enforcement training center
in Aria AR uh New Mexico yeah yeah fety
3500 Acres it's massive yeah it's a it's
a good training facility is it all is
that just border patrol or is it
everybody I it's pretty much um a lot of
custom stuff so you have ice you have I
saw some Marshals there you have
different different agencies you even
have some some um Federal uh Native Law
Enforcement Training there but for the
most part you got border patrol got it
got it um and while you're out there you
you got to learn all kinds of stuff like
I mean it's crazy you got a list of
stuff in here radios and radiation
detection and freight train TRS and
fraud fraudulent documentation
processing detention physical techniques
uh defensive tactics less than lethal
training just it's Firearms obviously
tactics Communications critical thinking
risk management interdictions active
threat res and you talk about all the
stuff in here I'm just going through it
tactical Light low light operations
basic ATV familiarization Spanish
language
training uh and then you go on to say
that like the places the way that they
train you guys is very Hands-On Dynamic
uh lots of scenario Based training it's
and again you got a huge section in here
about this stuff but um you got this
part that says I remember my first day
in basic training when the drill
sergeant yelled at me tuck that chin in
that was all it took I was no longer a
gray man for those of you aren't
watching on YouTube we could say that
you've been well endowed in the chin
Department once a drill sergeant calls
you out you're forever Target
additionally I had two full sleeves of
random tattoos that I've been hiding
which was uh very common for the Special
Operations Community I knew they would
discovered once we put on our PT gear
also whether I liked it or not I just
look like a former military guy when we
were directly told to raise our hands if
we had prior military background I
raised my hand as instructed as I did
not want to risk an Integrity violation
when one of the training Cadre asked me
about my military service I did not
volunteer much just that I was an
infantryman in the Army sure enough my
worst fears were realized that Cadre
pulled me out out to the front of the
formation divided us into two different
sections there were 60 trainees in total
making 30 trainees in each section
suddenly I was in charge of 29 new
friends so this is like your Academy
experience you can put in charge of
course um yeah you don't want to be like
you want to show up to these things and
just be a gry man and it's like they ask
who military and then you're like [__]
okay and then what' you do you what you
do like one gu one guy was a cook they
was like all right you cook you're going
to go take over that and then you over
here and uh yeah dude it's now in charge
of all these [__] dudes and I'm
scared as [__] for my own self like I
got to worry about these [__] dudes
how long was the school in total uh I
think I spent six months total and that
included my I did the Spanish portion I
don't speak fluent Spanish at all so I
had to do that too but it was pretty
long it was it was pretty long uh
paramilitary environment you know what I
mean they did the whole thing it talked
about in the book how they do their
version of a shark attack which for the
average civilian it was probably pretty
intimidating uh trying to get us you're
like oh [__] but uh I was a drill strong
already at the time right I've already
been a drill sergeant so oh cuz you were
in the Army Reserves drill sergeant so I
watched the whole thing and I was like I
was pretty cool but uh yeah par military
environment and crazy amount of training
PT was tough the the cad there was
pretty it was a solid solid crew and the
instructors were great at instructing so
you were there almost like college it
was almost like like law enforcement
college you'd show up you do your PT and
then you go to your classes and you
study and learn you have tests and so on
and so forth and so the crazy part about
it was like weekends like you're off and
so you're like oh what do you do I was
like just drink really and so it kind of
turned into this like you either study
or you drink and you know you either
fall into one or the other and you know
sometimes I fell into both and it was
just a [__] mess and I barely got out
of that [__] alive dude so yeah
it was cool I I like there one of the
cool Parts about it is is some of the
scenario Based training they would hire
you know some real authentic like
Hispanics right like these are they
spoke fluent Spanish they portrayed as
like an illegal immigrant and they would
make it challenging to just interview
right to ask them questions you pull
them over and they'd be they'd either
[__] run on you or they would talk
[__] to you and you'd have to try and
manage the scenario you do you you'd
have to investigate the scenario and ask
people you know and so it was pretty
cool it was a I did you know I was a
scoper for a while too and and the the
training for that was very similar where
they had a full like City and it wasn't
no different there fety they had a full
like kind of the environment was real it
made it it made it good it made it more
realistic how you didn't speak Spanish
growing up yeah no and so you get thrown
in what is is it a three-month course to
learn it yeah dude I went to college and
I had to take a language and I took
Spanish and I had a seal buddy who was
Mexican and we were in so he grew up
speaking Spanish and I got an A in the
class cuz it was like reading and like
the grammar and I was an English major
like the grammar and and he got like a b
right maybe even no he didn't get a c
but you know he would be so mad you know
cuz he could speak Spanish but like I
can't understand one single word that
like a a me person says to me like even
when I was getting an A in the class
like right in the class if I went to a
Mexican restaurant and ordered some food
like and they if I ordered something in
Spanish and I'm sure they're messing
with me too like Gringo shows up and
trying to throw some esbol at us like
I'm like yo all right bro you got me you
got me dude yeah I'm this I order food
really well until they ask a question
then you're like yeah just bean and
cheese burrito please that's all thank
you sorry like like I try like put up a
front that I got this and then soon as
they asked some question like you know
flour or corn in Spanish I'm like [__] I
can't remember that
one you know Vic Victor yeah he uh well
he worked construction and like had a
construction company and he he he's you
know a Mexican dude and he didn't speak
Spanish and he like went full bore
studying and training cuz he said when
he would go on to construction site and
like want to talk to the Mexican dudes
and and have to speak English to him he
said he just felt like just total
disrespect they just look at him like
bro what is wrong with you my whole life
is that dude I talk about a part in the
book where it says like you know in some
friends some friend groups I'm the
[__] the wife friend groups right and
then to my Mexican friends on the white
guy you know I mean and you're like [__]
I don't fit in anywhere dude you know
what I mean like I don't I'm the coconut
to them and the other guys I'm the
[__] and it's just this crazy world of
like it was no different being in the
boorder patrol you know they see your
last name they're like V and I'm like I
don't [__] know bro gu like I I
learned enough to work but the crazy
part was like the military the rang of
town sent me to go do poshu so I did N9
months of poshu damn I did six months
and then concurrent training for the
next three right and so I could actually
hold my own imposture when I was in
Afghanistan because you used it so
[__] much and I talked to someone
about that like some intellectual person
they said I believe it's the language is
used two different sides of your brain
so so that's why Spanish just never I
don't [__] know Spanish still my
parents spoke Spanish to each other I
yeah I just was I was around it my whole
life I still can't grasp it as well as
others right my wife she can understand
Spanish but his Puerto and Spanish is
slightly different right it's like super
fast as [__] so I'm like I don't [__]
know [__] way more attitud yeah a lot
more yeah a lot more anger um hostility
son hostility we go to Puerto Rico
people speak to me in Spanish I'm like
what the [__] he say I don't know [__]
dude but the Spanish became you know you
know enough to work the job you know
enough to interview you know enough but
you you if you don't have fluent Spanish
it can be challenging at times cuz
you know there's conversations you
really need to understand that's
happening you know what I mean the
discussions that go between people and
and uh yeah it made the job challenging
man did your parents uh purposely not
not teach you Spanish yeah it's kind of
common for like you know the the first
generation second generation to to try
and trying to assimilate to to people
you know I had a buddy in the seel teams
and he his dad his dad kind of barely
spoke English yeah and his dad would not
speak Spanish to him because he wanted
his son to speak English yeah it's the
same my mom and dad were trying to teach
my brother both and he became a late
speaker and they scared them they're
like well [__] May that's too much let's
just keep English and then we'll teach
them Spanish and eventually they go from
speaking Spanish to each other to by the
time I'm 16 I don't even hear them speak
Spanish until they're speaking to
someone else our houseold became like an
am just just English you know what I
mean and so uh yeah man I still to Day
wish I spoke Spanish and me and my wife
have dual lingo and [__] you know we're
trying bro but like It's just tough man
wait does she speak Spanish no she
doesn't she speaks Spanish to her mom
she can't but she doesn't have the
confidence to speak in a conversation to
to random stranger right right um all
right fast forward through a bunch of
stuff here and again get the book for
all all the good details and information
here but uh just before I left the
academy border patrol agent Robert Rosas
Rosas Ros Rosas was murdered on July
23rd 2009 while performing his duties in
a remote border area near Campo
California agent Rosas was responding to
suspicious activity in a notorious in an
area notorious for alien and drug
smuggling when he was shot and killed by
unidentified ass salance as salance this
was the first line of duty death I'd
experienced in my border patrol career
and I hadn't even started as an agent
yet it remains one of the most Vivid
memories of my time at the Academy it
was a rude awakening to the potential
hazards of the job reading the
information of the agent's murder was
chilling he was shot and killed with his
own service pistol I imagined the
struggle and fight that happened and
eventually led to his murder and it
frustrated me I hated hearing about it
but inspired me to take my training even
more seriously and challenged myself to
be the best prepared agent ever to take
to the field to defend our nation's
borders you got like a rude Awakenings
in both you know with Pat Tilman and and
agent rosess here getting killed like
that's yeah we heard about the details
we were like [__] and you you haven't I
haven't done the job yet I'm just
practicing the job you know and and then
to hear that it gets even more
intimidating like well why is he alone
well like well because he had to be
because there's so [__] few of us on
the border you know I mean and he just
went to go cover his area and go check a
bug that went off and and um when he did
that he got pretty much like ambushed
and uh whether he was killed with a
service pistol or not I I still don't
know the full details of those the
rumors that were told but like it's just
[__] terrifying to to it's so
opposite of what you do in the military
of like having a group of dudes with you
you know I mean everyone's got guns and
ready for the fight now you're just
alone and the the approach for a border
CH agent is not aggressive by Nature
it's just it's more of a passive kind of
interdiction most people come across
don't have the intentions to fight they
have the intention to come across
illegally so they can pursue whether it
may be work or whatnot and so we don't
go to a a known area a center that goes
off with our guns drawn and walk in
slowly even if it's late or not you
don't do that because that's that's not
the posture it's it's it would be it
would be almost too intimidating like
what are you doing that for like they
would look like what's wrong with you
dude it's just probably illegals you
know I mean just stop and say Hey you
know so you come out with it you get
your pistol and you got your your
flashlight you're just kind of like
looking around and then you're
confirming if it if it's real or not
like oh yeah hey I do got I got
footsteps and then you call for backup
you know mean that's that's kind of the
process and so I imagine he was going
out there doing that and but before he
even call for backup you
know got
jumped so that's how you graduate that's
what happens uh you end up getting
stationed at Eagle Pass North Station
yeah in the Del Rio sector does like
different AOS have different reputations
yeah absolutely Eagle Pass like a hot Ao
No at the time it wasn't at the time it
was considered to be very mild it was
just known for like Fast traffic I mean
because from where the border is to the
street the main Highway and some areas
it would take 10 minutes it would take
like no time they get just boots on
ground boom boom gone you know I mean
and then there's other areas that are
you if they pass that street and
continue moving forward most of the
objective that that area was to get past
the checkpoint and then get picked up
and so that would be probably more like
a seven eight mile walk and then if they
decide to miss that they can even keep
going charge to San Antonio which is
impossible but they all think it's
[__] close as [__] right and so it's
like 20 miles of walking and then like
[__] I'm not in San Antonio yet like no
bro you got a [__] another you know
5050 miles so it's really interesting
the traffic there but it wasn't it was
like you'd have I don't know a good day
you'd Catch 10 to 15 you're like damn
that's a good we're busy this we say
like that's busy now like Del Rio sector
is the busiest sector in the nation and
it's not uncommon for what the other day
I think they had 9,000 come over in a
day yeah yeah so times have changed and
again that's horrifying policies have
changed and just real quick to get into
that was that the policy at the time
Obama was the president in my area was
called operation streamlining so anyone
who entered illegally into America went
to jail immediately for whether it was
60 days 30 days for their first time
right the second time would be close to
a year and then so on so it keep gaining
gaining time right and so it was it was
a way to deter and prevent people from
just like thinking they could just come
across and just get dropped off right
cuz before then people would come across
you you process them and then you just
drop them back off into Mexico or Deport
them back to their country of origin so
in this time I was like n now you're
going to jail [__] you kind of thing
right and that made people like well
don't go there well let's just go
towards Arizona because Arizona you're
just taking a trip back and forth
they'll just drop you off and you you
have three attempts in Arizona before
they even give a [__] oh so it was
different depending on where you crossed
yeah every sector kind of has a
different policy each state too as well
so it just depends on where that is in
our area at the time I believe believe
it was from Big Ben all the way down to
Laredo was all streamlined operation
streamlined so like no matter what you
came across you get you getting put into
P to to jail MH and then Arizona you'd
have guys that entered three four five
six times and there was no jail time it
was just expedited removal so you
basically if you're in that situation
you just keep going until you make it
across right exactly well that yeah that
scenario is like well why cross here go
over there yeah and so then you see a
massive influx in that that direction
it's just their communication is like
top-notch it's like it's crazy to say
but that's really what it was soon as
they know like hey don't come here
you're going to go to jail okay where
else check uh back to the book here once
you arrive at your duty station you must
complete two years of training before
you can be considered a journeyman a
journeyman is a level of Competency one
can reach and the border patrol
recognizes journeyman status by
considering that person for a permanent
position until you reach journeyman
status you can be released from the
agency for anything that doesn't
represent them in a good light in those
two years you go through several levels
of field training which is basically
what most people would call OJT on the
job training you're also simultaneously
participating in computer-based training
and testing to ensure you are still
proficient in all the subjects you
learned at the Academy so this is the
situation that you're in right now at
this point in the book you're not even a
full-time employee when you make it
through the academy you're a full-time
but you're not considered permanent
position so meaning you can get fired
it's it's the two years of them just
saying let's just see how he does you
know what I mean if you turn out to be a
complete tur they could just release you
you know and so our job is as soon as
you become a permanent position now you
know like this job is legit now you're
permanent Federal position you can apply
for any federal position at that point
laterally over so this this is what you
want this is status you want but you got
to get there you can't just be a
complete
[__] uh fast forward a little
bit I have been working the line for
less than a week when things heated up
the line refers to the term holding the
line a common title for the Border
boundary and what the job of a border
patrol agent entails while our fto was
driving us back to the station to wrap
up our day we saw a group of what looked
like to be Runners straight from the
sign you see on the San Diego border
highways this is a familiar sign seen
with borders On the Border indicating
the potential of Border crossers a big
yellow diamond shaped sign with
Silhouettes depicting a family of three
three individuals flashed past us and
hopped the short fence to try and get
away my heart was pounding I was
confused yet excited
a huge Deluge of thoughts and emotions
went through my mind here we go I said
to myself I just landed the job I'd been
fighting for so long to attain I'd been
training for months and now for the
first time in my new career I was about
to apprehend a group of people crossing
the border illegally the adrenaline
screamed through my veins we jumped out
of the vehicle and gave Chase we easily
hopped the short fence that the runners
had crossed I teamed up with another
agent and went one way and my other two
partners who were both trainees went
another bad luck I picked the wrong way
however the other team approached the
runners with so much energy that the
three individuals gave up quickly as I
walked up to support my fellow agents I
noticed that the three people
apprehended were a 40-year-old male
40-year-old female and a female child
around 8 years old I don't know why but
this moment hit me like a ton of bricks
for some reason or another I looked at
the adult female and thought of my
grandmother and I looked at the little
girl and thought of my mother as I stood
there over the three illegals and helped
with the field interview the moment came
and became Bittersweet for me I am half
Mexican and half Puerto Rican my
grandmother on my mother's side was born
in Chihuahua Mexico and crossed the
border illegally when she was 18 years
old the story that was told to me and I
believe to be true was that her sister
Franc Francisca was born in the United
States and thus an American citizen had
died at a young age due to an illness as
far as my mother can remember my my
grandmother's name was francisa as well
to make a long story short my
grandmother stole the identity of her
sister in order to become an American
citizen my mother was raised in a small
town near El Paso and the Mexican border
I think you can I think that you can now
understand how knowing this story about
my Heritage I have always been
conflicted regarded ille regarding
illegal immigration and border security
I'm extremely proud to be an American of
Mexican descent and I will continue to
uphold the same values and beliefs that
my grandmother had in her desire to
become an American but there I was a
third generation Mexican-American whose
grandmother crossed in the United States
illegally who is about to apprehend some
individuals doing essentially the same
thing for the same reason to have a
chance at a better life the feeling was
surreal and my entire time as a border
patrol agent I wrestled with doing my
duty and my empathy for the people we
apprehended
that's a a huge part of the kind of
underlying theme of the book you know
that you've got going on in your head
yeah well I
just I don't know I'm I'm empathetic man
I get it I get why people would want to
come to America this place is [__]
dope you know what I mean it's dope the
opportunities you can get the hard how
hard you work and the opportunities you
can present for yourself y so like in
that first apprehension I'm just like
[__] this is crazy because I know my
grandmother came here illegally you I
mean and I know she stole the identity
of her sister just so she can be here in
America and I don't it's not lost on me
how important that was for her you know
what I mean and how important it was for
her her kids to be American citizens and
for them to have the same opportunities
and that for me was like she wanted it
so bad she would steal the identity of
her sister and she was so patriotic
about it like her kids joined the
military my uncle served my my my
grandfather served like they were a
patriotic family and for them to have so
much love and respect for United States
of America like who was I to turn my
back on that same dream and to not want
to continue tohold that but damn that
shit's wild to see it yeah I think you
do a great job here you break this down
um a little bit further in the book you
say consider border security in the
context of your own personal home here
are a few questions to frame the
discussion do you care who enters your
personal home why what actions or
Investments do you make to ensure you
can control who and what enters your
personal home do you believe that you
have the right to determine who enters
and stays in your personal home when
someone comes to your home where do you
expect them to go what do you expect
them to
do and it's commonly accepted and in
most States codified into law that if
someone attempts to enter your home
without your permission you have do you
have a right to see them as a threat and
prevent their entry so these are like
questions that pertains to the
pertains to the Border like you got to
see it that way right you got to see
this situation as this is our home and
we should have the right to know who
exactly is coming into our home and how
long we want them to stay and how we
determine who's allowed to come into our
home you know and if someone is forcing
their way into our home how do we deem
that a threat and how how do you handle
that threat and uh it's this interesting
thing where when you have this
conversation with most people like it's
an emot investing in conversation it it
completely it's so divisive people are
either one way or the other because they
feel like they have to be they feel like
they have to be because I feel most
people are forced to feel one or the
other extreme because those are the
agendas that are being pushed those are
the ideas that are publicly announced
their lack of information of the subject
doesn't matter just the fact that they
have to choose one side of the other
right and when you start to really
understand this it's not so cut and dry
yeah you have Homeland Security which is
established after 9/11 you have
immigration which has always been part
of our country and you can't be the one
guy that says close the border that's
not fair like close the border no one
can come in well that's not America
right our our country is we have dignity
right that's not America so you can't
say that and then you can't the other
way say well well open the border and
let everyone in well then you don't have
a [__] country this country that
we're all so fruitful and we're all so
uh the opportunities we've all presented
ourselves we can't say that either so
there's a midal space here but both of
these have to be met you have to have a
strong immigration policy that allows
people to enter our country that allows
it to continue to be this country of
immigrants and and they have to thrive
and and bring value to this country but
in that same IM immigration side they
have to also want the future of America
to be fruitful right they can't sit here
and say I want to take everything
America has but then I want to leave
like no you have to invest into this
country because you want this
opportunity for your kids too you have
to maintain this and the other side
security is like no but we also have to
know who the [__] is coming in here and
who we can say no to because of the fact
of of our own risk our own safety of our
families and our kids and so finding the
balance of that but you can't shut it
off so much that we don't even allow
good people to come and prosper because
this is what America stands on and so
the conversation is actually more in the
middle than we think I think what we're
doing is fighting both arguments like
open the Border close the border like wa
there's more there it's actually both
you know we need to open the border to
the right right people and we have to
see who's coming in and we also have to
close the border to the people that that
don't deserve to be here and so it's
this middle answer that we're all going
to agree on right everyone say do do you
want to Security in the Border
everyone's going to say yes okay but
what you see as security and what you
see security and what I see security it
could be starkly different and so we
have to find out what that answer is
instead of just speaking in just surface
level communication and that's why I
wrote the book is like well first I
believe we need to understand what the
career field of border patrol is and
what it entails for you to start really
understanding and breaking down this
seven layer cake of information yeah
there's so much in so much knowledge
that's not common knowledge right and
yet everyone has their
opinion you know what I mean I just saw
one the other day a meme Echo Charles y
it was like well I'm done being an
expert on Ukraine Russia war I've now
moved on to being an expert into the
Israeli Gaza War Palestinian War it's
like and everyone's an expert about it
now because it's been in the news and
they went and read two articles and now
they know everything and it's you know
that's what I found as I read the book I
was like there's a lot of things that
people don't know about there's a lot of
things going on that need to be
considered you know and the other
question like with your with your house
like how many guests can you have in
your house like at a certain point
you're like the part's over like I can't
no one else we're out of like the septic
tank won't hold anymore activity you
know so you got to consider that as well
you know and and the resources of people
that want to come here and bust their
ass and work and we we need those people
yeah um so if you shut down the Border
completely and there's no one coming in
we're going to
be we're going to have people that we're
going to need people to do jobs that
they're not there right we don't have
the people to do the job so a lot to
consider man that's for sure uh fast
forward a little bit lawn immigration
enforcement agencies operate in the
United States to ensure that legal
immigration and trade are facilitated
illegal immigration is prevented and
mitigated at the border and immigration
enforcement takes place inside the
United States these agencies include C
and Border Protection which is the
border patrol air and Marine Office of
the field operations and Immigration and
Customs Enforcement which is
ice um I don't think people can they
they don't know how to differentiate it
right so they'll call US border control
and you're like okay that's the lack of
knowledge right they call it border
control they see guys in blue uniforms
and think that's border control some guy
hits me up she goes they [__]
harassed me at the poe I'm like border
control doesn't work to Poe right not
they don't there might may some some
extreme circumstance but that's Customs
okay so don't blame the border patrol
for that right that's that's ignorant
right then they're like well why are
they housing them this way well like
well we don't house them we we actually
have a small facility for very few
because we don't expect a thousand
people to come into so who houses most
most of the time that you'll see the
pictures and everyone's arguing it's not
border patrol that's ice right and like
so people don't know the difference
between each of these organizations so
they blame it all on the border patrol
because they have the scope on them
right for some reason like the news
focuses on the easy target right but
like the best Target you have is the
border patrol like they are the valuable
tool and asset On the Border they stop
more drugs and they they they help more
people on the border than any other
organization has the best humanitarian
Mission that's happening currently it's
also the best apprehension of drugs drug
interdiction Across the Nation but they
get the shitty end of the argument all
the time they get blamed for it and so
it's the weirdest it's the weirdest
thing yeah they like the highest
visibility I guess and and even the name
right yeah when you think of like oh the
someone across the border that's border
patrol you don't think like what is it
immigration and Custom enforcement like
everyone kind of knows ice but I don't
know if they they don't know ice does
it's just easier to say border patrol
everybody border patrol right that's all
it is uh then you go on here to talk
about the just some of the basics of
like the concept of citizenship and
what's the difference between birth and
Naturalization and right of soil yeah
and like you know that explains it um
yeah that whole part is my goal is to
explain to people how to become a citiz
or how people even become citizen
through birth and it was just like I
felt like this book is like there's a
lot of layers to this book intentionally
because my goal is like if this someone
picks up this book to read my story of
border patrol they'll learn the career
but they'll also now learn how the [__]
immigration even is a thing in America
and they'll also learn a little bit of
the history like they're going to learn
a lot from the book because like I felt
like if you're going to pick it up you
might as well learn as much as you
[__] possibly can and that's a big
one people don't know how to become a
citizen or how like why is if if a
Mexican pregnant woman comes across and
she gives birth to that baby that that
baby is considered US citizen right
there's arguments to that right but
that's what it is in policy in place
that's what it is yeah the the way
you've woven in knowledge to the stories
like this is what a book should be a
book should be like um getting cool
stories um following a thread of like
the Arc of a good story and I know
you're a writer anyway so you that's
prob you did it but then it's also
you're getting information so this is
like even a even like a someone like you
that didn't want to read growing up
like you would be interested in this cuz
there's a cool story to it but then
you're getting the information as well
so you talk through all that stuff legal
immigration how that process works
illegal immigration which you know
there's two different types of that
right you got people that are coming
across running across the border down
here in Tijana and then you've got
people that come here on a tourist visa
and they never leave yes right
um the term immigrant applies to anyone
who intends to abandon residency in
their native country and permanently
immigrate to the United States you got
like teaching the normal person what
these things are so at least we can
raise our level of discussion a little
bit and have a little bit more of a of a
whatever intelligent conversation about
it and consider more than what you've
heard in like three talking points on
mainstream media which is going to leave
you with like just some basically an
extreme idea right of one way or the
other either close the border or open
the Border that's like the two options
it's the crazy thing like what I get in
most interviews is so how would you fix
it and it's like
there's not a one answer to this this is
like layers of [__] that we really have
to focus on that's not one thing because
like that's the simplest question you
can ask me because that's how much the
lack of information is about border
patrol immigration and the policies and
everything else is that well what's the
answer well it's it's more than just an
answer there's not a 1 plus one equals
two answer it's not how this works right
this is like a recipe of a cake and you
either [__] this up or fix it you know
what I mean and like a little too much
of anything can [__] things up on a
massive scale this is this is being
having intelligent conversations about
it but also educating other countries on
how our immigration works right explain
to them like this is how it actually
works and also let's remember most of
these people are probably being
manipulated by by smuggling smuggling
you know operations right that's a thing
that's a very big thing so how about we
teach them what the right thing is right
we don't have counter operations on
education we should right how about why
are they flinging that country how can
us as a diplomatic approach to like how
do we help that country be better be
more successful right a lot of things we
can do instead of like close or open the
Border that's that's like such a minute
thing that's like like it's so surface
level the the wall the building a bigger
wall does help in some areas because it
helps funnel traffic specific ways it's
just like it's any kind of like tactical
operation right but the problem is like
there is no one answer there's nothing
that's going to be like this fixes it no
because then you have to talk about
who's here in the country illegally
right who who's had kids here that are
illegally and those kids are now here in
the country and those kids are now 15
years old and have no other idea that
they illegal there's a lot of levels to
this that no one wants to address they
just want to get the close the border
open the border and that's why like part
of this whole book the intention of is
like if this is just a start to
educating people I think there's a lot
more conversations need to be having but
a lot more books that need to be be
written about this concept and this is
just one here's the boorder of control
side of it yeah um so so this time
you're working at Eagle Pass
and that's pretty much like your mission
day-to-day is you're going out and
looking for people that are crossing
yeah and um going through the the
procedures
to process them once they've been caught
yep um you go into a big section here
about border patrol culture and uh
pretty cool and culture is such a huge
part of any organization that you're
going to be in and I thought that this
was cool because you're given an idea of
what it's like um you start off with one
is none and two is one which is the
reverse first of what I learned in the
military which is two is one one is none
you say one is none first but hey it's
all good border patrol going to do a
little bit differently yeah one is none
and two is one yeah yeah and it's the
reason is because of batteries really
it's like the first thing is like if you
have one flashlight you're [__] cuz
you're in the middle of a 20 mile walk
like the thing shuts off you're like
okay now what yeah uh you talk about the
terrain being that that lens to the
culture inside the border patrol cuz the
trains you got to deal with it all the
time uh the community who lives in On
the Border you've got like you say this
it's not uncommon for an oil rigger or a
politician to become a part-time drug
Smuggler the corruption is potentially
everywhere right that's like wildness oh
it's crazy yeah and you I forget if I
call it out or not but you break down
like financially what someone's going to
be making in whatever career they're in
and then how much they're going to make
if they do a little bit of smuggling on
the side yeah you know and it's like
some people look at that and they go you
know what I would like a new car over
the next few month I think the average
income on a border in a Border Town was
somewhere around for like the average
person somewhere around 25 35k that's
not that's not a lot man you know what I
mean even the law enforcement some of
those border those Bordertown law
enforcement officers are making 35 to 45
65 maybe border STS come out the gate
swinging at 65 you know I mean so we
make a good amount of money compared to
comparable to any kind of border border
like job but like you're surrounded by
you're surrounded you'll go to a bar and
at night and here's your border chains
on one corner there's definitely drug
smok
you know hanging out in another corner
you know you got the oil riggers over
here you it's like the craziest thing
and like it's like all right uh well
we're just going to hang out for the
night and drink and then tomorrow we'll
be back at it again you know I mean like
this cat Mouse game of it all but you
know who's [__] shady as [__] you
it's like part of your job to understand
that but where else you going to hang
out you live on the border dude you got
to go to the same you got to have drinks
with your boys you got to go to dinner
and so you're just intermingled with
this wild world of it man yeah damn uh
cut and sign you guys do you guys do a
lot of tracking that's mainly our job
that's why bortac and borstar or bortac
specifically when borstar agents
attached to them uh get called on a lot
of like trafficking uh uh excuse me
tracking calls a lot of Escape convict
kind of calls because our job day a
doubt is tracking that's what it is so
we're cutting sign all day long as soon
as you see Footprints you get tracking
you start you start walking it and
that's how we catch people like that's
the job and their job is to try and you
know screw that up right whether they
wear things on their feet or whatever
the case is but yeah we cut sign day in
and day out that's the job of a b tra is
tracking how good did you get at it good
but not great I had dudes who could
[__] almost do a full Sprint and
catch sign on concrete and you're like
shut the [__] up and then boom Oh [__]
you found it again it's like it's crazy
like the guys who've been doing it for
15 years can do a slow Jog and and and
see everything bro I was wait wait real
quick what is it cut sign cut sign yeah
it's what we call it's called cutting
sign and uh sign is the imprint of a
foot right on the ground so uh we're
looking for sign and so we do a lot of
cutting which means is we're in our
vehicle we're driving really slow with a
flashlight at an angle or just looking
at the ground and we're cutting we're
making a just it's like a they call it a
cut I don't know oblique lighting yeah
just kind of walk just so in every
border there's the wall or a border
right the Border itself and then there's
usually some kind of dirt path and that
dirt path is dragged daily multiple
times a day and that's just to clean it
to get a clean slate and then to turn
around and start driving it and see if
the footprints are on it like a golf
kind of a scenario with the sand over
exactly and so once you see the
footprints it's like boom it's on it so
that's cutting sign for us we just look
for the sign of footprints then you'll
be like oh [__] I got a group of five
six depending on the different patterns
of the shoes and then the way you you
talk to your boy up ahead you go hey I
got sign of five I got a a running W I
got a shock like n shock yeah you got
all the different designs you give them
and then they're looking for that same
sign up ahead hopefully 5 miles away or
whatever and you're like boom now you
just jumped them five miles closer and
so that's a that's okay all right it's
dope yeah uh hunting and like shooting
elk and tracking elk like I've been out
tracking elk and I was with my buddy
John Dudley and our guide and like dude
I'm not kidding we would be no sign for
like 20 yards and all of a sudden like
dudy would like on it got got one and
there would be I'm not kidding through
like the bushes like through there would
be one one Speck of blood that is
literally smaller than a pin head
smaller than a pin head it's
unbelievable echo's looking at me like
that doesn't make sense I'm telling you
you're on a
trail and you can kind of like the
direction you like you can tell which
way the thing is moving right you can
tell that the elk you found a you know
you found a sign here and then you find
sign somewhere else so you got like a
direction that they're likely heading in
and then all of a sudden like got one
and you be the tiniest tiniest Speck of
blood it is impressive and then like
guides will be oh here's like you can
tell he's limping or you can tell he's
tired or you can tell this so yeah it's
pretty badass how good guys can get you
can do it for 20 miles and when you
catch someone at 20 miles [__] yes D cuz
you're like hope I'm not following some
old ass [__] dog you know what I mean
and yeah there's guys that can tell you
like hey they walked backwards this is
good traffic you're like how the [__]
what they healed that you know a tow dig
or a heal this or that and then you can
see when people wear carpet right it's
just like oh this is a good sign they're
wearing carpet you're like how it's like
well just the imprint slightly different
you're like these [__] are good
they put carpet on their feet to like
mess they do all kinds of different
stuff yeah yeah carpet's a very common
one you know the the the smuggling
organizations they they they they offer
them they hey we can give you carpet for
$2 more do you so they outline their
feet they wear the carpet and it's hard
to see that in print yeah damn uh you
talk about the duty bag tricky bag which
is where you car all you you talk about
carrying a sling shot and you no it's
not common I did it it's not common no
I'm talking about you carried a
slingshot yeah yeah um one of the
missions in mosul with s barza we were
we were on an alley and the sniper
trying to take out the lights as we go
and he kind of did a kind of a curve
where the sniper couldn't hit the light
and it was it was the older nods right
so it Whited out our nods pretty good so
we were like [__] we got to [__] do
something I threw a rock by chance and
[__] hit it and we were like laughing
like [__] yeah right bball yeah exactly
like with one good strike in me still um
we went back to the to the room we were
kind of aring the whole thing and we
were thinking about things that we can
do because we also had dogs that would
approach us at night and kind of
compromise us and so
the guys started talking about bringing
um BB guns or p u pellet guns and I
thought about a slingshot because I've
had one since I like when I was a kid so
like [__] I'll start caning so I brought
one with me in the border patrol dude
and yeah man I [__] use that mother a
couple
times uh buddy system you talk about
that obviously landmarks you know just
how you guys are navigating everyone
knows the landmarks in the area uh group
group is the term that you all use for
the group of people that are uh coming
in GPS GPS is just part of your part of
your
gig uh and then people just being
patriotic people that are they're part
of the border patrol it's like the one
big biggest Bond everyone has Yeah man
they know the mission the mission is to
protect America right and and I think
that's look at most of the border patrol
is Hispanics right and that's a crazy
part too because it's like people would
think oh why would you turn your back on
your people like no it's not that it's
they're protecting their country they
believe in America right and it is
genuinely probably the most patriotic
law enforcement in America just their
job day and a doubt is to protect our
soil
uh going back to the book here to
emphasize the sheer variety of what you
can encounter on any given day working
as a border patrol agent is breathtaking
it can it can include it can include
routine Patrol operations tracking and
hunting Smugglers capturing and
processing large groups of undocumented
persons participating in car chases to
apprehend fleeing suspects and much more
the point is that while holding the line
might sound like something static every
day is dynamic you got all kinds of
stuff going on um just just freaking
Mayhem all the
time a little more spec specificity here
the Border Patrol's main job is to
apprehend persons who cross our borders
illegally while ice is responsible for
everything else it happens to that
person once here or she is allowed to
stay in the United States or is deported
to their country of origin ice houses
these illegal immigrants in holding
facilities sometimes for months on end
as immigration judges have overwhelming
case loads in the majority cases those
holding facilities are jails immigration
judges are typically backed up for about
6 months or more during this time of
holding the apprehended persons will
receive Food medical treatment and
housing while they await their hearing
depending on the area of illegal
crossing the immigration judge can make
a determination of deportation or a
longer jail sentence sometimes during
this process a judge can allow entry
into the country if the court can find
evidence of the need for political
Asylum due to a country of origin
hardships
and I mean right now like in San Diego
they put they put people in hotel rooms
and they're doing that where is that New
York right yeah New York it's gone crazy
it's crazy I you know we're
not this is uh we don't have anything in
our repertoire as a country to house
these many individuals that's even like
remotely like Humane right like for the
average dude back in the day when I was
in you know um just a regular dude 20 30
40 years old coming across they put him
they used to put him in private prisons
and the private prisons the crazy part
about that is they private prison with
guys who are in there for real [__] real
prison [__] you know what I mean and so
you know you got the they call them the
pisas in the prison they're labeled as
pisas right which is like a Mexican
national but anyone from any demographic
down in South America theyd house with
pisas and then anyone from America who
is like a Mexican who who Who's in
prison would be you know and North Dano
right so they're different but the
Pisces ran the prison pretty pretty
strong because there's the vast numbers
of them could like overwhelm any any so
they weren't a prison gang but they had
to kind of come together in the prisons
and all of those dudes are there for
either smuggling or or illegal entry it
was wild dude and that's when I was
working at the prison I saw that before
I even joined the Border like this is
[__] crazy what what's up with all
these Mexican dudes you know what I mean
and you learn why they're in there and
yeah they're just waiting for an
immigration judge to make a
determination on their case and and like
what you're talking about uh 9,000 a day
just an Eagle pass right now like that's
insane yeah it's not every day but just
recently it was that's what happened
yeah no so they have yeah in Eagle Pass
recently they they built a processing
center so part of the border patrol job
right someone comes in illegally whether
it's illegally just because they want to
work and got caught or seek an asylum
illegally they still entered illegally
right they still have to be put through
the process and once we do is we we
process them in the processing We Roll
their fingerprints we identify the
country of origin we identify their
their what their identification is right
so we have this data on them and then
from there like okay the package is done
they're either seeking Asylum or they're
a family unit or whatever the case is
that's what the packet will be done for
like the legal documentation then it's
like we put them back into housing until
ice picks them up ice will pick them up
and then take them wherever ice does
this none of our business I don't
[__] know what it is but what's
happening I know is that ice has giving
them ntas notice to appears right and
that is that means here's your time to
come back and talk to an immigration
judge about your case and he'll make a
determination on it but until then
you're in America we found an address
that you claim his family or friends and
they're going to be bringing you in or
whatever and so go what happened
recently is like these these these
government organ these non-government
organizations these nonprofits have been
giving them money um phones and plane
tickets to go wherever they need to and
just kind of go and exist into America
and until their immigration process or
they don't or they never show up again
there's a good percentage that don't
ever show up again and that's just been
proven and so that's what's happening
now we have no system in place for this
massive influx why I don't know that's
above my pay grade um well because it'd
be freaking hard and it would take like
a massive amount of effort to get can
you imagine trying to process this many
people like that's it's so the
processing center alone in Eagle
Pass is I forget what they call it
either way it processes about 1,500
people a
day it can at Max Capacity can process
1,500 people a day um and it and it has
about five contract companies that are
working that together some for the kids
some for just security some for food
right whatever it is there's just a lot
of personnel working that location and I
think there's multiple here in San Diego
I'll look into that but that one costs
us 24 million a
day that's one one if it's a day it's
got to be it's a day or a month but I'm
almost positive it's a day it's
something crazy it's something to the
point where I was like I'm sorry what
yeah and so then I started trying to do
the math like what if we just deported
him right mhm it it was
just I don't understand I don't
understand what's going on man yeah one
thing is we talk about like all these
different all these different approaches
that you'd have to take to get this
under some kind of control like one of
them is you got to let people know that
this isn't a good move for you you know
what I mean because the whole idea of of
people that want to come here hearing
that like hey Now's the Time right you
know Now's the Time like it's go hey uh
Echo Charles here in San Diego used to
be really really hard to get a concealed
carry permit yeah in San Diego County
like it was damn near
impossible and there was some kind of uh
uh uh legal thing that happened and it
wasn't even like a legal call it was
like just the pressure turned and all of
a sudden it got really easy and now now
like a lot of people have sealed carry
cuz you can just go and get it pretty
relatively easy compared to what it used
to
be well be when it was really hard
people wouldn't even try they weren't
even trying because it wasn't going to
happen and as soon as it got easy
everyone's just like oh cool it's easy
now let I'm going down there to the
Sheriff's I'm going to get my concealed
carry no Factor so I think that kind of
thing has happened with America right
now where people are like like in other
countries oh yeah if you go to America
right now you can get through and you
can get in and you can get it you can
get in Now's the Time and just that
right there and then you see it on the
news like if if I was a foreign National
I wanted to come to America and I'm
watching the news and I'd be like wait a
second run across there if I get caught
they're going to put me in a hotel and
give me a phone and give me a notice to
appear wait hey am I am I translating
this correctly you're telling me you're
going to let me go in America and ask me
to come back 6 months later to a court
that's what that's what's going to
happen go I'm in I'm going now the time
to go exactly and now it's totally
overwhelming it's the weirdest thing
because so what was really weird was
during title 42 title 42 was an
executive order that was implemented
during the co time right because they
were like well let's just shut the
border down so then people can't bring
more coid into America so we're going to
implement this this executive order that
that Mexico at the time was in agreeance
like we can just send them right back to
Mexico and at some point it stopped at
some point we started letting in like
late when it's when I think it was like
only like four months ago it
transitioned back to to to title 8 right
to the 15 23 what 1525 or something and
what does that one say 13 1325 that is
if you enter in into uh America outside
of a Port of Entry you know you're here
illegally and you will be pressing
charges or whatnot right so it's
whatever whatever it is so right now
it's they're coming across they're
getting charged with 1325 that's what it
is uh but does that mean they have to
get put into prison here no it's just
that's that's the problem there's no cuz
there's not
yeah there's no so all we're doing is
processing them the way we do if you
have a a history of record of of
negative record right some kind of
background history uh sex offender
whatever F they'll send them back to the
country that's that's going to happen if
you don't have anything on record
whether you're going to be welcomed in
for for notice to uh NTA and the process
will go as such the problem is that is
because everyone is claiming political
Asylum so the same thing the
conversation goes claim political Asylum
and it's up to them to determine if it
is or not and that's going to take a
long [__] time and so they know the
loophole right and I guess there's like
uh people that give them the scripts of
this is what you have to say absolutely
here's the I am claiming political assm
I'm blah blah blah blah they have a
little script to say and they say it and
it's like okay you know it's not the
determination of either ice or the
border patrol to say yeah well that
sounds like a good nope you're not allow
you get told yep no yeah that's not the
board Patrol's job to investigate that
it's like okay that's what you say
here's the Asylum package I'll put you
in this pile over here boom yeah and
that's what
happens this is jacked it's wild dude
it's a wild wild time um then you have
three groups that you talk about in here
that they get processed as Mexican other
than Mexican and exotic yeah right so
Mexican obviously someone's Mexican um
other than Mexican obviously that's
someone that's not Mexican but then
that's like El Salvador Honduras
Guatemala but then you get into this
exotic category considers anyone from
places like Asia the Middle East and
Europe so now we have
like people that are coming in and when
when you start coming in here from these
further away places well now there's
more things to be concerned about
absolutely cuz why the hell are you
coming here all the way from the Middle
East right what's up bro yeah and using
the using the Mexican border to do it
right so we and how are you making that
happen right there's a lot of money that
gets involved to do that how much does
it cost to uh smuggle someone across the
border it just depends on what the
organization is is managing it I mean it
could be $5,000 it could be $10,000 just
depends it it all depends it just kind
of fluctuates like right now they're
doing something like they're giving them
a wristband it's kind of like three
tries you you got three tries to make it
you know the first try second try third
try oh oh you're saying the Smugglers
have that yeah it's like a hierarchy of
like attempts like you got three
attempts with this amount of money like
getting your Starbucks card punched like
first try like oh you're back again cool
punch it you get three tries it's a
weird I I don't know the exact number uh
on how much it cost but they're spending
a lot more money than they ever have
just to save for that
now the caveat to that that I say is it
is extremely expensive to do it the
legal way as well hiring a lawyer who
does immigration right who's helps you
process your paperwork the right way and
the time it takes it's a long time and I
think that's a it's not an excuse but it
is a reason why people say you know what
why wait as long as it's going to take
me I can just do this now and that's
that's something that needs to be
addressed on our side as well of a kind
of a streamlined approach for people
that are deserving of that streamline
approach but that's the big reason I've
seen a friend of mine whose wife was
from the UK it took her 12 years to get
a citizenship from the UK female where
did he live where did they live in South
Carolina my wife a Brit and it was like
every meeting that she had when we in
San Diego would like take months to
schedule and then we moved to Virginia
and she had like a meeting like two
weeks later and no way because they're
just overwhelmed here and in Virginia
there's no one coming across the border
like to Virginia right so it's it was
just a lot easier once you got there
yeah but uh how much did it cost you
guys I don't remember it wasn't crazy I
mean because I mean I was whatever an 01
at the time but it wasn't some crazy
amount of money I it was like in the
hundreds of dollars like we didn't get a
lawyer just process I mean she was my
wife so maybe that makes and we were in
the military so maybe that makes it
easier but it wasn't I don't remember
the expense being any sort of barrier at
all so it was probably like a hundred
bucks couple bucks you know I mean we
got married at the courthouse for 50
bucks so you know that's how we're
rolling back in the day um cool here you
say while border patrol agents face many
dangers when apprehending undocumented o
uh immigrants those dangers increase in
intensity when it becomes to tracking
finding and arresting drug smugglers
border patrol agents must sort
undocumented immigrants from drug
smugglers this is one of the most
important things we do because drug
smugglers are often armed and if
cornered they might try and take out
border patrol agents when we try and
apprehend them so this is a whole
another gig yeah it's the part of uh
it's probably the most exciting thing
you do as a regular Board of Trent is
apprehending dope but it's also the one
that carries probably the most Threat
Level right um people who transport dope
for for a good amount reason right they
have they carry they carry firearms or
they know that they're going to go to
jail for a long time so someone puts up
a fight it's going to be those guys uh
and so you know when there's dope it's
like oh [__] you're you're in for a
potential fight um there's very little o
very little times that you see an actual
engagement on the border and there's a
reason for that right because as much as
there's a threat um they would be hard
hard pressed to pull that trigger
because the repercussions of causing any
kind of violence on the border they
still have to face the the cartel the
cartel keeps a balance as crazy as that
is they will keep a balance because as
we secure our borders the best we
possibly can they're still getting
enough cross you know what I mean just
just the name of the game uh and so when
their side uh decides to engage on one
of us and maybe injures one of us or
creates creates enough Buzz that it's a
national news the influx of agents that
we bring is to protect I mean every
Special Operations unit in the border
patrol gets activated our mrts everyone
and now the border is shut the [__] down
oh yeah so then you [__] with money
from the cartel and they're like [__]
you right and so they don't [__] with us
they [__] with the people who stirred
the pot and so it is not uncommon for
them to show a sign of like well don't
worry we kill them you know and you're
like Jesus what a [__] game this is
like the wildest game ever right but but
knowing that there is guys who go off
the hinges right there's guys who who
who still carry and so it's a fear that
we have is someone who's carrying the
100 lb bundle might potentially be
willing to fight and so you just know
that pucker factors up there you're like
okay this this might get real what about
like 14-year-old boys oh they do it all
the time cuz they're CU to me that's
like a free you know yeah so very common
pass right right exactly it's very
common for for them to use 14 15 16 year
old boys uh to smuggle dope and those
guys don't give a [__] they'll run their
dope and if they get caught they get
caught and they roll their they roll
their fingers for you like that's yeah
there's like uh uh they ask like can I
get my burrito my my drink they know the
process and you're like this
[__] rolls their fingers sits
there and waits they get sent back to
Mexico to go do it again yeah that's
very common Texas started a law though
if they got caught over I think it was
four times and they were at 16 we could
start charging as adults so that started
changing things because like obviously
this [__] is just smuggling dope
and so there's things that are putting
into play to try and mitigate that but
yeah for the most part they use them
young dudes I talk about it there as
well like yeah the juveniles get get
yeah that was the opening thing that I
read was like you're that was a couple
younger you know 14 15y old kids that
you were about to have to take a shot at
yeah yeah that was that was a that was
an intimidating moment where I was like
this is [__] crazy yeah uh you got in
here I mean you got the freaking crazy
story about here you jump in and save a
dude that's drowning in the in in the
river in the Rio Grand yeah I mean and
it's kind of crazy you're like uh you're
like hey I'm the strong you're telling
you're a senior guy there you're like
hey uh I'm a good swimmer I can get him
he's like it's up to you man and boom
you go for it uh and then it's kind of
it's kind of weird I won't read the
whole thing but like you eventually get
washed up or you say as I got closer I
could see the panic in the man's face
this guy's drowning in the Rio ground
each time I saw his head drop a little
water I was worried that he wouldn't
come back up the current was pushing us
down river as much as I was gaining on
his location I was about 4 feet from him
when we both washed up in a shallow part
of the river he stood up with the water
now just above his knees and I could see
he was grateful to be alive I stood up
not sure what to do next it was an
awkward moment with me being in my
boxers and a green undershirt with his
with a shirt cuff around my wrist cuz
You' ripped off your shirt and ripped it
we were in the middle of the river and
it was shallow all the way to the
Mexican side I looked at him and he
looked at me almost as if we both didn't
know what the next move was I knew there
was nothing I could do so I started
turning back to the American side he
gave me a sheepish look and then headed
back to Mexico I swam back to the US
side of the river and was met by a group
of agents who had been watching the
entire event some thought I was the
biggest idiot for risking my life some
commended me on the attempt I was just
grateful I didn't watch that man die
without trying to rescue him yeah when I
was in the academy man um we had this
crazy [__] swim instructor he was a
bort Tacker back when borack was going
down to Columbia doing some [__] dope
ass [__] right this dude is like old
school postraumatic stress [__]
psycho ass [__] right and he'd
be like he like come here get over here
and he'd like [__] intense like scary
dude right I was like this dude's wild
bro he showed us this video he's like
watch and as we're like we're we're
watching these two guys drown they
attempted to come across and they
started to drown and one jumped in
trying to save the other and then they
both started to drown and then they're
doing this thing where they're pulling
each other under because they're
panicking and I'm watching and anytime
any was like we're trying to look away
he'd say like watch keep watching you
know and he's like wants like pay
attention [__] like he wanted us
to feel the gravity of this [__] [__]
and I felt it dude I watched those two
drowned and I was like Jesus [__] a lot
of people who come across the Rio Grand
River don't understand the dangers of it
a lot of them don't know how to [__]
swim they weren't raised with a swimming
pool you know I mean it wasn't common
and they'd still make the attempt to
come across no matter what some of them
have things like floaties or whatever
the case and some don't some think it's
shallow and when they take one step boom
they're sucked under right they're
[__] Pulled Under And so in that
moment man I told my like I don't I've
always known like I I'm willing to
[__] risk my life to save people you
know what I mean even if it's an illegal
IM I just my heart couldn't sit there
and just watch and so when I saw this
[__] happening I was like get the [__]
out of here like this is my first like
30 days on the job dog you know I mean
and I told the I told my senior he like
I I dude I gotta go dude so when I
ripped my shirt off so fast the cuff
came [__] I had my [__] little
green cuff it was a tattoo it was a
tattoo thing I had to wear long sleeves
so I had this green cuff my [__]
underwear um my my shirt and I just
jumped in this [__] and I handed him my
gun like dude hold this and uh yeah we
both got washed up and we just looked at
each other and I was like this what the
[__] dog didn't even get to rescue the
dude you know what I mean like we just
stood there but uh the rumors from that
for the next few years was like bro I
can't believe you jumped in to save a
Doper I can't believe you did this this
all like it just turned into this rumor
mill was like [__] it was funny but I
had to tell them I was like no man we
both got washed up on the flight and
like it was the weirdest moment ever
dude and I just saw one of the
supervisor she goes oh I remember that I
should have let you [__] drowned cuz
it was just like she was like you
dumbass you new guy but
I I felt I I did I did the right thing
um you know it just turned out the way
it was yep
uh going back to the book here Goda ways
is a term we use when we track a group
as long as we can and the trail ends at
a point where we assume they have been
loaded into a truck or a vehicle we
determine this by tracking the
footprints to a road at which point the
sign ceases without crossing the road
this is a sign that the group is loaded
and we would then report the group as
Goda ways yeah often happens often
that's pretty normal yeah man as as as
shitty as that sounds even at top
performance you're going to find you're
going to have Goda ways you I got a sign
I three at the bottom boom boom boom We
track them we see the same sign and go
up the top and then right there at the
road like [__] they were picked up at a
location where like No cameras there
nothing it's it's it's common
frustrating [__] yeah frustrating
because you don't know who the [__] that
was that for me is like the Tactical
mind of mine who the [__] was that who
was that was it the next dude who's
going to do some kind of terrorist you
know act on America was the next dude
carrying some [__] biological [__]
Warfare I don't [__] know dude and
that frustrates the [__] out of
me uh speaking of Spanish you got this
in here I walked over to this guy and
asked him as calmly as I could KO may he
didn't reply I was using the motivation
ask tell make method that I learned in
the military I got a little louder Kom
May again nothing the man just confused
look at face now I was getting pissed
that the dude was stonewalling me I have
one job to do and it's to ask the guy
what his name was come may I screamed as
loud as I could my partner ran over and
asked bro what the [__] are you doing he
doesn't know your name it was only then
that I realized I was asking him what's
my
[Music]
name you can imagine the good nature
abuse I got from my fellow agents even
today I still get calls about this [__]
dude that was pretty good yeah [__] was
embarrassing as [__] dude what's just
screaming the dude kept trying to look
for my name tag too he kept looking he's
like trying to figure it
out [__] dude yeah dude always you know
people would you know they they would
teach us in Iraq like how to say all
these different things and you know get
down and show me your hands and all this
stuff and like 95% of the time people
were just like they have no idea that
you're even trying to speak your LS cuz
you're just a big white dude or at least
me I'm a big white dude like saying
whatever and they think I'm saying
something in English that they don't
know even though I'm supposed to be
saying like show me your hands and
they're just looking at you like yeah it
took me it didn't take me very long to
figure out that I was not a linguist and
just wasn't you know we're going to
figure this out another way uh for
border patrol agents dope is the name of
the game catching dope was like a
stalking like stalking a prize deer and
taking a hero shot once you're close
enough to do so trouble was at that time
everyone in my unit had had their photo
taken with sees dope but me anytime I
was involved in a dope bust I was always
part of a group effort and I never
really had that feeling that I was
instrumental in the outcome that might
not make complete sense to all of you
reading this but for me that photo was a
right of
passage yeah and this is the story that
I actually started the podcast with
that's that was your first uh big drug
bust that you actually felt like yo this
is this is mine yeah yeah and you got
that picture that they've always put in
the news right they always put that in
the news they do but we have a ton of
them we just don't post them and stuff
but yeah it's something that you know
the you get commended by your but you
know your brothers and sisters who work
with you they're like hey good job on
that one you know like an 800 lb bus is
pretty cool for us like it's a
significant one you know and so yeah we
chase that it's kind of those dud those
kids they had pot right but yeah and how
do you feel about that now like pot now
it's weird yeah it's the weirdest
[__] thing yeah I it's one like I'm
not removed from that and you know I sit
there and be like well that's [__]
weird as [__] now yeah like like they're
just carrying You Know th000 PBS of
[__] weed it's just weed do they do
that now and like there's no you don't
get in trouble for smuggling weed across
the border no you still do you still I
just I don't know the rules of it
completely but you're still not allowed
to transport dope that way it's still
illegal weird you can go down to the
store like down the street from where we
are right now and just buy pot you know
someone's getting rolled up coming
across the border like that's the whole
world gone crazy yeah it's [__] weird
right and the other the other part is
like I know that drug smuggling is
slowed down a lot for for marijuana but
you know obviously the influx of meth
and and Fentanyl and all those other
[__] cocaine still
yeah um fast forward a little bit here
you see I want to highlight the death of
Brian Terry in the line of duty I have
to tell a story in a way that sheds
light on the true nature of events what
follows of the story I've been able to
compile over almost seven years of
research during my career agent Terry's
death occurred during operation
Huckleberry which was intended to
disrupt local rip Crews
yeah rip crew is a term used for a group
that steals drugs from other and other
Contraband these groups have been
popping up more recently over the years
in effort to steal the dope loads that
come across the borders or goods from
unsuspecting illegal immigrant groups
these small pocket gangs have found the
vulnerabilities in the uninhabited
deserts along the border and so
basically this group that he's working
with gets an Intel report about a
certain area yeah where there was a lot
of these rip Crews had had a high
possibility of working he says the
original you say the original plan was
to have an interdiction team and full
early warning teams on both sides of
this Valley north and south of the X and
for the operation to last a month after
two weeks of long days and longer nights
the teams became exhausted they thought
it was best to cut some manpower to give
the teams more adequate work to rest
ratios and I'm going to fast forward a
little bit the unfortunate thing about
this decision to reduce Manpower CU
that's what they ended up doing like hey
this is you know guys are smoking
everybody um is that it proved to be a
costly in the most devastating way on
December 15th 2010 a rip crew had
approached the designated objective
location that bortac was focused on this
is exactly the situation this operation
was developed for as the as the four rip
crew criminals Advanced closer to bortac
bortac was able to determine that the
rip crew was heavily armed the bortac
team identified themselves and engaged
with less than lethal force it is
important to understand that up until
this point the bortac SOP or Roe was to
initiate with less than lethal force and
escalate to force if necessary as the
bortac team engaged the rip Crews
returned fire from what I was told it
didn't take long for bortac to
transition to Leal lethal force and
initial after the initial engagement but
in the chaos of the volley of fire Brian
Terry was hit Agent Terry was struck in
the pelvis by a round fired by one of
the suspects armed with an AK-47 he was
flown to the hospital where he succumbed
early the next morning Brian Terry's
loss was the first line of duty death in
bortac history Agent Terry was a US
Marine Corps veteran and had served with
the US border patrol for three and a
half years he had previously served as a
police police officer in Lincoln Park
Michigan he left behind his parents one
brother two sisters five nieces and one
nephew I need to relate these stories in
order to make the dangers of guarding
America's borders real for you by
telling you about a person not a
statistic it's important to show how the
border patrol has had to evolve and come
up with better Sops to enable agents to
do their job proactively even
aggressively when needed without putting
themselves at extreme risk a final
reason and an intensely personal one to
tell Brian Terry's story is to explain
how his death influenced my career
trajectory leading me to apply for bore
star star and eventually serve alongside
bortac these were major career decisions
that were hugely influenced by the death
of a single
agent
yeah so this is the introduction here of
bortac and uh bore
star what do you got the special
operations of the border patrol has
evolved into this [__] incredible
fighting force and protective Force but
as well as medical Force I was uh on the
fence of whether I wanted to go bortac
when I first joined because I I did the
ranger thing and part of me was like you
know losing my friends I've always
questioned like man what if I was a
medic what if I was a medic I could have
I could have helped or you know for some
reason that was always in the back of my
head my father was an EMT I've always I
did EMT when I got out of high school uh
when I was left the Border I went back
to EMT again and so I kind of always had
this Medical Foundation um and thinking
like that I I just felt like well maybe
I'll just be a good medic maybe I'll be
a good shooting medic for the for the
Tactical teams at the time bortak and
borar weren't really fully integrated it
was kind of a it was kind of still in
the air there was a lot of animosity
between both groups um the Brian Terry
incident just an example they didn't
have a medic on hand with them it wasn't
their sop right for them it was like oh
just wait and we'll call you when we
need you kind of concept
and even if medic was there just to be
straight it was one of those shots that
was it wasn't you could he was going to
he was going to die from the from the
incident anyways but it always made me
like why the [__] not have a medic you
know and so when when I read that I was
activated I was a drill SW got I got
activated for the military for a year
and I read about it and I started
calling my friends about it I'm like
dude what the [__] uh where was the
medic you know I kept asking that and
they were like they didn't have a medic
assigned to him it just wasn't a thing
and so that was like well [__] that I
want to be a medic I'm going to borstar
I'm going to be I'm going to be the best
[__] shooting shooting medic I could
possibly be and that's really would push
me to become a borar agent was that
maybe I can Implement things or help
trust I'd help bortac hopefully trust
their Medics to be to be on on target
with them right and it was weird to me
that bortac didn't didn't think like we
did in the military like military had
years and years of proving why we do
what we do why not [__] take their TR
put a medic on yeah that's like crazy
it's weird as [__] and then you know
what they do they' be like hey we're
going to teach them just blood you know
stop the bleeding [__] and so yeah but
all these War attackers don't want to be
Medics like it's like okay cool I did
the course now you know I have my med
pack but like no one really gives a [__]
about medical until you [__] need
medical and so when I was going through
borstar selection I remember a guy so
just by through a cousin of mine told a
friend and then they got to him and goes
hey uh you a ranger and I was like I I
was Sir like we can use you it's like I
know sir like I'm trying you know I got
to get through this [__] selection
he's like all right um keep going I'm
like I'm going you know and so I knew
that they already knew that there was a
ranger going through borstar and I knew
that there was a potential future in
really helping hopefully bridge that Gap
and just so everybody knows so bortac
and we have friends that are on bortac
but
bortac like what's what's the mission of
bortac they're they like they're
assaulters they're going to hit targets
they're going to do warrants they're get
SWAT team of the Border Patrol and we
you know I was attached to them as a
medic but what they did was any kind of
so if the US Marshals had a warrant you
know they don't have the Manpower we we
would be the Manpower right the borch
would take that mission uh any kind of
like Escape convicts that had a
potential of heading towards any border
bork would get activated for that um
when they're just sitting there looking
for New Missions it's usually to disrupt
uh drug trafficking organizations and so
we' gather Intel and do operations to
disrupt and so they're just the the the
Tactical fighting force of the Border
they're they're they have sniper
qualification guys they have dog team
teams bite teams they have everything
you could [__] think of that a
special operations tier one element
would have and they are the tier one
element of the Border Patrol and then
borar B Star is trauma search and rescue
yeah search trauma and rescue
essentially what a borstar agent is is a
civilian version of a par rescue jumper
we do long line rescues we do Swiftwater
rescues we do we we're shooter we're
proficient in shooting not as much as a
Bor attacker would be but we we do care
our we do care for our shooting
proficiencies as well um we do medical
interventions uh we're all EMTs
sometimes uh we're EMT with uh with the
capability of uh Innovation right so
Airways because we're usually two hours
from definitive care and so we have a
high level of medical proficiency as
well as we have AER Medics paramedics
and so on and so forth and so we are
kind of the best medical practitioners
On the Border you can think of uh if
there's a car accident civilians doesn't
matter we engage we we work if uh we're
out there and we hear there's a group
that got scattered and we're nervous
about the heat potentially um them dying
because of the heat exposure we're out
there doing search and rescue if we get
a 911 call of of an illegal immigrant
that gets lost we're the ones who who do
the triangulate that location and we go
find him uh there there's a long list of
what we do i' in the book I talk about
Swift water rescues you know i' I've
done it all as a medic and eventually
you know that's what we do so there's
bortac is your Tactical Team borstar is
your medical team originally borar was
it was implemented to help for the
issues that you see with illegal
immigration as well as agents the field
and then they slowly kind of came
together and created like a really
strong um Tactical Team with a medic
attached like now Medics are attached
with them and that is the SOP and it'll
continue to stay that way as it should
be I don't want to detour this too bad
but it's sort of a detour in your life
you you mentioned it real quickly so you
were activated as a reservist to go be a
drill sergeant in the army during this
whole thing yeah for a year for a year
where were you uh drill Fort still and
this was boot camp yeah I pushed [__]
uh I pushed five Cycles in one year U
one of those Cycles the first cycle was
called WTC Warrior transition Center it
was people who got out of the military
and wanted to come back and finish and
so they did like a like a dumb down
version of basic training a lot of them
like 30 40y old dudes were just like I
just need my five years and I get my
retirement you know what I mean so I do
be the drill sergeant and some of those
guys are still my friends to this day
now they're like hey you my drill
sergeant I'm like oh [__] but uh yeah
then I push troops for for it was first
of the 45th um are division recruits
that come in yeah like you you if
someone joins the Army you can go to
Fort S and that's where you're going
through boot camp yeah it's not all in
Benning I thought no no Benning is all
infantry God Benning is now it's not all
infantry there's other Moss's but it's
specific to infantry got it Fort S is is
mixed Moss's and sometimes you're going
to get like I had every MOS you can
think of besides infantry no it was I I
don't think I had a combat arms person I
think I had all you know 42 Alphas
whatever just men and women it was like
fully integrated it was [__]
integrated yes it was men and women
together in boot camp yeah dude how was
that it was tough we had a lot of
cameras in every different area because
these dudes they just they're stupid
[__] kids you know what I mean
they're all they just Mayhem it's
[__] nuts my whole platoon at one
time was all women and it was like you
had to have a female drill s with you at
all times because just just protect
yourself from just [__] you know I mean
yeah dude it was it was crazy it was
cool though I actually really loved
being how long how long was a cycle how
long was a boot camp um what was it was
it was it eight weeks or nine weeks I
think it was because it's not osit right
osit was like the full um
basic training and AIT it wasn't that it
was just they're just basic training
boom and they shoot off to the AIT and
so I believe it was nine weeks or eight
weeks did you just like it seems like in
that situation you just see everything
people breaking down people freaking out
people trying to kill themselves people
trying to like just Mayhem yeah I had I
had a kid in another company while I was
there doing CQ jump off the second floor
and uh take his own life we had a bus of
soldiers who who rolled over cuz the
drill SW at the time of driving was just
Reckless and roll it over and and just
hurt permanently hurt several kids uh
you had some really good kids who went
out there and did good [__] right it was
just everything it was it was cool cuz
being a father this was being a dad
right you're showing these young
Knuckleheads I taught a kid how to shave
and he never had a dad I had a girl who
when she graduated she said Jo I look up
to you like you were like a dad to me
I'm like [__] what a crazy experience so
it was a beautiful experience but it was
so like compartmentalized in my world
like cool get back to work you know what
I mean yeah that's wild it it's just a
wild like I said you barely mention it
in the book it's literally like one line
or maybe two sentences in the book like
by this time I was you know in Fort S
and I was working as a drill a drill
sergeant I was like damn that's a whole
that's a whole thing man being a drill
sergeant like I I always have an
interest in people that worked at buds
like buds instructors cuz I never did it
and I never really even paid attention
to it dude like honestly like my I I
went through it and like that was it it
was done with Buds and I just was in the
teams I never really thought about it
again but then I when I got out and I
started like paying attention and
talking to my buddies that worked it
like it's you learn a lot about human
beings and what's going through their
little heads yeah so like when I sat and
wrote this book I was like all right is
this going to be my life story yeah no
this is just one part because I have I I
want to write that story I want to write
my leadership book and a lot of it is
focused on being an SEO in R of town and
a drill AR and the the the dichotomy to
use one words that that you've made
[__] massive is like what an
interesting difference between those two
but as well as the values that both of
them I learned from and so I definitely
want to write my leadership book
eventually but like I decided to
compartmentalize my life so that I have
more stories to tell but I give them
give them more credit when you know give
more time well that's what's funny is as
you read this book it's like one lot
actually I don't I think you have like
no lines about Ranger school it's just
like on this day I graduated I'm like
dude you know like Ranger school is a
big deal man that's one of the hardest
schools in the US military that's a
thing that people you know wear with a
badge of honor is having a ranger tab
yeah and like you're like I graduate on
this date you know oh and by the way one
of your deployments to to Iraq it's like
you just said it was your best
deployment was highly kinetic guys got
wounded in the in the book you don't you
just say I got back from a deployment
yeah you don't even talk about it so you
got a lot of material left in you bro
yeah the intention was to give the all
the folks I can to the border of Patrol
and also to hopefully not like look how
cool I am well that's another cool thing
is honestly like even though I'm into
like hearing about Ranger school and
whatever and your deployments this book
is about border patrol and there's a
whole this is a this is worthy of its
own book you know what I mean like I'm
glad it's like this let's face it
there's a lot of books about mil I mean
we've covered hundreds of books on this
podcast going back to freaking you know
the
1800s um and you know all from a
soldier's perspective I don't I've never
I don't is there another book that's
first person account of border patrol
not like this there's a few like
independent people just you know
self-publish stuff but like there's
nothing like this yeah so this this is
really nailing an area that people just
don't know much about so especially the
Special Operations the first time really
yeah really highlighting that you say
this my mind was made up it was clear to
me that Medics need to be part of
potentially all potentially dangerous
missions that border patrol and agents
undertook or border patrol agents
undertook I want to be part of that
solution and help Rec the situation I
knew that bortac agents and borstar
agents didn't often didn't always
appreciate each other I also knew there
would be a bridge there there would need
to be a bridge to bring the two together
all the evidence and experience that I
had suggested that bortac agents were
reluctant to fully Embrace borstar
agents as important players in the
Tactical world of bortac I also knew
they were absolutely incorrect I thought
that I could provide that bridge by
taking taking my experience of being an
Army Ranger infantryman with a wealth of
knowledge of combat operations and
tactics and transitioning that skill set
into becoming a trusted tactical Medic
in the border patrol that was my new
Mission but first I had to apply for
borstar and pass their rigorous
selection
process the seven of us headed to the
selection site in San Diego California
we were going to a small island called
Coronado most might be familiar with
this place some more than others as it
is the location of Naval special Warfare
command where Navy Seals go through
their training we moved into the same
Barracks as the seal candidates going
through
buds yeah looking back on that aspect of
our training years later it's a bit of a
blur what I do remember was getting on a
bus and heading to a place called Gloria
de Bay once there we checked our gear
and waited for everyone to get there it
was the Calm before the storm I remember
getting our number identifier that was a
participant number based on alphabetic
sequence my number was
83 once we received our numbers they
took us back to the seal barracks and
all hell broke loose the Cadre was
dumping our gear looking for Contraband
they found so much stuff that I couldn't
help but believe they planted it just to
make us pay this Cadre was worse than a
new Army drill sergeant who had just
graduated from the academy they smoked
us for hours and hours as if they didn't
give a damn that we had a PT PT test the
next day once the smoke job was done
they gave us so many impossible tasks
that I knew we were in for a long night
from cleaning the barracks to lining up
our gearbags to delegating fire guards
to assigning bunks it was meant to kill
any time we were thought we might get
for sleep this was a common thing to do
in selections if you don't introduce
real-time stressors you have to create
them by taking away common Comforts like
phones families sleep food basically all
those items we've grown accustomed to
having easy
access but of all the stressors lack of
sleep was the crippler that could make
the strongest man question everything it
was maybe zero 300 when we decided to
bed down and deal with the consequences
in the morning the room was trashed the
task unfinished and I was making every
effort to be a gray man for as long as I
could getting through this next day
meant everything I needed to get through
the PT test swim litter carry the next
day after that it was all about having
the intestinal fortitude to keep pushing
I closed my eyes and tried to be ready
for what was to come it didn't take long
at 4 in the morning we heard wake up the
instructor Cadre came crashing in with a
Vengeance I woke up to what felt like
deja vu I jumped off my bunk to get
dressed but before that I was so
disoriented that I grabbed the guy next
to me and yelled at him what course is
this he yelled back fourstar selection
now is all making sense I had been to so
many courses in my career especially
ones with roote Awakenings in the
military Barracks that I was confused as
to what course I had just time traveled
to I told you that lack of sleep was a
stresser and I was living it um you go
through so you know you go through
awesome details in the book of what this
selection's like really tough selection
uh you have a PT test the next morning
third of the class freaking fails it uh
next night similar thing they got
something called rescue Randy which is
like litter carrying like in this in
Seal training you're carrying boats on
your head right this you guys are
carrying a litter around with freaking
dummy on it um funny part of all this
funny in retrospect not so much while it
was happening was that while we were
getting dusted off by our Cadre so was
the next buds training class it was one
big pissing contest between cadres of
opposing forces I realized how this was
a huge disadvantage for our class the
Cadre just wouldn't just copy what the
buds instructors were doing they would
try and top them all to make our lives
as miserable as possible I can see that
going down all that it was [__] nuts
I was looking like this is [__] dude
yeah uh fast forward a little bit I have
never been in a situation in my military
career that would have made me quit the
hardest thing I had done before joining
the military was hell week and football
hell week was a week-long physical
fitness and football simulated exercise
that would push most high school kids to
the brink of quitting during Army basic
training and Beyond I had never let the
idea of quitting cross my mind even when
I when pushed to my limits I had always
continued to push forward and find a way
to power
through that is until day seven of borar
selection my knee was starting to swell
it was painful to bend and agonizing to
run on but it was still working as I
started to fall out of the morning PT
session run on a beach the kadre started
to punish everyone for my lack of
ability to keep up they would yell say
thank you to 83 and how does 83 how does
it feel 83 to know you are the weakest
link those words on any other day of
training would fall upon death deaf ears
but on that day at that moment it was
the excuse that I needed just to stop
the pain yeah I was feeling defeated and
for the first time in my life I
contemplated quitting it was an
emotional painful thought I kept
wondering what my kids would think of me
what would my father how would my father
react to me what would he say or would
he say that I wasn't Tough Enough how
would it feel to face everyone back in
my unit who up until then believed in me
a Cadre instructor named McCardell was
in my ear the whole time he was playing
good cop bad cop and was going all
psycho on me as bad cop he yelled things
like quit 83 you aren't good enough go
home 83 we don't want you then he
switched to the nice guy persona and
said things like it's okay 83 you don't
want to permanently hurt yourself it'll
ruin your future the van's there man
just quit it's cool I admit that I was
about to quit my eyes were watering I
was breaking down and the voice in my
head said [__] I might actually quit I
can't tell you what it was God or ego
but just as fast as this desire to quit
penetrated my brain the anger followed
without breaking stride I turned to
mcardell and said with all due respect
sir you can keep yelling all you want
but I won't quit I was able to close the
gap and get back with the group and
thank God the Run ended yeah I was like
you were danger close bro I dude I felt
like I was embarrassed like I've never
been in that position dude where I was
embarrassed cuz they're all getting
[__] up dude I see them getting just
you know they're in the sand getting
[__] up and they're doing you know
they're making sugar cookies all the
things you can think of and they're like
catch up to 83 if you don't catch up
we're going to keep [__] him up you
know and you just feel like [__] I'm
like dude is maybe I'm just old maybe
I'm just old you know I'm looking for
everything cuz I'm like and the one
thing I was like I can't quit and then
show up and two days later my knee's
fine you know I couldn't I kept thinking
like dude do I need what ended up
happening I told myself like let the
[__] break like like if the
knee [__] gives up that's the best
excuse cuz then I'm like yeah I need
surgery just die yeah like just let it
[__] fall off so I just kept going
and thank God man I need I needed I
needed that run to end cuz I was [__]
breaking down dude [__] I felt man I've
never felt like
that yeah uh it's interesting too like
I've heard people talk about Buds and
that there's like look there's 10% of
the class they're not going to quit like
you can literally kill them yeah and
they're just like whatever die kill me
then and then there's like 10% of the
class they're going to quit no matter
what like they're just not for it maybe
20% maybe even 30% and then there's like
people that are on that border you know
they're like they're thinking about it
yeah and then depending on what happens
next they're making a determination on
like what their whole life is like get
back in the water like I mean I saw that
you're like all right get back in the
water and you see someone just like that
was G to stay with us hey get back in
the water and you see guy just turned
around walk away I one of my best one of
my best friends like they're doing the
same thing cold water treatment right
like just cold as [__] get back in get
go in the car warm up get back in about
four times the fourth one he's like I'm
not doing it I'm not I'm like bro we got
to go let's go like like I had to like
if if if I didn't but same way around if
if something didn't tick me like I would
have done i' been gone I would have been
back to border patrol but yeah dude
there's those weird moments where you
watch them just break and you're like
[__] yeah you say in Ranger
indoctrination program we ran a hard
five miles fast and furious we knew the
route so when so I knew when we were
getting close to the end we started to
slow down near the Finish Line we turned
around and went for another mile so like
you had a f mile run and you guys were
on the F mile run and you start to slow
down at the end and then you just nope
we're going to keep going and you said
guys were dropping like flies it was the
most effective way to break someone in
selection process I told myself to never
get excited or expect any kind of relief
in any selection from that day forward
and here we were many years later and I
got just excited as cuz you guys were
doing this wheel of Misfortune
Misfortune I don't know if they got that
from Seal training you guys do that yeah
we had wheel of Misfortune and like
there's it's like Wheel of Fortune Echo
and like one little tiny sliver says
easy day on it and all other ones are
just like hellacious exercis excises and
they actually had a wait on that like we
couldn't you could not hit easy day like
ever for us but you guys spun it and uh
it says easy day it it lands on easy
land easy day would you're like no way
and we're like and my student like yes
like [__] yeah we got a [__] it was the
first day we were dry we never went into
the sand and I was like dude we're going
to finally have decent dry boots in the
morning yeah [__] no dude then the
instructor's like you want to easy day I
got your easy day follow me that dud
right there he said I knew it was about
to get
medieval that dude right there is Aaron
Rogers Aaron no sorry Alan Rogers not
Aaron Rogers not the quarterback but
Rogers was I we became friends because I
became a cad instructor later
right during that I looked at him like
who is this [__] dude what's his
background cuz he was like every Special
Operation dude I've ever seen like the
[__] stud he did this thing where
he'd uncuff his sleeves slow SL and he
take his top off and when you did that
you're like [__] here we go got [__] up
and when we rolled easy day he put the
the the back of his truck down the the
the the tailgate and he started warming
up by doing box jump on the top of that
thing this dude's probably a 250 lb
monster he look like a like dude he look
like a [__] like a superhero and he's
doing these box jumps and he's saying
under his breath easy day easy day and
he's jumping on his truck and the truck
like bottoming out right you're like God
damn it dude and I'm like getting
emotional dog like oh [__] we're about
to [__] damn it man this is the day I
got excited and I [__] forgot my own
Rule and he [__] us up dude he [__]
us up so bad and uh I later talked to
him about it and I was like why didn't
you join the seals or something D he
goes I don't know man I I was training
for and I just never did it like God he
would have been a scary dude bro but it
made that selection that much more
respectable for me but also like
memorable like man what it wouldn't have
been as great if it wasn't for that dude
being there and just completely [__]
us up every day I had a guy we we
mustered out for like first phase got
out there for a conditioning run called
the conditioning run so it's not timed
it's not a timed run so conditioning run
you're like oh we're going to get in
shape now but there's this warn officer
and he and we're like staying in a in
ranks right and he comes out he's
smoking a cigarette like cigarettes in
his mouth just like his cool like maror
man [__] going down and he he comes out
and he's like bring in jent so he he
didn't want to yell at us right he's
like jent I'm 42 years old I smoke two
packs of cigarettes a day I've been
doing that for 23 years we're going to
go on a run all I'm asking is that you
keep up with me and I was like like same
thing I was like oh dude we're we're
this is going to be a [__] disaster
dude this is going to be a disaster and
sure enough it was uh any other big
challenges or uh cut going through that
that again you you detail it in the book
get the book get the book people um but
what were any other thing that you want
to highlight no the the selection was
like so good and I was so happy to to
when I graduated it was like I don't
even have like an Army Ranger tattoo but
I thought like man I need a borar tattoo
that's how much like at the age of my
age at the time were you 31 I think I
was somewhere around there I I don't
even know where I was I think I was like
31 yeah and I was just like God this was
this was tough and I respected it and I
was super proud of it and it felt just
as good as graduating from Ranger school
to getting through rip it was I I I I
highly recommend like that is no [__]
joke if you think you're coming out the
military special oper you're going to
show up and it's going to be a cakewalk
[__] no it was tough check uh fast
forward a little bit my very first day
on the job as borar agent was dedicated
to finding a group of scattered migrants
in the night smilo and I this one of
your your uh Partners Smo and I were
riding together in our new Special
Operations uniforms it felt just as good
as putting on the tan Ranger Beret or
the tan Beret and ranger battalion we
were pumped because just like combat
medics in the US mil military we could
save lives we were digging deep into a
ranch cutting and cutting a drag road we
noticed some footprints that looked
clean and very recent we knew from the
time frame that this could be the part
of the group that had scattered earlier
that night and this is previous in the
book we parked the truck and proceeded
on foot in the direction of travel what
we discovered was that this group of
people was asleep during the middle of
the day just trying to get out of the
heat that day the temperature was in the
high 90s it's is completely possible
that some of them could have died from
heat exhaustion if we hadn't Ed them we
started pulling them out of the bushes
and lining them up and this is what
you're doing man now you got a whole new
skill set that you're you're uh using
out out there on the job and you know
this is what this is what you end up
doing this isar Bor star's job when not
doing any kind of rescue is to find
where groups have been scattered and try
and rescue them before the the
temperatures get them uh and so like
what we do is we show up to work we
already have our all of our
certifications we're already EMTs
everything else and we look at all the
Intel and if say a group got scattered
at 2: in the morning you already know by
7:00 uh in in the morning when the sun's
coming up it's starting to get hot and
you got to start trying to find these
people and so we go try and round them
up and sometimes you're fortunate enough
to to save them and sometimes uh you
know you're unfortunate you're just a
little too late and that's the sad part
about it just Del Rio sector last year
uh they lost I think it was
247 uh illegal migrants who were
attempting to come across and got
scattered at night and during the day
you know the heat exposure or drownings
so that's just a lot of death on the
border man and that's that's exactly the
border patrol the Border star agent's
job is to do everything they can to
mitigate that yeah and and you mentioned
this earlier um that you also do search
and rescue for anybody like not just
migrants but anybody that any emergency
situations going down and then you got a
whole section in here about some of
those rescues you're a huge there's a
situation that you talk about in the
book where you rescue like eight people
that are it's like Swift Ro so you got
all kinds of stuff going on in here um
again get the book get those get those
stories learn those
lessons and then you finally you get
assigned as a medic with bortac right um
and this is kind of what your goal was
as as you stay earlier I read that
little section but so here you are on
bortech I'm going to go to the book here
one day as we were going through a
lengthy premission briefing when it was
my time to talk about the emergency
medical plan for operations I
recommended attaching a borstar medic to
the team Direct on the X which is a term
we use for the objective location one of
the borac agents replied it's not safe
to have a medic with us just in case
there's contact contact on the border
isn't likely but it's definitely a
possible it's definitely possible
contact in the tack award isn't literal
terms such as touch and feel it's
referred to troops in contact I stood up
out of frustration that had been
building inside me for the past few
months I asked how many guys on the team
bit have combat
experience the room was quiet one bortac
agent raised his hands raised his hand I
had more Comet experience as a trigger
puller than the whole team I wasn't
trying to be a smartass but I had to get
it through their thick bortac brains
that I was an asset not a liability they
all knew my background and I didn't have
to explain my point of view any further
they finally supported my recommendation
and placed me on the X with the rest of
the team yeah it was very odd for them
to hear that a medic wanted to be on the
a with them because it wasn't their sop
they just were raised to think that's
odd and for me it was like I wasn't
trying to be a dick or anything but I
was like dude why the [__] wouldn't you
want me on the X one because I can shoot
two like I'm your medic like put me in
the [__] game dog and you know
there's a couple guys who weren't even
military so they were just board
attackers with no military experience so
they didn't even understand the the the
the teamwork between Medics and and
Shooters right and so his that guy who
mentioned his just disconnect from the
from how it should be uh was just what
how he was raised into the team and so
he didn't know and So eventually they
all started to get more comfortable like
oh dude I think this is probably the
best way we should be running yeah and
it worked out like Del Rio started using
a lot of us it was me and smilo really
helped integrate the Del Rio sector yeah
freaking legit and it's just cool that
you were able to come in and slowly
change their mind and let them see a a
much better way of doing things uh you
got this section here in 2007 the US
border patrol joined two joined together
two units The Bard their border patrol
Tactical Unit bortac and the border
patrol search trauma and Rescue Unit
borstar to form the US border patrols
Special Operations group headquartered
in El Paso
Texas um and then you go into this
section here by this time in
2013 I was training to try out for
bortac unfortunately it was a rough time
in my life I was going through a
difficult divorce and to add to it I
became the custodial parent for my four
kids nonetheless I was able to maintain
enough Focus to be good at my job and be
good at my job enough to still try and
find a way to get to so
and then you end up um I spent a better
year better part of two years running
the borstar selection process and
training at the mobile response teams ac
across the border so you end up being an
instructor yeah I became I became uh the
Bor one of the borar uh selection
instructors I helped uh integrate the
Tactical medicine program into bortac I
helped I just helped grow that whole
tactical medicine side of it um what
what what happened was you teach
tactical medicine but you don't
understand tactics you kind of miss a
part of it and so I started teaching a
lot of the borstar guys anyone who came
through selection during my time they
were taught tactical medicine and
entering clearing rooms the Sops were
borch uses so that when they did become
a borer agent borch would be more
comfortable using them as a medic
because actually they know theps they
understand patrolling they understand
all the things that you should know as a
tacm medic and so that's what I
implemented I know things have changed
slightly since then but still the TAC
medic program has continue to grow and
continue to integrate but yeah so
because I was a custodial uh father for
my for kids uh I had to take on a
training side of training role or else I
couldn't do the [__] 24-hour call out
and stuff because how was I going to
find someone to watch the kids uh and So
eventually I just stayed the medic for a
while eventually I I ended up meeting
someone and and and she ended up helping
me with the kids and that's when I
eventually got attached to bch as their
medic MH uh would so you ran the
selection that you went through is that
the one you're talking about and how
often would that selection go down it
was once a year yeah once a year yeah so
we would we would and would you do it in
Coronado is that the no we did I think
they did two classes in Coronado and
eventually just funding what what made
sense we end up moving it to White Sands
New Mexico and so since so is in El Paso
White Sands was just a drive and so we
started using that facility as our as
our training location and so for the
next three that I ran we're all in White
Sands isin't it weird to be in Coronado
getting your ass handed to you bro I
never wanted anything to do with [__]
seals homie you know I mean all a I'm
sitting there watching these kids dude
get their ass kicked and I'm like oh and
I see you know we're all chained up in
the beach because we see them getting
chained up on the beach getting hit by
waves and then they go you guys get in
there you're like you [__] dude you
know so now we're getting chained up in
the [__] it was um it was cool though
man it kind of again it it kind of
checked the box for me like this is a
legit selection and I'm proud to have
been through it you know what I mean
yeah um you also bring in Matt lson
who's the guy that kind of the the
father of uh com army modern combatives
program uh I always like this podast
come out and I'll hear from him like
he'll hit me up or and it I got to get
him on the podcast he's my boy man and
he's a great dude and he's been a mentor
of mine for a long time he's someone I
could bounce ideas off he's very
intelligent but you know he you know I
was a combat instructor in the Army and
he was The Godfather for that for us and
so when I got to actually become friends
with him it was dope and so what we did
was we created a modern Army combats
program for the Special Operations group
um eventually the border patrol and the
Special Operation group didn't move
forward with the program but we were
able to teach four classes five classes
no injuries teach guys how to [__]
manage themselves teach them how to how
when to use Act like Jiu-Jitsu not to
use it you know I mean really focused on
uh weapons retention is really the focus
in like creating distance and then being
able to punch out right hey when you
when when uh the officer got killed and
they engaged they started by engaging
with less than lethal yeah what were
they using uh I think they had the PLS
systems it was just kind of like a it's
like a pepper ball system but as well as
we have the the the I think it's called
FM 304 or something like that which is
kind of like a hard uh plastic uh you
know project
it just wasn't in their Sops to start
with like it was that' be crazy for them
in that point in that time it was really
[__] farfetched to like why would we
need to engage lethally but what
happened in the time is like those rip
Crews were not just [__] those were
like gang bangers you know I mean that
were like trying like hey we can make a
quick Buck by stealing their dope and
[__] using it for ourselves to sell
and so those dudes were were like they
had no other job but to [__] make
sure they got the dope to the [__]
group and so their intentions were
definitely they were worse than any any
kind of drug smugler cuz drug smuggers
will just dro the open and run these
dudes are like we need this [__] dope
and so it became a [__] you know a
deadly
engagement
um so you you mentioned that you were
getting in a bortac um you say this if I
was going to jump on a bortac team as a
medic I would only be willing to work
for Chris Voss Chris Voss was a dual
tabber borar and bortac he had extensive
background as a combat experienc Ranger
and many years on the teams so this is
the guy that sort of you work together
yeah you meet him you know Ranger Ranger
kind of thing we met we became friends
yeah we just dude we we we bro out
exactly and uh we became pretty good
buds I wasn't sure if I wanted to get
attached to a tactical team at all
because I'm like I'm just I want to be a
good medic but I don't know where my my
life was that was kind of crazy I talked
to Voss I said if I was going to join a
team I'd join a ranger like you're the
dude I would follow and he said we'd
love to have you as a medic so just to
be clear I never was a I never became a
board attacker I talked about it on the
thing I never had the time to try out
because my life just with the divorce
and the kids it it got a little crazy
but the next best thing was what I what
I got is what I wanted I was attached to
one of the number one B attack teams in
the nation the sog which is our our tier
one element compared to in what you
would identify them as a tier one
element I was their medic and that was
like for me like I [__] got to where
I wanted to Y yep legit um and it's cool
you talk about going to the kill house
with these guys for the first time bro
and you're like yeah hell yeah dude I
haven't shot live rounds in a [__] in
a in a training environment so long like
it was probably four years or something
like that 3 years and so like I had no
idea what I was going to be able to do
and then yeah by Chance the dude in
front of me his his weap went cold and
he got he had a malfunction I stepped
across boom to engage the Target and
boom kept flowing into the room and the
the you know the range safety officer on
top was like later was like what's your
background I was like oh it was a ranger
he goes yeah thought so and it was cool
it's kind of like the all right you're
good you're on the team you know what I
mean and felt good that's like years ago
when I went to the concealed uh carry
school did you go to that school yeah
and like of course I just sat there you
know took the notes or whatever it's
like a two-day thing first day is
classroom second day you go to the range
so we went to the range and the guy
comes up to me he like looks at my
Target's what what's your background I
was like I was in the teams he's like
check yeah cuz everyone's everyone else
looks like shot I'm freaking drilling
this thing
um this is I'm going to fast forward a
little bit um we get to New York State
here two inmates Richard Matt and David
sweat both incarcerated for murder were
discovered missing during an early
morning bed check in prison Matt was
serving 25 years to life and sweat was
serving life without parole the two
prisoners had dug a tunnel out of the
prison with tools obtained from a prison
employee so this is what's going on
there's high alert there's a bunch of
false
alarms um and again this this story is
like it this story I think is what you
open the book with yeah you open the
book with the beginning of this story
and so now you've kind of built this
story arc where we gota like we're now
we're going to get some payoff and stuff
uh and so you guys show up there they
fly like you mentioned earlier if
there's tracking that needs to be done
yeah bortac is going to get the call
you're attached to bortac you're the
medic so you're going on these
operations you guys go up to New York
and this is like what everybody dreams
about right this is like this is this
this is the [__] yeah we've been
training for so long now and you're like
man when going to get one you know what
I mean and we just got back from a
training Mission uh that was with you
know several threel agencies and we we
we showed ourselves to be [__] dope
right we we kicked ass in that
engagement and we're like a man and I
felt good as a team I felt the team I
understood the team the team understood
me we had our slps down I'm clearing
rooms second dude third dude it didn't
[__] matter I'm just I'm the dude
right and so it was dope we got back and
I'm I'm preparing for my daughter's
birthday I haven't been to her birthday
in [__] forever right because that's
kind of our world it's like you're just
gone gone gone gone and uh yeah dude I
saw the news and I was like oh [__]
maybe they'll call us maybe not it's
been a few days boom get the call from
Voss it's like hey pack it up we're
going you guys roll up there and like
start running Ops man like you guys run
out and again there's details on the
book get the book but you guys take
boats out to like a little island
there's a cabin out there you guys hit
this
cabin freaking dry hole dry hole what's
cool about this up like next day or a
couple days later you're out in
helicopters you're going to hit another
Target this one was like a school big
school where they you know thought these
guys were
hiding also a dry hole and then
uh in the book here you say it was
frustrating at times it felt like we
were on their tail and at others they
seem to be at other times they seem to
be long gone we tracked for several more
days looking for signs of where these
two inites might have been we searched
many abandoned structures but by the end
of the week I felt like we might not
catch these guys we were running long
hours and days for almost a week before
we were even given a night off I was
bummed because it was a Friday and my
daughter's birthday was on Saturday and
I was stuck in New York I asked Chris
Voss how he felt about me going home for
the weekend to catch my daughter's
birthday and then head back on Monday he
was completely comfortable and I got the
idea approved so you know you're like
doesn't seem like this shit's going down
we going to catch this guy well they
told me that we were going to redeploy
on Sunday I was like look for some
reason we're we're not I'll come back I
just got like I want to catch this you
know and you know like everybody that is
in any kind of service you've missed so
many freaking birthdays and here you
were you had everything set up and she's
anticipating it's just like a just like
you got to do what you got to do so you
decide you're going to fly home so I'll
go to the book here I flew home Saturday
to enjoy my daughter's birthday I
watched the news and started to set up
the bouncy castle when I saw on the
report that Richard Matt had was killed
by US border patrol agents I looked at
over at my father and asked him to turn
up the volume I couldn't believe what
what I was hearing my team was scheduled
to come back a few days after me but
they were called in because of some new
intelligence they had walked in on
Matt's final position and one of the
members of my team was able to engage
the threat as Matt elevated his shotgun
on him my father asked if I was okay as
tears trickled down my face I had to
explain to him that I was on that
mission the night before and I'd come
home for the
party you end up getting a phone call
you find out Chris Voss was the person
who had made the engagement and I was
hurt that I couldn't be there for him
this was the first time in my career
that I had chosen my family over work I
was extremely conflicted I chose to be
with my daughter for her birthday and
not with my team for the mission I left
them without a designated borstar medic
and I was at my daughter's party with my
heart torn by whether or not it was the
right decision after the party was over
and the friends and family left I was
left alone with my thoughts I have lived
a life dedicated to serving a greater
purpose I believed in the mission and
the men even though I knew how much my
kids have missed during my life when I
was away on missions and how much I had
missed theirs the mission and my path
had started to blur the whole ordeal had
left me confused the last thing my team
deserved was a half invested medic my
priorities had changed and I decided it
was
best to resign and shift gears in life
it was time to put this chapter behind
me and start a new
career that was a heavy one for me yeah
that's
like that's kind of I mean what about
like just the logistic side of you're
now however far ranking you are you have
retirement at least somewhere in the
future you know what I'm saying like
there's yeah I walked away from like
everything everything uh yeah
um yeah that's it was tough it was
um it was like I never thought it would
happen and then when it happened I said
I [__] knew this would happen you
know what I mean did you have any uh
idea what you'd be doing
next had you cuz you know you you you
end up in a totally different career had
you no broached that at all no it was
like I I did have a couple business that
were doing decent and uh I didn't know
where they were going to go but I knew
it wasn't what I wanted either I just
knew I I needed it I needed something
different I I needed to do something
that would put me more in my kids' lives
than it was and I was just tired of like
I wasn't tired of it but I just knew I
needed to I needed they needed me and
and and that to me is more important
than anything and it wasn't for so long
I never thought I thought like well put
I'm paying the bills so that's most
important thing a dad can do and at that
time
they've already gone through one divorce
they were going through now their second
divorce that they're seeing and it's
just dad trying to figure it out and I
felt it was I had it to do my duty as a
father to just give them more of me and
so it was just and and not be a half-ass
medic for a team it's just [__]
wasn't fair for anyone how many kids did
you have at this point I had four that
was my original four for my first
marriage and yeah and and look that's
not the end of the book at all um there
there's the the the stories continue um
there's a bunch of information you go
through like history uh it's stuff that
you really number one it's interesting
but on number two if you're going to
have an opinion about this stuff have an
educated opinion know not just what the
theories are but like what people that
have lived it go through so from that
perspective uh it's just a great book
and and you do talk about like thoughts
and ideas on how to prove improve Safety
and Security so it it really get the
book If you know get the book um and and
really I mean I think just to give a
little bit of the book an idea of the
book I'm just going to go to the forward
written by me uh borderline gives us a
look into border security and border
patrol Through The Eyes of a dedicated
professional he not only explains daily
border patrol life and culture but also
shares his approach and attitude while
on duty similar to specialized military
schools the border patrol has a dynamic
challenging training curriculum that
teaches agents to survey the Border
Lands and then track apprehend and
process migrants who have crossed
illegally this requires that agents
learn how to care for children for
scared children traveling alone and in
the same night perhaps even at the same
time contend with dangerous criminals
looking to smuggle steal exploit and
kill this dichotomy of being combative
while remaining empathetic often puts
agents lives at risk the harsh
environment of the Arid desert the
desperation of people seeking a new life
and the cruelity of Smugglers and
criminal criminals make for a grim and
Bleak environment one with many moral
dilemmas Vince has seen all aspects of
this convoluted chaos the perspective he
gives in this book is insightful and
informative and it should be mandatory
reading for anyone that wants to
understand the Border challenge we
confront as a
country so that'll give you an overall
look that's part of the forward that I
wrote um for the book so fantastic job
on the book man it's like I said it's a
great read not only from a storyline not
only from the what you learn but just
the whole Arc of the whole thing is
awesome I appreciate it um so let's get
to you though you let's talk about after
you leave the border control so you got
some business what are the business you
got going on uh I have veteran uh that's
just it's just t-shirt TR no I'm talking
about when you got out like so what's
your next move when you get out where
are you getting a paycheck from oh we
had I had Article 15 clothing with with
Matt JT right we we were growing that we
had lead singer whiskey uh and those
were and then we had uh drink and Bros
podcast and so those three were kind of
paying me um and then slowly I started
transitioning into we we produced a
movie called range 15 you saw the
documentary you came to the premiere for
the doc I came that's where I met you
for the first time right yeah that's it
yep so you came to the premiere for for
the it's called not a war story it's a
documentary that shows kind of what we
did it was like you know six veterans
rais enough money to do a film and we
used a lot of the community to help film
film that right we use them as zombies
or whatnot it was kind of kind of a cool
crazy story you and and I think it was
kind of beautiful but that doing that
film is what inspired me to kind of like
okay I want to pursue acting I want to
write and I want to act but how dude
does this come out of left field or like
no man so I I tell you where it fits
into my life I grew up in LA and it's
not uncommon to see an actor you know I
worked at you know I worked at [__]
Champ Sports and sold hats to [__]
Mark wallberg and [__] like that and so
you see actors and all that the world
you have friends who their dad's a
producer of this or whatever the case
and so it was not uncommon to be in my
world when I was in junior college for
me to kind of get good grades I did
theater classes so I did like a improv
comedy and you know like an improv class
and and other and other classes and I
knew that I had a natural knack for it I
wasn't embarrassed I was it was
completely comfortable doing it and my
acting coach at the time the teacher was
like hey I think you should look further
into pursuing this I'm like baseball's
more important you know what I mean she
wasn't like pottery's not your
kid yeah and so you know uh as I started
doing the YouTube videos with my boys I
was like damn how do I pursue the real
thing like I don't want to do YouTube
forever I want to [__] do the real
thing so when we produced the movie I
knew I I looked at Nick palmo the owner
of Ranger rep at the time and I said
this is what I'm going to do for the
rest of my [__] life and after we
were done filming that um I produced a
short film about postmatic stress and
that based off a poem I wrote and then
that introduced me to another actor
veteran uh that is in Hollywood and he
said come out and do some improv comedy
with us called dads and Parks right this
is this YouTube series that we did and
so I helped with that I helped write a
couple episodes and and we end up
getting another contract with AMC to do
more and that was so we can be the
preview before the preview so we would
do these jokes about film or whatever
the case and while I was in LA filming
those uh I had a buddy say hey Mayan is
still like auditioning I was like well
how the [__] do I do that you and so M's
had it started yet no they just started
auditioning for the first pilot okay and
I was like well I feel like I looked
apart I feel like I can hold myself and
acting pretty decent um how do I get an
audition you're like do they have to
speak
Spanish that was a question they asked
me I'm like yo I
so I I hited my buddy uh Steve Hoy who
was a pretty big actor at the time and
and we became friends just through the
range 15 movie and just he came out and
supported us and I said hey man I don't
know what's the next step here but you
know I have a reel I have an acting re I
have a resume I have some head shots um
I would love to audition for this m go
dude you be perfect for it and you know
by chance I know the casting director
let me send your head shot and just see
if she's interested sent my head shot
boom we got an email audition the next
day damn and we're there for spring
break me and my wife are like we're
we're we're doing Disneyland we're doing
you know we're doing all the and I was
like uh how because getting an audition
like that like that is is like crazy
right it's almost impossible it's like
everything lined up right for that even
to happen yeah man yeah that's it's
almost impossible the the why it
happened the way it did was they're so
deep into their casting and they're
about to start filming in like a week
and a half they're still missing two
people it's everyone's the same dude
they have they've seen everyone else and
I think they were looking for something
that was just different and then I
showed up and I showed up like a dumbass
I brought my wife to the [__]
audition because I don't know any better
I'm just like hey babe let's go check
this out right and then John Bera later
he like you brought her to your [__]
audition I was like I didn't know any
better dog I just like sit down babe let
me go knock this out you know and so we
did the first audition uh the casting
director Wendy O'Brien she gave me a big
old hug and a kiss and on the cheek and
was like that was great and I'm like she
what did you have to do in the audition
did you read lines or something yeah you
read lines right they just gave me like
one character and it was probably like
four different lines right and and I and
I memorize him off book just because off
the off the what my friend Steve told me
he said dude just do it off book just
memorize it I'm like cool and and I was
terrified because I don't memorize [__]
very well so I I dude you can barely
read I can barely read yeah exactly dude
so I I I I read it I I recorded it I had
my wife check it I like are these the
right words she goes yes I'm like cool
and I I listen to it all night so by the
morning I was like ready mhm and then I
had to like act it too you know so do
you remember the lines right now no but
I have the tape
I'll send it to you dud you want I'll
send it Echo we'll post that up put you
put you on on trial out here it was it
was funny so then I got done with it
like I said she kissed me kissed me on
the cheek very friendly and I was like I
don't know if she's just really friendly
or she really liked it I don't know so
we flew home back to El Paso where we're
living that's where I I left the board
TR in El Paso I still still living there
and right before I landed we already got
an email saying they want to see a
second a second run and they want to see
two different characters now the same
guy and then a funny one I think I had
like 700 bucks in my account at the time
I already walk I walked away from like
my my businesses and it's just me trying
to figure it out um I bought that like
$400 ticket or something like that I
knew it took a lot out of the account
and we went there I had my dad drive me
as said dad driveing you know and I
can't afford an Uber yeah Dad get your
ass over here so he drove me and he was
all excited about it he's like Vinnie
maybe they have a roll for me I'm like
calm down dude like can I get the job
first you know my father's cut man
Carlos right this wellknown cutman in
boxing and so he's just always into
everything and so uh he we get there and
I took my dad to the next audition then
there's Kurt Sutter Elgen James and
Wendy O'Brien in the room and uh they
say start and so I do my first one uh
was the serious one and then we do the
second one it's the funny one and I said
they said you want to sit down like G
sit down I don't know any better so I
just sat down and I do the lines and at
that time I don't know I blacked out
like I don't remember it I remember
coming to
and everyone laughing and I'm laughing
and I'm like all right shook their hands
and I left and uh eventually I got the
tape and saw what I did it was like I
[__] up the line but I added something
to it which I didn't [__] it up I added
more to it for some reason which is
usually you shouldn't do but whatever
the case it worked enough where like by
the time I got home again boom I had the
job and so we flew back to LA and
started filming the first pilot so oddly
enough I mean this is just weird the way
the world works like you this is my
brother's elen's show you know what I
mean and told me like this is what I'm
doing next he's he's telling it to me
for the first time you know and he's
like I'm I'm making this show and he
never well you know him so he never like
says that anything is going to be good
or big or successful or anything he just
says it matter of fact of like what's
going on you know like yeah it looks
like and it's always there's always like
a almost like an out
of like yeah I'm working on this show
right now it's have you heard of Sons of
yeah it's it's going to be like kind of
something like that like that was like
the information that you he's not like
bro he landed this thing you know he
never says anything like that cuz he's
too like humble to to brag and
especially to me cuz me and him we
always like understate whatever's going
on like whatever's going on it'll be
like oh yeah we did this and you know
whatever so I I knew about the show as
it was coming out obviously as it was
even getting before it was even getting
made but that's like wild y dude so I'm
eating lunch and I don't know any better
I didn't know there's a place to eat so
I grab my plate and I'm I just go sit on
like a tire he goes hey uh Rocco you can
go eat inside and I'm like oh okay cool
and so then we started talking to he
goes you're you're a military right he
goes you know my my brother he's he's
kind of well known in the military I
yeah cool me too kind of you know I was
like so what's his name Joo I was like
shut the [__] up I was like shut the
[__] up Joo I was like yeah I [__]
know exactly your brother like what and
I was completely blown away by it but
like I was like all right and then I
didn't even know the gravity of who he
was yeah you know what I mean I just
knew he was a really cool dude really
nice guy and he's just there and and
because I don't know film very well I'm
learning like oh he's the co- showrunner
yeah you don't really know what that
like what the [__] is that is oh that
must be the guy that runs around and
gets stuff yeah crazy me again I brought
my wife to one of the days of filming
and I just had her sitting there right
again no [__] clue and he goes hey uh
ch chy comes sit down and he put he puts
her in his chair and I'm like cool
whatever and then she's sitting next to
[__] Kurt Su she looks at she goes I
was like I don't [__] know what to do
like I'm about to get fired I feel like
cuz you're sitting next to the [__]
guy the main guy here right and
eventually it was just super cool and it
was he was one of the dudes who would
just welcom me in and we became really
close and still he's one of the guys
that you know I I go to for a lot of
things he's just a really good allaround
guy it's just kind of How It's all
connected yeah it's freaking crazy um
that runs for five SE just ended yeah
and uh well again is it spoiler alert
nah enough people seen it by okay but
like well there's two two good stories
about spoiler alerts so did you ever see
little birds I didn't yet I got to see
it well then spoiler alert so oh I guess
I don't know so Elgen and I are driving
to the screening it's not totally done
movie so just to catch everyone up Elgen
made a movie called Little Bird
after he got out of prison and he made
this movie and he's like hey man my like
my movie is it's getting a screening
tonight which means they actually get
feedback from an audience before it gets
released to make sure they understood it
to make sure that it made sense make
sure so that's what I'm going to so I go
up to LA and I'm at his house we're
chilling and then he's like yeah we got
to go so we get in his car and we're
driving down there and I goes so what's
this thing about and he's like oh he
again like totally like understated he
goes yeah it's just about like these
girls he goes it's kind of about like us
like growing up and getting crazy and
like just wild things happening and I go
cool he but in this case it's two girls
and I was like okay well that's a
different take and he goes and um he
goes and they they run away from Nyland
which is again the weird how
everything's so connected but that's
like desert training for the SEAL Teams
he's like yeah they run away from there
and they end up in LA and there and he
goes and [__] goes sideways and I go
like what kind of [__] goes sideways and
he goes uh you you'll you'll you'll see
like that and I was I was honestly never
been mad at him and I was like dude like
it seemed like a punk move to be like
you'll find out type thing like oh
you'll see I was kind of like I didn't
say anything but I was like bro the uh I
was like oh he is Hollywood now like in
my mind like I had like some and then
sure enough I get in there and I'm
watching it and the
movie like what the part where you're
like it is it is it is uh it's shocking
right like it goes from it just takes a
turn where you're just like holy [__]
what is going on and it's awesome and I
was so happy that he didn't give me a
heads up as to what went down but yeah
so so that was going on um and then he
eventually got into this thing and
yeah uh ends up doing five seasons of
this thing oh and so that's the other
thing was when the when the finale was
coming for
Mayans and again this is spoiler alert
kind of but he's like yeah everyone's
[__] dying and I was like what do you
mean he's like he said to me he goes you
know a lot of these stories about crime
and about gangs and stuff they spin it
in a way where everything kind of turns
out kind of good you know and like
people make it and people get blah blah
and he's like and that's just not
realistic it's not true and he knows
like so he's like it's going to be a
realistic ending and then I was tracking
it on uh Twitter and people were just
like holy [__] like oh my God yeah yeah
dude so I was a writer this last season
you know and I was there in the writing
room for all of this just being able to
kind of one learn from Elgen how he does
things and and two just helping
conceptualize because I was there from
the beginning to the end so I was able
to kind of like oh this story I was
helping out with a lot of kind of story
details and uh when I heard like the
plan I was like oh my God I mean and
it's like I'm holding on to this and
like my wife's like she's a fan of the
show too so she's like what is that like
I I can't even tell you that's like
that's how [__] wild this is but like
the way Elgen sees the world in writing
uh was inspiring for me because I would
be if I'm see it this way he'd say but
that's what everyone expects see it this
way and it was just it just made me that
much better of a writer in the sense of
like how to construct the story and it
just proved like the way mind was how
many people were hurt the millions that
were hurt
good it's like what the purpose was was
if you don't watch a show and you don't
have an emotional response to it it's
like did it really like was it that good
of a show for you everyone who was
emotionally invested into the show was
heartbroken and as it should be yeah
then that's the real scenario that you
end up with if you're doing [__] it's
going to catch up with you over time
that's the way things work in the world
you know there's no fairy tale endings
yeah it was freaking dope uh so so you
wrote one of those yeah
and and then that leads you to be able
to write more opportunities to writing
hopefully you know the the goal is to
continue down the the road of the
Hollywood SC the H Hollywood scene as a
writer and an actor um I like writing
more than I like acting I love I think
it's [__] dope but um a guy with
tattoos on his hands and neck doesn't
get too many opportunities to do
specific roles that I think would be fun
uh so uh I'm I'm I'm not oblivious to
that um but I can continue to construct
my own world and tell the stories that I
wanted to be be told and so that's my
goal and I knew writing this book would
potentially lead to hopefully I'm hoping
uh a border patrol series as well and
all the beautiful nuances of the things
that could happen on the border could be
told uh visually that's what my goal
would be but there's a long things a lot
of things in my life that I've
experienced I want to turn into his
stories um and so you know with with
everything going on in Hollywood right
now with kind of the hiring the writing
strike that finally ended and then the
acting strike that's still currently
happening right now I'm hoping to come
out on the other end of that uh and be
able to continue to work in the space uh
continue to work with people that I've
worked with in relationships like Elgen
and so on and so forth and so yeah we're
trying we have a lot of projects out
there that are getting looked at now and
hopefully something gets picked up uh
you know I've still I got a lot of
stories from my life that that I'm able
to turn into little scripts and and I
get like compartmentalize them as well
and and turn them into something special
hopefully and so yeah we're we're we're
trying trying to make a run out of it
man yeah so you got the writing stuff um
and then what else you got going on you
got you got vetan right us about better
better a company that we started is just
kind of a positive outlook on the
veteran veteran community that that just
I felt like it needed to be done there's
so much negativity there's so much focus
on the negative sides of veterans that
uh the word veteran to me was a better
approach to trying to hopefully motivate
and Inspire veterans to do more to be
more right to to that they can do more
and so you know when I did that then I'm
like okay well what can I bring on with
that well for me in my life uh I've kind
of gone through a big Wellness push you
know I I'm I'm sober for four and a half
years now or just under four and a half
years now uh I've done many different
modalities of healing uh different from
therapies and stuff like that and so uh
I became kind of a guinea pig for for
other veterans to just see even men just
to see that we can heal our past we can
heal our past traumas from childhood as
well as military and law enforcement and
we can we can strive to be better and in
the same aspects of bettering we created
uh light the fuse wellness and so it's a
kind of a I have accountability group
where people can join and we just kind
of hold every people accountable but as
well as the the mentorship side uh
excuse me the the wellness side is we
did a men's Retreat and we introduced
different modalities of healing we
introduced some stuff that was like
plant medicine non- psychedelic but we
also did what's a plant medicine that's
non psychedelic uh compo we did a thing
called compo we did uh it's it's a it's
the Venom of a of of a frog you know of
the toad the to what Mike Tyson and Joe
Rogan were talking
there's there's different ones there's
different ones so this to yeah this one
you but it's not psychedelic non
psychedelic right this one this one for
this trip for this retreat was we chose
to go non- psychedelic but still plant
medicine and so they introduced the the
the Venom to your I think it's the
saliva so what do you feel when you do
it uh just overwhelming heat but
everyone's experience is slightly
different everyone's experience
overwhelming heat it's like a yeah yeah
it's like a very very heat therapeutic
kind of it's almost like a
internal sauna but everyone has a
different effect of it right and and
introduced with that there's we did
um two other ones one was introduced to
nose it was like a tobacco and then one
was uh eye drops into the eyes and three
different versions of of plant medicine
that was not psychedelic but they all
had some kind of effect and and uh guys
left their feeling uh Clarity right they
felt uh they were able to to I guess
manifest some emotions that they've been
harboring for a long time uh but also in
that same weekend they did whim Hoff
they learned how to do Wim Hoff sessions
of breathing right they learned uh
things about um uh Matt Larsson came out
and taught uh about moral injury we had
a an EMD EMDR counselor there to talk
about that and hopefully introduce MDR
is like the lights in the face yep that
helps with the kind of the frontal
cortex and processing trauma uh we had a
long list of different things as well as
Community right we just the goal is to
introduce I guess to dip the toe in the
water of wellness and for them to kind
of continue to pursue it on their own
it's a place where like men can feel
like they can be one vulnerable if need
be but to uh open expression of of some
of their own traumas and being a part of
a community that that welcomes it as
well and so yoga breathing all these
different things how many dudes were
there uh that one was 30 30 participants
and how long is it it was three days and
I'm telling you it was life-changing guy
like my brother who's a he's a battalion
chief in fire department named Chandler
he would never be open to any of the
stuff he's kind of stoic and he left
there like when's the next one like I I
got to try it where where do you do it
we did this one in Dallas we kind of
we're scheduling one in California here
soon we're scheduling another one in
Dallas in April uh it really just
depends if we can find the facility to
to to host it you know I have a long
list of the the wellness leaders that
I've you know been introduced myself
going through different programs uh and
so now I brought them all under my my
little umbrella and I bring them in to
teach their portion mhm it's dope dude
it's you've done so far we've done one
so far but we have a continued so we
have like the the it's
the the accountability group those guys
are still in that world too so as these
guys I can introduce them sing so like
we have guys going to do high Wasa right
we have guys connected to the heroic
Hearts Foundation to do hawasa we have
guys who are doing sessions with the
same healers that did the compo we have
um American Yogi uh xsf dude who does
yoga he's the one doing breathing and
stuff like that we also all these guys
are still introduced into the same world
so um yeah we're just kind of bridging
that gap for the guys okay and then you
also have a podcast yeah the VIN Rock
podcast Vin rock yeah the Vinnie Rock
podcast yeah Vinnie Rock podcast and
what's going on with that we I did it
for about four years and then M's got
really kind of took over and I wasn't
able to so now we just I I bought all
the cameras and I have a producer coming
in to help us and so now again just
bringing dudes in and interviewing them
a lot of focuses on Wellness a lot of
focuses on just successful careers I
hope to inspire motivate and Entertain
You know so it's just kind of a cool
spot to to hear me interview people and
also have my opinions on it when you're
working at Mayans when you're on TV
doing these shows did you know what it
was like well I guess you kind of knew
from Article 15 of like what was going
down and that you have to do the same
thing over and over and over and over
and over and over again yeah no when you
do YouTube it's not like that oh yeah
when you do YouTube it's just like turn
the camera on and go you know what I
mean and and even if we [__] up we
kind of we Ed it whatever yeah and
acting was crazy acting real Hollywood
style acting was like the military in a
sense of hurry up and wait but also like
holy [__] this manous yeah it's like you
do the scene if it was a scene of us
three right you do your takes you do
your takes you do my takes you do the
wide takes and then you go in and clean
up and you're like what the [__] so how
many hours seven hours for one [__]
scene like our scene we did when you it
was just like over and over and over and
you're like what the the first I was on
billions and uh I didn't know any of
this right I didn't even think you had
to actually memorize the words right so
they sent me a script and I was like
cool whatever dude like I'm gonna say
what I want like what up you know I'm
[__] joa what and so I get there and
I probably only had I don't know how
many lines I had but it wasn't like a
lot but I'm watching like the scene
before me and I'm like oh God they're
doing the same thing over and over again
oh that means I got to say the same
thing that means other people got to
respond in the way and I didn't know
that at all so I'm I'm sitting there
trying to memorize the lines my whatever
seven lines like and then we you know
same thing we we have a a scene in
billions and it's
like I'm on this the opening like
Running Scene or whatever but it took
like seven hours BR yeah and I was like
dude this is crazy yeah and then I went
back again which I knew what to expect
but yeah it's weird that you that actors
in those shows man you're doing the same
thing like 20 times it's emotionally
exhausting like not emotionally in the
sense of like crying but it's just like
you have to think and process and and
and you know you have to emote whatever
emotion they're asking for and you have
to do it over and over and over and then
they say cut and you go hang out with
your guys and you're talking and
bullshitting then you go right back to
back on Target and uh you don't realize
how tiring that [__] is for your body
until you're done with it and the day is
over you're driving your car you're like
God I'm [__] smoke dude like I didn't
do nothing I sat on like the the truck
bed of a car and said the same lines for
like seven hours I'm smoked so weird
dude so JD the the star of Mayans right
so that's when I was on Mayans it was us
and a few other guys but he was kind of
the main guy he and I were talking right
Ezekiel and as
we're as we're standing there right so
he and I have a lot of FaceTime where
they're not filming but we're just
standing there set cameras we end up
just talking a bunch yeah and so I'm
kind of getting his life story and stuff
and uh great dude super cool and but
then he's like yeah you know I was
getting in trouble and I think his dad
was a marine Mar his dad was a marine
and so he had like that going in his
life but then he was kind of getting in
trouble you know just being a kid and
then he's like yeah you know he says
when um I I was in I think it was in
high school and like I got put into this
acting class and like the first time I I
like got on stage man I knew that like
this was for me and I looked back at him
I was like that's how I felt when I
first got a machine gun in my hands it
was so dude he laughed so hard cuz it
was just such a contrast of [__] but
uh yeah what he's a freaking good dude
he's a great dude uh it's it's weird
though like when you think of what an
actor does man they're just doing the
same thing over and over again you got
to be a patient person well dude imagine
an emotional scene that's a hard yeah
it's hard because you have 30 people in
this room and they're watching you go
take after take after take and you have
to keep giving it performance po SC cuz
for me every time you have a chance to
do a performance you're like give it
your all cuz you don't know who the
[__] going the next casting director
is like we want him for the next movie
you know what I mean like so it's always
a try out it's always an interview it's
always an audition you know what I mean
so every scene you get it's like give it
dude give it everything because then the
other side of it which one do they take
we don't know which one they edit in and
it might not be your best take and
you're like [__] you know whatever that
is so every time you get the chance
you're trying to give it everything and
[__] dude it's like this is [__]
impossible and how long so I've done
like I said like I did billions I did
NCIS and I did Mayans that's 4 days on
set right H yeah and but how long like
when when you start filming Mayans yeah
it's about five months is it five months
are you and how many scenes are you in
like how many dat it all depends on the
riding that's the hard part for like so
me being the family man like I would fly
home every weekend because we don't film
on weekends but I would be there
sometimes on Monday Tuesday Wednesday
sometimes be Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday sometimes it be just be
Wednesday times I don't have nothing
that whole week it all depends on my
character and what how much is written
but I know for a fact we're filming for
5 to six months MH so those five to six
months is like it's dedicated to Mayans
and for the most part I was in like
almost every episode every season that I
was there almost one or two days every
week what about for JD is he just he's
like five days a week no he's the same
he's the same he might have more but for
the most part like if we it might be a
heavy week where it's the cartel focused
well JD's not any cartel stuff right it
might be and they stack it that way so
they're going to have all the cartel
guys they're all going to do a bunch of
scenes all in the same time my scenes
were with with this actress um named
Erica Erica and she um you know our
scenes were our scenes and so we'd have
two days in a row just our scenes and no
one else was even working those two days
it was just me her and you know our our
CM Punk right and so we would have two
days dedicated just for our stuff and
that would happen often so if it was
like a JD heavy week where he was doing
his own stuff like we would yeah but
damn that must be like dude five six
months of work you I'm excited the last
day actually I'm not good at saying
goodbye so like even on the last day of
filming I was there from day one all the
way to the last one we said cut boom
grabing St and start driving home like
I'm out dog I I don't I'm tired like six
months of this [__] playing a character
emotionally invested into the character
and my character having a lot of emotion
like you're like I'm over it dude like
I'm tired I need the break I need the
break and now like we don't even have it
no more I'm like [__] dude I miss it I
miss it uh all right so you got done
with that you got light diffuse you got
uh veteran Vinnie rock you got music too
did you think I was going to find this I
don't talk about that often hey this
dude over here making music bro hell
yeah I'm actually going home after this
to to go work on another song I got a
producer coming to town so what do you
play an instrument I don't I just I
write I write you write it and then you
sing it yeah you got um a song called
leftovers you got a song called keys you
got a song called Lonely Road
uh so you write this the lyrics right
and then for leftovers for example so
who who's the dude that's going to come
and make the music how's that work uh
that's my producer um his name is Jay
Den he he just he owns indor uh he's
just a really cool dude that we got
connected with and and he develops all
the music for it and helps put into
music you know I write I write the
concept of the song and sometimes we
just co-write and finish it up but it
all comes from something all the songs
mean something right I'm not I I just
write whatever I'm dealing with or
something I want like if I want to write
something for my wife um and so he he
comes in and helps me finish it up so
we're a good team and then is he playing
the the inst he plays all the
instruments yeah and then you you roll
in there and throw down the vocal
track it's embarrassing dude I hate that
on my bio people and music I'm like no
dude I don't even mention that cuz that
I originally did it for myself it was
like my own like oh that's why you put
it on YouTube no then eventually he was
like it's really good I'm like uh all
right right [__] it I'll put there's one
song on YouTube uh well they're on no
there's more than one song on YouTube I
was watching them last night were they
on YouTube yeah no they they're good man
I was I was it was interesting to me
because there's no uh there's a very
limited thread of the musical style it's
like one song sounds like this one song
sounds like something else the other
song sounds like something else and you
you know your voice is obviously the
same through all of them but it's pretty
interesting that you're able to go this
mode and go that mode and go that other
mode your voice again no offense you
don't have like a ton of range right
you're doing what you're doing yeah and
this is coming from someone that has
zero range yeah I stay in my pocket I
stay in mycket it's cool that you can
take what you do and you can put it in
this kind of song and that kind of song
it works out pretty good man sweating
bro I'm nervous credit bro I'm
embarrassed um so you got that going on
and what else what what am I missing I
don't even know the yeah I don't know
the book that's it I just I I like
we we just about book talked about the
book for a couple
hours no I I just like to write uh and I
just found a lot of like therapeutic
value in the writing and it's just kind
of turned it into a career and it's been
kind of cool what's your process for
writing I'll ask a Tim Ferris question
yeah um so for writing the book I I
first established which chapters I want
to write or kind of like the the broad
Strokes of chapters and then and then
I'll knock out one chapter a time and I
just write like my heart out to all of
it and then uh you know you'll go I'll
go back and say this doesn't fit so I'll
save that in the extra file on my
computer and I just keep writing and
then I'll read over it and I I don't
really read as much as I do I I I
highlight and speak and I hear it and I
hear the flow of it and if it feels like
it doesn't flow well I know there's
something in there I need to change and
so I go back and change it but uh I try
and write from the heart man that's kind
of everything all the songs all the even
the scripts I write I try and write uh
something that that's near and dear to
my heart of of some kind of empathy or
emotion and do you write at the same
time every day when you're writing a
script yeah I usually it's either early
in the morning before the kids wake up
or late at night when they're all asleep
that's kind of like my time to focus and
what's the kid count at this time uh
we're at eight yeah we're done we have
eight kids we're done we're done
quitting huh I don't know if that's
quitting or or trying to be sensible
about the whole thing
Jesus uh what what else so anything else
did we miss anything else I mean I I
know I got your music we know we got
light theuse ltfw wellness.com got
better and by the way everything can be
found at uh on the interweb at Vincent
ROV Vargas doc
yeah so that's but did I miss anything
else no I don't I don't I don't think so
well if if whatever I miss we'll come
back and do it it'd be you know we could
do five more podcasts about little
things that I would dig into from the
book and from your life uh where so the
book is borderline defending the home
front and where can people find you they
got
Instagram Vincent Roco and by the way
you spell Roco wrong r o c not like Joo
j o c KO I know I felt like it was tooo
close to the way you spell it uh Vincent
Rocko Vargas you're on Facebook Vincent
Rocko Vargas and your YouTube channel
that's where you got not only can you
watch your uh Vinnie Rock podcast but
you can also listen to the smooth tones
and comforting music of what do you call
your
band is called Rocko Vargas music I
don't know Rocko Vargas music uh it's
good stuff man it's good stuff uh Echo
Charles yeah you got any questions
plenty but I'm going to keep it kind of
simple um so you ever do you explore AI
tools like for the creative process at
all uh no not as much um I've used AIS
to like construct some kind of like um
like if you're going to post a photo and
I use the AI to help create that
sometimes but for like the business side
of things but not my personal stuff yeah
cuz like you know like songwriting for
example it's becoming more and more
where you can you know like if you like
writing right you can be like hey if you
know how to talk to the AI like you know
how to do prompts or whatever um you can
be like okay I you can creatively write
your song and then ask the AI to kind of
do everything
else and those tools are becoming more
and more I have to check that out robust
yeah I've used AI to help edit a paper
you know what I mean like like a college
paper before CU I'm like God I got to
clean this up oh yeah oh yeah the the
tools are getting more and more like
there's a lot more um I do find though
especially if you're like a c if you've
been a creative person for a long time
you kind of you really notice the lack
of the human element in the creation
that's what I've heard is the big
difference right now it's like it's like
I guess a lot of the writing strike was
because of AI and people were using that
in script writing and supposedly but but
yeah I I tried that out for a script
that I wrote a script about like a dad
and spanking their kids something that I
I'm I'm working on is kind of like the
short to kind of like display the change
of the things have changed right and I
went to AI to have them write it too
just to see yeah see and it was close it
definitely lacked a lot of like the
empathy and the heart and emotion but it
was [__] close and I was like damn
there's some things that they put on
that script that was just exactly what
mine would have been right pretty crazy
I've run some tests with like leadership
questions and and what's interesting for
me is since I have so much content out
there from books and podcasts and
interviews that it can get a really good
uh assessment of the way that I think
right and I would ask it I've asked it
just like the fundamental leadership
questions and what's it's interesting
kind of like you said it'll it'll give a
really it'll give a good answer and not
only does it give a good answer it also
always gives like these really good
well-crafted
caveats things like and we have to
remember that all leadership situations
are different so you have to consider
that when you are applying these tools
so and it'll do that for everything like
you ask it for an exercise program it be
you also have to consider that
everyone's different biologically it so
it's really good at at covering its ass
yeah but on top of like the good answer
and the good caveat it always misses
like a critical component where you're
like Yep this isn't you're not there bro
you're not there AI robot you're not
quite there you're close you're in the
ballpark yeah yeah and I'll tell you why
because usually
like you know how you get a real
creative person that's like an anomaly
right where it's like you know these
guys who Stand Out Elgen James like
there's something about them that's
really unique AI doesn't work like that
AI works the opposite it's like it Ates
everything everything all recorded and
analyzed and be like okay now to answer
your question given everything that the
AI knows and has learned and is going to
continue to learn with all the
information out there so it's the
opposite of anomalous really it's like
let me just like how you said it gives
caveats it's for a reason because it has
all the information yeah you know you
know what be interesting is could you
come up with a prompt not to go freaking
full freaking Lex Freedman where you at
nerd out on this stuff but can you give
it a prom
where it's like in a leadership
situation what would you do here based
on Joo willing principles narrowed down
to eliminate obvious answers and give a
unique yeah uh scenario for this answer
like could you prompt it hard enough
figures AI does well if you're really
good at knowing how to prompt it yeah
and then the more people get good at
prompting the more it can learn for
itself so and that goes for any kind of
computer thing like think of of CGI
right we got like all the simple stuff
is like figured out it's like super easy
right like mechanical stuff even water
is actually more complex than like a
steel kettle bell and then you got a
machine or something like this right
like a refrigerator or something like
that an alien robot alien Rob robots
yeah they can do good but when you when
you try to do really like highly
specifically evolved stuff like a human
face talking and getting sad and mad and
stuff stuff where like however many
years of evolution like tuned us to
understand and recognize or whatever the
AI is like fumbling even now it's really
hard but it it's going to get closer of
course it's going to get closer and
closer and closer and closer for sure
yes but that's that's my whole point
where now if you're like hey I can't
really play many instruments really you
know I know a couple guys who can and
you know whatever but I can write real
good and that's really my passion so
when I make music the writing is really
what's going to kind of spearhead my
whole creative Endeavor I'm going to use
AI for all the other stuff cuz really I
mean you know I just need a guy who can
play guitar I don't need freaking Jimmy
Hendrick over here I just need a guy who
can play guitar cuz the writing is the
the front running element right so you
go AI play a guitar in this style and
just the best you can right and then you
finally tune it with the AI but the
thing you have control over creatively
is the writing and it can kind of build
from there you know you ever listen to
the band The White Stripes yeah yeah so
I was listening to Jack White talk about
the White Stripes right and
basically he's saying listen you go to a
a regular like a modern studio for music
to make an album if you're a person and
for instance they take a snare drum and
they like hit the snare drum a 100 times
and they find the one that like whatever
on the computer showed like the most
rounded resonance and all this other
stuff and that's the one that they use
for the whole drum track the perfect
drum hit on the snare and they do that
for the symbol they do that for the
crash and they do that for the keyboard
and then they do that with a person's
voice and so what you end up with is a
thing that is perfect it's a thing that
perfect and when you hear it look the
nor a normal person when they hear it
they go oh yep sounds great that's why
pop Britney Spears every one of those
scenars everything in her voice
everything is perfectly done and you
know what that kind of makes me think of
a cubic zarcon do you know what a cubic
zarcon is it's a fake diamond and you
know how they can tell it's fake too
perfect because it's too perfect and so
there's a certain for me I get a feeling
when I listen to like really highly
produced music I'm like this isn't a
human and this doesn't have any emotion
to it and that sort of was Jack White's
point of like you can you can feel it
man like even Meg white she's GNA hit
the drum a little different on that
verse than the other verse and it makes
a difference and the way he's playing
guitar and the way he's singing it and
his voice is breaking it's like all
those things are going on and that's why
lad Zeppelin sounds like Leed Zeppelin
or Black Sabbath you're like Black
Sabbath sounds like Black Sabbath they
cut their first album in one shot in8
hours by the end of their careers they
were doing like nine months to record an
album and like everything had so so just
things change and you get more away from
the raw and more into the highly
produced highly refined and for me it
loses value absolutely right especially
from an artistic standpoint and that's
my whole point with the AI where sure
it's going to get better and better and
better and better but it's almost like
it gets better but at the same time can
never get perfect ever it's like if I
get halfway to you every single step
like halfway if I get halfway to you
then another halfway to I never really
get to you that's what it seems that's
what it feels like in the creative stuff
because like I said like a a real
talented artist in one way is very
individual when AI works on everything
it's learned from everything else you
know and then so it's like doing a big
Insight study to see who's like the most
creative yeah there's also going to be a
point where that AI is going to generate
things that are are its own and that are
going to be unique and they're doing
that with art right now like you know
like remember when everyone was posting
pictures they freaking sells AI generate
s h yeah that was just like the ultimate
in uh yeah I guess so look at the
perfect version of me that's what it is
decided to get in the game with the AI
pictures of
myself in case anyone was wondering what
I look like if I was freaking it's
[__] Terminator 240 lbs of you know
blue twisted steel hell yeah but they're
pretty cool though that's I'm saying
there's a uniqueness to them there's a
uniqueness that you're talking about a
lack of uniqueness there's a uniqueness
that's for real that's coming when you
randomly generate what about freaking
artists that throw paint at the freaking
wall yeah but it's coming from it
actually has meaning because yeah cuz
it's coming from a person yeah yeah but
that's it is true so the the computer
generated stuff it's like it's cool and
it's fun and okay so the whole I'm going
to do a AI generated uh version of
myself right the thing that's fun about
that is because it's yourself still you
know and it's the ai's kind of
translation it's fun to see the little
translation and then of course the
perfect version of yourself I get that
part too but like I said it's like a
person is imperfect and so there's a
difference between a perfect I said
too exactly exactly right in fact you
can be technically better but the per
the imperfection is part of a greater
Perfection so so you can't okay if I
want to be a highly individualized
person it comes with a bunch of
imperfections all like almost on an
infinite level where the computer's just
trying to replicate those imperfections
and bro you can tell guess what this I
almost cut you off I had to restrain
myself cuz I really wanted to rest but
when you were talking about Elgen
writing right yeah Elgen when he's
writing when he's directing the
direction of the story the AI generated
solution would be that thing that you're
talking about that kind of like this is
the standard story know going we know
this is going move the emtions this way
move the EMS that way it's going set up
this ending the blah blah blah blah and
he's like no don't do that thing he has
a a look on it that's not a cu the cubic
zarcon no one's watching it yeah or let
me rephrase that because here's the
thing man plenty of people watch cubic
zarconi like uh remember those TV shows
back in the day that that that were like
uh Hallmark specials remember those
right yeah you know what
mom moms watching but it's like it's
like a story that everybody knows the
whole story and hey you ever watch do
you ever get on on Facebook on the
algorithm you'll get like watch these
like six minute movies about like I
don't know they'll be about like I I I
watched one of them one time and I was
like okay I see what this is it was like
a guy and he's like sweeping up and a
guy like drops something and he the
guy's the janitor but then he ends up
being actually the owner it's like that
kind of thing kids have that yeah there
anyway yeah I know those are just
generic those are like AI generated
stories like write a story about a
lesson from someone that and it's like
an AI generated story and people still
watch them a lot of people watch those
but they there's there's the lacking
element like you can go to the club and
you can dance to Britney Spears or one
of these pop people but then you go to a
white stripe show you're you're like
different yeah it's different bro the
cubic zirconia things or whatever
they're still shiny they're super shiny
and oh yeah they're shiny they looks
they sparkle on their they do all that
stuff for sure but if you care like a
you know you're a creative person you
care about other stuff than how much it
shines just like you care about music
more so than how many albums it sold or
how many plays it got on the freaking
radio station or the club or whatever
see what I'm saying and that's what I
anyway at the end of the day I think
that's going to be a massive challenge
for AI to replicate yep I think it's
going to be
interesting cuz it seems like if it
takes enough cracks at it it's going to
figure some [__] out well it's a
freaking one of the I mean it's face is
probably the best well one of the best
tools ever created even for a creative
person cuz it's like a little helper you
know like any like creative like project
when it when it has a bunch of people
some people are better than others
sometimes you just need somebody to go
run and grab that coffee and bring it
back you know so the AI can kind of take
care of a lot of jobs meanwhile if as
long as you have creative control it's
like hey it can be a good tool yep know
we'll see where it goes um so that's my
only question by the way I have a lot of
Border actually have a lot of border
patrol good but bro we'll do another one
do another one uh meanwhile you can see
Rocco's got a lot of stuff going on some
other stuff going on joof fuel joof
fuel.com we got all kinds of stuff going
on at joof fuel.com we got energy drinks
we got hydrate we got greens by the way
do you do you take greens I don't but I
will oh yeah we're going to hook you up
we get on some greens I know why you
don't take greens cuz they freaking suck
most of the time yeah cuz most of the
time they taste like crap yeah I'd
rather eat all the vegetables required
than take most greens for real not but
not this one for real not this one uh
the greens are legit everything's legit
um so check it out joof fuel.com get a
subscription to what you take all the
time like if you take time more all the
time just just get in there also this
stuffs are available in stores vitamin
shop GNC military commissaries Apes
Haniford Dash stores wake for and
shopright HB down in Texas we're there
Texas and we appreciate our people in
Texas we also appreciate our people up
in the in the midwest going to
Meer killing it by the way so thanks to
all of you Harris Teeter Lifetime
Fitness Shields small gyms out there if
you're training in Jiu-Jitsu and you
have a Jiu-Jitsu Academy or you got a
CrossFit gym or you got a powerlifting
gym and you want to sell some of the
goods or you got a bodybuilding gym hell
yeah there you go speaking of which the
Pre-Workout oh this is important to
mention if people don't know the
Pre-Workout is not like the old school
freaking ephedra you know risk your life
for the pump kind of pre-workout it's
like it's good it's not risk your life
for the pump get it get the
pump sometimes though like let's face it
sometimes you need it you know my my my
daughter the other day she' been
training kind of a lot and she still you
know look just cuz you're in jiujitsu
doesn't mean you're not lifting it
doesn't mean you're not getting your
pull-ups in but she told me yesterday
she was like I was tired yesterday I was
like oh that's bummer and she goes I had
to take the Pre-Workout I was like oh
she goes how'd it work she was like
freaking awesome so you can be like that
and you can still get your [__] done oh
yeah in there it's like a slippery slope
in a good way by the way where it's like
okay let me just take this pre-workout
when I'm like just kind of tired then
it's like oh damn that was kind of a
solid little boost and then the day
you're not really that tired but you're
like I could kind of is this how people
get addicted to crystal methamphetamine
kind of it it seems like a similar
pathway yes for sure but at least we're
lifting you know I mean you can and and
at least it's healthy yeah I was going
to say and you won't end up uh dead dead
yeah with no teeth you know and sores
open sores on your face well oh yeah
right you knowy you took pre-workout
before right like old say You Know Jack
3D exactly right okay so when
pre-workout freaking exploded onto the
scene it was like bro Wild Wild West
some meth in there freed they had to b a
bunch of stuff say hey you can't put
that in there anymore cuz guys are dying
you order the [__] that was banned you
had like that shit's good that must be
the good [__] if it's illegal it's good
bro I'm tell yeah it's crazy so like
taking pre-workouts still I think even
now still has kind of that stigma where
it's like yeah I stopped messing with it
because I was nervous about cuz the
heart thing same exact thing that's why
I stopped I was like bro if you say you
got some good [__] I could use some good
[__] do you like it's got 200 milligrams
of caffeine so that's two cups of coffee
maybe two and a half cup cups of coffee
it's not crazy you know some of these
things they're freaking out of control
uh and you got to be careful but even
for me like I don't take pre-workout
normally so I don't need to take a whole
scoop I can take a half a scoop and all
I feel like I'm on cocaine and I've
never even done cocaine before like I
feel like that must be what it feels
like I heard somebody asking Theo Von
the other day like what's your favorite
what do you say what's your favorite
kind of pot or something like that and
he's like probably
cocaine I was like
d keeping it
real bro that guy is freaking awesome I
met him at UFC event he's he's freaking
hilarious uh okay also origin usa.com
hey you guys just picked up a UFC deal
yes we did I you like that [__] it's
freaking outstanding that's so pumped so
cool to see um if you didn't catch this
news uh we partnered with the UFC we
partnered with the Ultimate Fighting
Championship that's freaking
I watch every single weekend man I love
it and I'm glad you guys are part of
that and and let me tell you straight up
the Dana White the team at UFC they
wanted to partner with us not not saying
they like I'm I'm not trying to make it
sound out of balance but they could
partner with anybody right they they get
to decide who they partner with it's not
so the fact that they looked at our
company they love what we're doing
they're patriotic they support America I
mean Dana obviously supports American
companies and things being made in
America so it was just awesome that it
all came together and yeah super stoked
origin usa.com I forgot we used we use
origin shirts for better and for the
light the fuse W hell yeah everything
yeah hell yeah for the same reason yeah
got freaking made in America uh geese
you said you're starting to change your
again yeah I just signed up again yeah
so we need to get you a ghee maybe a
couple GES or you a no G guy no no no
I'm I need to learn the ghee dude I've
done enough Noe that I'm I've been
hiding from ghee I need to get in ghe it
definitely when you if you don't do it
or if you haven't done it it's really
really annoying like you can see you
train with a wrestler that's never worn
ghe
before their whole life is frustrating
yeah I need it I've been avoiding the
ghee for so long I need it um so we got
everything at origin what else did you
origin usa.com jeans boots jeans boots
all day all day geese workout gear the
whole nine yards man all made 100% in
America bringing manufactur back to
America so that's awesome the hoodies
are nice the hoodies are Deluxe the
hoodies are the hoodies are Deluxe
freaking good to go right made right
here what else it's true Joo store Joo
store called Joo store discipline equals
Freedom good def core all this it it's
you know it has a what do you staying
power see what I'm saying the name for
real oh yeah but yeah you want to
represent discipline equals Freedom
that's where you get it also we have the
shirt Locker Rock I don't know if you
know about this shirt lockers a new
shirt every month different designs
anytime you see like something like
discipline equals Freedom me kind of but
not quite as serious or maybe a little
bit more creative if you will by the way
not AI generated key because if it was
AI generated we know what it would do we
would it's actually interesting people
will like give that's a term I use now
like if someone answers a question or
someone makes a statement about me I'm
like oh that's an AI generated like
opinion of me like it's like AI
generated opin of what to do at the
border like oh this is the talking
points that they read like here you go
here's the here's the you know answer
well and then there's a caveat that says
of course there are some details on that
right so don't get an AI generated
t-shirt is not AI generated get an echo
Charles generated t-shirt up in this
pieace i' say it's I'd say it's
generated by the community I would say
the people that are on the path you know
they all have their own influence on
these specific designs every month by
the way I didn't say that there you go
boom that's how Jole store it's called
the short Locker but it's at Jo
store.com now that name shirt Locker s
Hur t locker that came from the people
came from the community exactly like
what do we call this thing someone's
like shirt Locker D nailed it send it
yeah exactly and yeah so there you go
choc store.com Primal beef Primal beef
get yourself some grass-fed and fruit
and grain finished yep got that I had I
had so normally I'm a ribey guy what
about you ribeye yeah ribeye 100% right
I I would say but I did get the New York
strip that's where I had bro and how's
how's this to um and I text Sean glass
as this is happening so I got the I got
the New York strip I had three of them I
only had one left from the from the
Primal and then the other two from a
different company I'm not going to say
but I was like okay let me put Shan
glass to the test here look I'm not
going to go tell everyone If he if he
loses or whatever so I do them I prepare
him literally exact same way literally
the exact same way and I can already see
before I cook them I'm like I already
see the difference but whatever you know
that's that's no proof the proof is
afterwards see what I'm saying cook him
up exactly the same way by far too yeah
by far Prime will be yeah that thing
good so I normally look I'm not like a
okay I'm a snake snob a steak snob like
give me a riy bro that's what I'm
talking about but you know had that had
that New York which normally New York
doesn't do it for me yeah it's kind of
like whatever is cool but dude this New
York was money bro agree money tastes
good uh so there you go Primal beef
Primal beef.com get yourself some get
yourself some meat also check out
Colorado craft beef.com those things
freaking tasty so we got options for you
look you can't live on MK alone well may
you can't well probably can't but you
may need to supplement your supplements
with
steak so go to Primal beef.com go to
colorcraft beef.com awesome people make
an awesome steak for us out here here
subscribe to the podcast we got Jo
underground.com uh check that out $818 a
month if you can't afford it it's okay
we got you we want you to be here with
us on the Underground so go to jock
underground.com check out that little
alternative podcast that we do got a
YouTube channel Joo podcast is that it
yep official I think Joo podcast
official you know you're gonna see it we
got uh joof fuel.com they're putting
their own spin on things put a bunch of
really cool they got Danielle Kelly yeah
dude Danielle Kelly girl tried to can
open her in one you know what I'm
talking about I know what a can opener
is I know so a girl's trying to can
opener Danielle Kelly and Danielle Kelly
just like Maneuvers and gets the girl's
back and chokes her salute to Daniel
Kelly they got stuff with her b nickel
by the way she dope yeah dude dope watch
I watched him his whole college career
yeah yeah he's freaking legit and he's
that's good work let just come and take
over the but you know he's Joo fuel go
and so he's getting after he's also
sponsored by jonco podcast by the way
you know that I did I did know that yeah
okay just just making sure you I'm in
the uh so yeah check out those YouTube
and origin USA has the YouTube thing and
don't forget you got you got Vinnie Rock
YouTube channel you can check that out
how often you posting something on there
uh we're trying to go four four uh four
times a month four episodes which still
we're still getting in all all the
guests going on I got a um a brain uh
went to a brain clinic for TBI and Dr G
she's going to be on on the 20th I'm
excited about that and then Flo Grover
uh the metal H recipient he's be damn
right on he's goingon to be on soon I'll
connect you with him dude he's he's just
dope dude really good dude yeah bro
remember I said like when you went into
the recruiter and then the recruiter saw
you and he's like sees you like I'm
waiting for my ride he's like you look
like a steak yeah imagine when dudes
like you and me walk into like the TBI
clip
oh let me see your background you're
like I did this this and this like you
look like a steak they want to get their
hands on you and figure out what the
hell's going what's rattled up in there
uh so check out those YouTube things we
got psychological warfare we got
Flipside canvas Dakota Meer speaking of
Metal of Honor recipients he's got cool
stuff to hang on your wall Flipside
canvas.com check that out books we got a
bunch of books number one of course
borderline defending the home front by
Vincent Roco Vargas get that it's coming
out on Joo press by the way is it's kind
of a new thing that's going down this is
the first book on jao press different
from jaal publishing yeah how's it
different it's different because we're
in League
with St Martin's press oh so we're we're
we're helping them and they're helping
us in order to get Mass
distribution and help on it's it's it's
a coordination of efforts so I have a
great relationship with St Martin's
press and eventually you know some of
the books and some of the people that I
talk to and know I know that I couldn't
deliver what they might need for a book
and this is one of those books I mean
this book is everyone should be reading
this book if you live in America you
should be reading this book um if you
live overseas you can still get
information from it as well because you
actually you actually have content in
there me you have Spanish content in
there like a whole section about how to
actually legally uh become a citizen
become a citizen so you got all kinds of
stuff so that's what Joo press is it's
sort of
an imprint of St Martin's press so
that's a new thing we got a few more
books coming out in the near future on
that that I think people are going to be
excited about but this is the first one
dude number one yeah I was excited about
that honored let's rock and roll man
honor is all mine um so that book then
you know I've written a bunch of books
you can get those books you can check
out those books uh you know what they
are check out those Warrior kid books
I'm just saying I'm just saying ashon
front we solve problems through
leadership go to ASF front.com for
details if you want to come next up is
Dallas I'm leaving for Dallas that event
will be over by the time this comes out
but it's been sold out for months we
crammed in we reorganized seats we did
everything we could but it sold out so
if you want to come to one of our events
go to ason front.com get some details if
you need help inside your organization
we work with companies we work with the
largest companies in the world and we
work with a lot of very small businesses
and everything in between so if you need
help inside your organization with
leadership go to conf front.com
we also have an online Training Academy
leadership is the most important factor
in business in life in family everything
that you're doing is leadership so learn
how to lead if you want to improve every
aspect of your life go to extrem
ownership. comom we have a curriculum
that has been developed over the past 17
years that will help you learn how to
lead in all situations also if you want
to help service members active and
retired you want to help their families
you want to help gold star families
check out Mark Le's mom mama Lee She's
Got an incredible charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved in that go to americaas Mighty
warriors.org also check out Heroes and
horses. org mic aink my brother I don't
know what he's doing right now but you
know that there
is Big Sky Montana activities happening
dude the last time I talked to him he's
like yeah just got I had to go down to
Wyoming and brand 1,200 freaking cows
out on the ranch on yeah I mean he's
just getting after it dude I want to go
next time let him know hey if you really
want to go to his thing I would love to
do you know what his thing is it's 41
days they go out into the mountains like
I've heard living off of horses yeah I
would love to I I want to do it I I want
to do it when I'm like I want to be
older though cuz I it takes a 41 days
bro you know that's a lot a lot that's a
lot 41 days not on the calendar right
now um but at some point yeah so check
that out uh Heroes and horses. org also
Jimmy May's got that beyondthe
brotherhood. org helping guys transition
out of the military um if you want to
connect with us on the on the
interwebs well you can do that uh
Vincent ROV Vargas dcom Instagram
Vincent ROV Vargas Facebook Vincent roov
Vargas YouTube Vinnie
Rock and uh Echo is that Echo Charles I
am at what am I at I am at Joo willink
just watch out because the algorithm's
there and you know what that algorithm's
going to try and do um it's G to try and
it's G to try and Crush you so there you
go um Rocco you got any closing thoughts
anything else no man I just excited for
people to kind of check out this book I
think it's going to be one of the
biggest books for military who
transitioned out of the military looking
for a new career I think it's going to
be good for the retention of the border
patrol as well as the recruitment for
the border patrol and just for the
average person want to really understand
what the board Patrol career field is so
they have a better Foundation of what
immigration entails so yeah well I'm
glad you wrote the book thanks for
coming on uh thanks for sharing your
lessons and thanks for all the things
you're bringing in the world today you
know the the the art the books the
movies the music the podcasts everything
you're bringing in the world thank you
and um of course thanks for your service
to our great nation in the army in the
Rangers thanks for protecting our
freedom overseas and thanks for
protecting our borders here at
home
and thanks to everybody out there in the
Army Navy Air Force Marines and a
special appreciation today for the
Rangers living that life that Spartan
life Rangers lead the way and we salute
you all also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers Secret
Service and all first respon responders
thank you all for your service here at
home with a distinct salute to our
border patrol thank you for what you all
do every day to protect our border and
our way of life and everyone else out
there you don't really know what you're
capable
of you don't know you don't you don't
know what your limits are and you know
what you don't always end up on the
right path
you
don't sometimes you have to shift gears
sometimes you have to change directions
and that takes courage and that takes
commitment it takes courage to walk away
from what you know and commitment to
succeed in the
unknown
but like Rocco like
Vinnie if you work hard if you push
yourself if you give it everything you
got you can not only ch your
dreams but you can catch them and make
them a
reality so if you have something that
you want to do go out there and get
after it and until next time this is
Roco and Eko and
Joo
out